COMMITTEES ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE AND BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS-
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE WITH US
HERE ON THIS THANKSGIVING WEEK.
TODAY'S HEARING FOCUSES ON THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER THE STATE
WHETHER THE STATE SHOULD
ESTABLISH ITS OWN PUBLIC BANK.
THIS HEARING FOLLOWS UP ON A
PREVIOUS HEARING FROM THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND CHOOSE LEGISLATION
FROM EARLIER IN THE YEAR WHICH
WE HELD IN AUGUST. THE
COMMITTEE AT THAT TIME HAD A
ROBUST DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
WITH THE COMMITMENT THAT WE
WOULD TAKE THAT DEEPER DIVE IN
THE FALL AND WELCOME TO THE
DEEPER DIVE LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN. THE PROPOSAL THAT IS
IN FRONT OF US IT'S AMBITIOUS
FOR THE STATE TO ESTABLISH ITS
OWN PUBLIC BANK ESPECIALLY IN
THESE CHALLENGING TIMES MAY
PROVE TO BE DIFFICULT. BUT ONE
ONE THAT DESERVES OUR ATTENTION
AND THE NECESSARY HARD WORK TO
WRESTLE WITH THE COMPLEXITIES
OF PRISONS. THERE IS A
POTENTIAL HERE A POTENTIAL HERE
FOR DOING GOOD WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE HONORED TO JOIN WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD THE CHAIR OF
THE BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS COMMITTEE ALONG
WITH THIS COMMITTEE MEMBERS. TO
CONSIDER THESE ISSUES. WE'RE
GOING TO FOUR PANELS TODAY
CONSISTING OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
IN PUBLIC BANKING ADVOCATES
STATE CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS
AS WELL AS REPRESENTATIVES FROM
STATE AGENCIES IN. INDUSTRIES
DIFFICULT.WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING TODAY'S
TESTIMONY AND WANTED TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO HAS AGREED TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY AND WE WANT
TO SAY A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO
EACH OF THE MEMBERS. FOR
JOINING US ON THEIR
THANKSGIVING WEEK. I WOULD NOW
LIKE TO COVER SOME HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS THAT WILL HELP GOVERN
TODAY'S HEARING. IN RESPONSE TO
THE COPING NINETEEN MERGING SEA
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING SITTING
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE. PROCESS WE'RE
GONNA BE HOLDING COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WERE IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS
THIS MORNING WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. TODAY WE HAVE TODAY
WE HAVE EIGHT MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WE WANT
TO SAY GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
TO SENATORS CABALLERO SENATOR
HERTZBERG OUR MAJORITY LEADER.
SENATOR HUESO SENATOR HER TADO
SENATOR NIELSEN SENATOR
PORTANTINO SENATOR WIENER IN
THE MORNING TO CENTER TORONTO.
IN THE SENATE CHAMBER WITH ME
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO SEE CHAIR OF
THE BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS COMMITTEE SENATOR
BRADFORD AS WELL AS THE VICE
CHAIR OF GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE. MR MORLOCK. I WOULD
NOW LIKE TO TALK ABOUT. PRICE
FOR THOSE HER. REMOTELY ON JUNE
TODAY THOSE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. PLEASE
MAKE IT MEET YOUR PHONES OR
YOUR COMPUTER'S THIS IS GOING
TO GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. AND
ASSET EVERY TIME THAT YOU WISH
TO BE RECOGNIZE THAT YOU USED
TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN
THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WE WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT THE ON MUTE. BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. THAT WE WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO OUR I. T.
PERSONNEL THEY'RE GOING TO PUT
YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE
DONE WITH YOUR WORDS. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU WILL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. IN THEY'LL
BE YOU ARE ALSO GOING TO BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE OR RISK
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFIED TO THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. IF YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO JOIN US IN VIA PHONE HERE IS
A PHONE NUMBER ND WE WELCOME
YOU TO CALL. EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE TO PROVIDE
A COMMENT VIA PHONE TODAY
PLEASE DIAL ONCE AGAIN. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR THE ACCESS CODE
IS. SIX ZERO FIVE SEVEN SIX
FIVE THREE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE STATE SENATE AND
OR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITES.
PRETTY DAY'S HEARING WE'RE
GONNA BE HEARING ALL THE PANELS
OF WITNESSES ON THE AGENDA
PRIOR TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT. ONCE WE'VE HEARD OF
THE WITNESSES WILL HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON THE
TOPICS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
IS AWARE WE HAVE A HARD OUT A
HARD OUT OF THE SENATE CHAMBERS
AT ONE PM DUE TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TODAY. SO WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO WATCH THE CLOCK IN
AT SENATOR. BRADFORD NINE
YOU'RE NOT TRYING TO BE RUDE
BUT WE WILL BE KEEPING TO FOR
EACH OF THE PAN. WELL IT EFFORT
HAS BEEN IS. HEARING FOR.
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS. AS CLOSE TO
THE MANNER IS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO WERE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. WE'RE TO GO
SLOW BUT STEADY. IT'S GONNA BE
GREAT HEARING AND AGAIN THANK
YOU ALL FOR JOINING US. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE INTO
THOSE ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. WOULD NOW LIKE TO
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO CHEER
BRADFORD. FOR BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
COMMITTEE. MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOUR PARTNERSHIP
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR FOR
OPENING COMMENTS. THANK YOU
CHEER MCGUIRE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY COME BEFORE YOU IN
A JOINT PROCESS TO DISCUSS
PUBLIC BANKING. I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE WITNESSES WHO WILL
TESTIFY TODAY FOR YOUR
EXPERTISE. WERE HONORED TO HAVE
A STATED TO CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS WHO WILL PARTICIPATE
IN THIS. HEARING AS WELL AS
DIRECTOR OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION INNOVATION- THAT
WILL. PROVIDE THEIR EXPERTISE
AS WELL. I ALSO WANT TO THANK-
THE BANKING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SENATOR CAFIERO DORADO AND
PORTANTINO FOR JOINING US.
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE JOINED BY SENATOR HUESO
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S HAD A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE OF DOING
LEGISLATION. OVER DURING HIS
TENURE IN THE LEGISLATURE ON
THIS PUBLIC BANKING ISSUE SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO. GETTING HIS
INPUT IN THE FUTURE- I'M GLAD
WE'RE HOLDING THIS HEARING
TODAY ALLOWS US AGAIN TO. BOB
LOOK AT PUBLIC BREAKING-
WITHIN- THE JURISDICTION OF-
YOUR COMMITTEE MR MAGUIRE'S
WELLS MALAI- IT'S SPORTING
AGAIN TO HEAR WHAT OUR
WITNESSES HAVE TO SAY- UP AS WE
KNOW COLBERT- LIMITED A LOT OF
WHAT WE WERE DOING LAST YEAR WE
WERE AND DID NOT ALLOW ME
SENATE BANKING TO HEAR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. OF SANTIAGO'S AB THREE
TEN A LAS YEAR SO IT'S NO DOUBT
WE'LL SEE MORE LEGISLATION IN
THIS AREA IN THE COMING-
LEGISLATIVE YEAR. AND I COME AS
WELL AS MY COLLEAGUES WOULD
OPEN MIND HERE DISCUSSION THAT
WILL BE BROUGHT FORTH TODAY-
I'VE BEEN A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF- ME GETTING IN THE STATE
BEHIND LOCAL- COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND SMALL BUSINESS
FINANCING AND- OTHER LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TOOLS- THEY HELP
US SMALL BUSINESSES. AS WE KNOW
NOT EVERYONE IN EVERY COMMUNITY
IN CALIFORNIA HAS EQUAL SHOT AT
ECONOMIC SUCCESS PRIME EXAMPLE
IS THE NUMBER OF UNBANKED
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE HAVE- THAT
CLEARLY DEMONSTRATES THE NEED
FOR. OTHER TOOLS. TO BE
AVAILABLE ALL. INVOLVED THE
STATE IN A THAT IN OUT FOR.
FROM EQUITY PERCENTTO
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL SHOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF- A PUBLIC TO
DEPOSITORY COULD BE ONE WAY TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL IT COULD ALSO
BE THAT A NON DEPOSITORY STATE
RUN FINANCIAL AUTHORITY MIGHT
BE A BETTER WAY TO GO AS WELL-
AGAIN I'M INTERESTED IN HEARING
THE PROS AND CONS OF BOTH
APPROACHES AND I THINK THIS
YEAR WILL PROVIDE SOME HELPFUL
INFORMATION AND ALLOWING US TO
MOVE FORWARD NEXT YEAR SO.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
FRAZIER WE LOVE WORKING WITH
YOU WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP SIR
THANK YOU DEAR COMMITTEE AND
ALWAYS GOOD TO BE ABLE TO
PARTNER THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU CHAIR. LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
NOT GOING TO TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR OF
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE FOR
OPENING COMMENTS BUT BEFORE HE
DOES WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE AT
SENATOR MORLOCK THIS IS GOING
TO BE CENTER MORLOCKS LAST
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE MEETING FOR NOW- AND
WE WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO BE
ABLE TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
SENATOR FOR HIS SERVICE. AND
IT'S HARD WORK AT SERVING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA CENTER
MORE LOCK IS ONE OF THE MOST
DILIGENT MEMBERS HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SEN. HE
SUCCESSFUL AT HIS JOB BECAUSE
IT'S PERSONAL TO HIM. HE READS
EVERYTHING AND I MEAN EVERY
DETAIL IN THE STAFF REPORT AYE
HE'S INCREDIBLY HARD WORKING
ANY IS DEDICATED TO THE JOB
HERE IN THE SENATE. HE'S ALWAYS
CURIOUS HE ASKS SOME OF THE
MOST INTELLIGENT QUESTIONS THAT
I'VE SEEN IN OUR COMMITTEES
HE'S ALWAYS ON TIME AND IN FACT
MANY TIMES. HE'S THE FIRST
PERSON IN THE ROOM. HE'S ALWAYS
PREPARE. NOW I DON'T KNOW YOU
KNOW THIS BUT HE'S ALL CP. IN
THE FOR TREASURER TO COLLECTOR
IN ORANGE. HE'S OPEN MINDED. IN
ONE OF THE THINGS I APPRECIATE
MOST ABOUT SENATOR MORE LOCK.
IS THAT WHEN THERE IS A
CHALLENGING ISSUE YOU COULD GO
ALWAYS GO TO HIM TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE A CASE. FINNEMORE LOCK WE
ARE GOING TO MISS YOU SIR- YOU
HAVE BEEN WONDERFUL TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH EACH AND EVERY
DAY. OUR TIME TOGETHER ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE NOT ONLY
HAVE I ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATIONS I'VE ENJOYED OUR
PARTNERSHIP TRULY. AND AS I
SAID TO YOU HERE A FEW WEEKS
AGO- I AM JUST SO GRATEFUL FOR
THE TIME THAT WE HAVE SPENT
TOGETHER SIR. BUT BEFORE WE
TURN IT OVER TO YOU IF IT
WORKS- THROUGH. SENATOR
BRADFORD THE CHAIR OF. THE
INKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS- I'D LIKE TO BE TO
TURN IT OVER AND I KNOW THIS IS
A BIT EXTRAORDINARY TO. CALLING
GRINNELL WHO'S THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT FOR GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE TO BE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS- IS WELL NEVER GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO SENATOR MORLOCK.
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT. IF WE
CAN I RECOGNIZE AT. THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT BACK PLEASE. IT'S
BEEN A GOOD EMMA OKAY CENTER
MORLOCK I JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS ON BEHALF OF THE STAFF
OF THE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE OUR APPRECIATION FOR
WORKING WITH YOU FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS- IT HAS BEEN AN
HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE WE'LL
NEVER FORGET WHEN YOU CAME
PHYSICALLY TO OUR OFFICE TO
CORRECT A GRAMMATICAL REFERENCE
IN ONE OF THE OMNIBUS BILLS
WHICH WE TOOK AS A WAY TO TALK
IS AN HONOR SO. GOOD LUCK TO
YOU SIR WE WILL MISS YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MUCH FOR SERRANO.
WITH FURTHER ADO AND TO GET A
TURN IT OVER. VICE CHAIR MARLA
MR BY CHAIR. THANK YOU AND HAVE
YOUR DOWN WE HAVE A PARTING
GIFT ON BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE
COMMITTEE. MISTER VICE CHAIR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
SENATOR MCGUIRE I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO. RESPOND A LITTLE. IT'LL
CHOKED UP BUT IT HAS BEEN AN
EXTREME HONOR. TO WORK AS YOUR
VICE CHAIR- YOU ARE INCREDIBLE
SENATOR- AND LEADER AND- ONE OF
THE MOST- IMPRESSIVE.
PRESIDENTS WHEN WE DO FLOOR
SESSIONS YOU HAVE- YOUR STAR
AND I AM HUMBLED AND HONORED BY
YOUR KIND REMARKS. I WANT TO
THANK CONGRESS L. AS WELL BEEN
HONORED TO WORK WITH YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE- YOU'VE ALWAYS
BEEN ACCESSIBLE. AND WE WE'VE
HAD FUN TOGETHER SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH I'VE BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE FOR SIX YEARS AND-
IT'S BEEN ONE OF MY FAVORITE SO
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR WHEN I
WAS YOUNG. AB AND MARRIED TO A
BEFORE KIDS WE NVESTED IN A
NEW BANK. AND IT WAS A PRETTY
CONSERVING INVESTMENT OUT OF
THE SMALL LITTLE PORTFOLIO WE
WERE BUILDING AT THE TIME- BUT
IT WAS A FINE VENTURE- ONLY TO
WATCH AFTER A COUPLE YEARS
THAT- YOU KNOW A COUPLE OF THE
LOANS THAT THEY MADE ACTUALLY
FAILED AND THEY WERE
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH. THAT THE
BANK AT THE CLOSE AND WE HAD
GOOD OLD FDIC AND ALL KINDS OF
FUN STUFF WAY BACK IN. THAT
TIME IN HISTORY WHERE BANKS FOR
FAILING. SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
A PUBLIC BANK- I CERTAINLY
HAVE. A PERSONAL SCARS- OF A OF
AN INVESTMENT IN IN IN SUCH AN
ENDEAVOR KNOWING THAT THEY ARE
NOT. MASSIVE PROFIT MAKING
VENTURES AND COULD HAVE A LOT
OF DOWNSIDE. AS YOU MENTIONED I
WAS THE TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR
FOR THE COUNTY OF ORANGE. AND
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS I DID
WAS TRY TO FORM A BANK BECAUSE-
AT THE BANKS IN THE AREA THE
LARGE BANKS DID NOT WANT
WELFARE RECIPIENTS- IN THEIR
LOBBIES. THEY JUST WANT TO CASH
THE CHEQUES. THEY DIDN'T WNT
THE DIRTY DIAPERS AND ALL THAT
THAT ALL THE THINGS IGOT TO
HEAR ABOUT WHY THEY SHOULD NOT.
BE DOING OUR- A CHECK CASHING
SO YOU HAVE FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE SHOW UP ON A MONDAY- WE
HAD ONE BRANCH THAT WAS IN THE
STORE A GROCERY STORE AND IF IT
BLOCK CUSTOMERS FROM GOING INTO
THE STORE SO THEY SET UP A VAN
IN THE PARKING LOT. CASH
WELFARE CHECKS AND CHARGE THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE A PRETTY STEEP
SOME. FOR THAT PRIVILEGE EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS. NOT OUR FAULT
THAT THE BRANCH WAS INSIDE A
GROCERY STORE. SO WE HAD FUN
WITH THE STATE BANKING
INSTITUTION THE FDIC- WE WORK
PUT TOGETHER A BUSINESS PLAN
WORK WITH OUR LOCAL- BANKS- AND
WE FORMED A ROOF WE WERE IT WAS
SO CLOSE TO ACTUALLY DOING
SOMETHING JUST BECAUSE WE
WANTED TO HELP THOSE WHEN. THEY
WERE DEALING WITH THE SOCIAL
SERVICES AGENCY. BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY MISTER CHAIR. OF WE
WERE GOING TO SAVE ABOUT A
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN FEES
AND COSTS BY CONVERTING AND I
AND SETTING UP OWN BANK BUT- WE
FOUND OUT THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REIMBURSES 80% OF.
COSTS FOR SOCIAL SERVICES SO
WE'RE ONLY GOING TO MAKE A
PROFIT OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND.
DOLLARS A YEAR AND THAT WOULD
BE AFTER ALL THE AUDITS ALL THE
STAFF AND ALL THE WORK. AND SO
IT JUST DIDN'T SEEM TO PENCIL
OUT. SATISFACTORILY AND SO I'M
I'M I WANT TO KEEP AN OPEN
MIND- ON TODAY'S DISCUSSION BUT
I HAVE A REAL. CONCERN WHEN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR. GETS INTO THE
BUSINESS THAT IS. NORMALLY
CONDUCTED BY THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. AND I GET NERVOUS WHEN
THERE'S A CHANCE THAT THERE
COULD BE LOSSES IN THERE FOR
THE TAXPAYERS WOULD HAVE TO
SUBSIDIZE YOUR BAILOUT OR-
WHATEVER CAN HAPPEN SO. I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION BUT I I'VE SORT OF
HAD PERSONAL EXPERIENCES. THAT
HAVE. YOU KNOW MADE AN
IMPRESSION ON ON ON MY
THINKING. BUT AGAIN I JUST
WANNA THANK EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN
AN HONOR TO SERVE THESE LAST
FIXTURES IN THE STATE SENATE
WANTED BANK CENTER BRADFORD IS
JUST BEEN CONSUMMATE GENTLEMAN
AS WELL- IN THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
ON TIME CAUCUSES ONE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE THAT'S- ON- ZOOM- IT'S
BEEN A GREAT PLEASURE TO BECOME
YOUR FRIENDS AND WORK WITH YOU
AND I I'M MOST GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
VICE CHAIR- AND- BEFORE WE COME
BACK TO YOU SIR I'D LIKE TO BE
TO TURN IT OVER TO. MISTER.
CHAIR CENTER BRADFORD. I THINK.
CHAIRMAN I TO JUST WANT TO SAY
WITH CENTER MORE LOCK FOR THE
LOS FOUR YEAR. YOUR J. YOUR
SCHOLAR YOUR DO. MAN THAT.
APPROACHED JOB ENTAIL. WITH
THOUGHTFUL. AND COLLABORATION
AND AS WE OFTEN SAY. ELECTIONS
HAVE CONSEQUENCES UNFORTUNATELY
THIS IS ONE THAT. UNFORTUNATE
CONSEQUENCE OF ELECTIONS
BECAUSE- YOUR VOICE IS NEEDED
HERE AND IT'S BEEN APPRECIATED
AND- IT'S GOING TO BE MISSED.
AND I ENJOYED FOR THE LAST FOUR
YEARS- SURE IN THE HALLWAY
WE'RE ON SEPT FLOOR AND- MORE
WALKING INTO YOUR OFFICE
ANYTIME ALWAYS HAD OPEN DOOR
AND YOU WERE IN THE OFFICE. ONE
AND NO ONE ELSE IS THERE AYE
IT'S ON THE TO GIVE OUR TIME TO
AND- HE'S ALWAYS TO. GIVE IT
RIGHT BACK TO ME AS WELL AND-
AGAIN WE'VE OF A ONE THING I
APPRECIATE MOST IS HIS TIME
VALUE AND I'M HAPPY AND I ARE
ALWAYS- WE PRIDED OURSELVES
ALWAYS BEEN ON TIME AND LEAD. A
FRIENDLY COMPETITION BUT IT WAS
JUST. INVOLVED THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE DO SO I'M GOING TO MISS.
WONDERING WHO'S GOING TO BEAT
ME TO THE FLOOR ON THE ERROR-
COMMITTEE- IN THE NEXT SECTION
BUT AGAIN I APPRECIATE- THE
RELATIONSHIP BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY I APPRECIATE
FRIENDSHIP ANNA I LOOK FORWARD
TO. BIGGER AND BETTER THINGS IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER- ON THE OF THE ENTIRE
GOVERNANCE FINANCE COMMITTEE
WE'D LIKE TO BE A PRESENT A
VERY SMALL TOKEN OF OUR
APPRECIATION OF THE VICE CHAIR.
FIRST AND FOREMOST- MISTER VICE
CHAIR WE GOT YOU A- GREAT
BOTTLE OF- CINEMA COUNTY YOU
KNOW FROM ONE OF THE BEST SAINI
AT RANCH HERE- IS INCHING DOWN
OLD VINE ZINFANDEL WHICH WILL
PROVIDE YOU AFTERWARDS. IT A
TRADITION HERE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCES A LOT OF CANDY- AND SO
WE GOT. MR MORLOCK HIS OWN BAG
OF CANDY AND THAT HE IS GOING
TO BE ABLE TO CHOW DOWN ON OVER
THAT COMING FEW DAYS. ONE OF
THE BEST MEMORIES WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT AND THE VICE
CHAIR IS WHEN SENATOR NGUYEN
WAS SERVING ON THE COMMITTEE
AND THE VICE CHAIR WAS THROWING
CANDY TO HER CHILDREN AND- HIT
PERSONER WINDS GET IN THE HEAD
WITH A PIECE OF CHOCOLATE HE
DIDN'T KNOW WAS COMING IN. SO
THOSE OF THAT LIGHT HEARTED
TIME AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AT VERY
GRATEFUL AND AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE. THAT SOME
WINE AND SOME CHOCOLATE AND WE
ARE SO APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
AMAZING WORK SIR. PLEASE MR
RICE HERE. I RECOGNIZE YOUR DID
YOU TO PAY FOR I JUST TO SIT
THERE YOU VERY MUCH. SENATE
MCGUIRE YOU'RE YOU'RE YOUR
FIRST CLASS. FIVE START TOPIC
CABIN BY YOU'RE JUST BEEN GREAT
TO WORK WITH I WILL MISS YOU
DEEPLY AB ARE GONNA MISS YOU
SIR NO YOU'RE NOT GONNA GO FAR
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH. BUT MR
VICE CHAIR. LACING GENTLEMEN-
BOTH COMMITTEES WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE INTO
OUR FIRST PANEL THE FIRST PANEL
IS TITLED THE CASE FOR CREATING
A STATE PUBLIC BANK. THE FIRST
PANEL WILL BE A TOTAL OF TWENTY
FIVE MINUTES WERE RIGHT NOW AT
NINE THIRTY. WE'RE FIRST GOING
TO HEAR FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MIGUEL SANTIAGO AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVID CHIU. THEY'RE
GONNA BE PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW
IN OPENING REMARKS. ON BEHALF
OF THIS PANEL WE'RE THEN GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO A MY AT
POWER HE'S HE OPEN SAID HE'S
WITH THE OPEN SOCIETY
FOUNDATIONS OF PUBLIC BANKING
INSTITUTE. ADVISORY BOARD
MEMBER AND HE'S A FORMER
ALDERMAN IN THE CITY OF
CHICAGO- AFTER THAT WE'RE GONNA
THEN HEAR FROM MARK HERBERT
MARC FAERBER. IS VICE PRESIDENT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY WE DO HAVE
TWO OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
ON THE LINE HERE TODAY. THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE HAT'S
RACHEL TORRANCE AND SHE SHE'LL
JACOB WITHOUT FURTHER ADO
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO. AND IS A MEMBER CHU
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY TO.
ESPECIALLY SOME MEMBERS
SANTIAGO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP SURE SIR. THAT YOU
ARE NOTHING BUT- WONDERFUL TO
WORK WITH- AND WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP. DECEMBER
SANTIAGO THE FLOOR IS YOURS- IN
THIS PANEL HAS TWENTY FIVE
MINUTES THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MEMBER. THEY WILL GO TO SOME
NUMBER TWO. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR A LONG US TO PER
TODAY AND ONE TO. EMPHASIZE
THAT AM GRATEFUL TO THE
PARTNERS THAT YOU DO COMMITTEE
PROVIDED US- THE SENATE A WHOLE.
I AND- MR CHU WHO REALLY-
REALLY BEEN A. AN INCREDIBLE TO
WORK WITH. HIM WORKED THE FIRST
PUBLIC BANK BILL IN THE- IS
LET'S. AND THE AYE AYE I'M NOT
YOU KNOW SUCCESS ONE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. ADJUSTABLE LOCAL PUB
BANKS. DOESN'T DOES NUMBER
PEOPLE WANT TO STAY OUR- BESIDE
YOURSELF WHO REALLY HELPED US
TO MAKE IT A SOLID- AND-
EVENTUALLY GOT IT WILL
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND WAS ABLE BE
SIGNED. YOU ARE. HOW VALUE IT
WASN'T HOW MUCH WE NEEDED AT
THE TIME. IT'S MORE TODAY. A
MISTER BRAD TO. WHO THROUGH THE
HIS COMMITTEE GAVE STOCK FOR
INPUT THAT MADE IT THE BEST. AS
STRONG AS- YOU KNOW I COULD
CONTINUE FINANCED MR. RELEASE A
SIGNIFICANT OF TIME. HELPING
DESTROY IN THE IN BRING IN
STATE. TOGETHER IN I'M HOPE-
HOPE THIS- NEXT SUCH THAT WE
CAN MEAN ON EXPERT AGAIN GET
THE- VALUABLE- ABOUT MEANS THAT
YOU HAD WITH US STAY COOL. LED
TO A THAT COULD BE SIGNED IN
AMPLE THE LINO YOU ONE TIME IT
WOULD BE. VALUABLE FOR TO BE
ABLE TO THAT. MISTER HERTZBERG.
WHO ASK ALL MILLION DOLLAR
QUESTION. AND REALLY US THINK
OF ABOUT PROCESS BECAUSE WE ONE
OF. GONE WHERE WE'VE IN WE HAVE
THE TIME QUESTION ASKED. OFF
FROM SO WHO KNOWS THE WHO WHO
WOULD KNOW. OTHER BANK AND FINE
SYSTEM- AS WELL AS ANYBODY. AND
I CAN GO ON BUT BUT I WANNA-
LIMIT. TO ONE MORE YOU WHICH IS
MISTER MOORE- AND IT'S WITH
THAT SAME. SPIRIT OF ONE TO
HELP WE INTRODUCED THE FOR BILL
IN WANT TO CAN TO ENSURE A
SECOND AND WHICH YOUR COM VERY.
WHEN YOU TALK TO- MAKING THE
DEPEND DOWN MAKING SURE THAT IT
WAS. RECEIVED MAKING THAT WE
LIMIT RISK. MAY AND WE BACK TO
THE GONGWER AND WE WERE ON IT
AND- THAT'S WHY WE GOT. EIGHTY
SEVEN THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AND
WAS ABLE TO GET WITH ITS WITH
THAT SAME CLASS. ACTUALLY A WAY
TO TRANSFORM THE STATE I'D
BANK. INTO CALIFORNIA'S- STATE
STATE PUBLIC BANK LOOK I THINK
IT'S MORE NEEDED MORE NOW THAN
EVER- BUT YOU ALSO WANT TO TAKE
A COUPLE PEOPLE- CONTROLLER HE-
WAS GONNA BE PARTICIPATING
TODAY WHO REALLY GIVE A
THOUGHTFUL INPUT LOTS TO CHEW.
AND WE WERE GOING TO BE- OPEN
TO WORK WITH HER AND- TREASURE
MARK TO ENSURE THAT WE DO A
STATE PUBLIC BANK OTHERS
RESPONSIBLE AND DOES THE PUBLIC
BENEFITS INCLUDE THAT WE
INTENDED TO DO. BUT I THINK
TODAY IN TODAY'S CONVERSATION-
AND NOW TO UNDERSTAND THAT
MAKING ECONOMIC. DECLINE WE SEE.
THE CAME ACROSS OUR ACROSS OUR
COUNTRY. OF MILLIONS OF. ARE OF
WORK BIZ ARE. CLOSE LOOK
GOVERNMENTS TO FACE. OFF BLOWN
FINANCIAL CRISIS IS AND WE
HAVEN'T SEEN. OUR BIG BANKS
STEP UP TO THE PUBLIC GOOD BUT
THEY HAVE STEPPED UP. A TO
LEARN. TO ENSURE THE PROFIT.
OUR ARE STILL BEING MADE AND I
THINK THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH
THAT I THINK WE NEED TO CHANGE
THAT WE DO OF THE BANKING
SYSTEM SO THAT. WE HAVE A STATE
PUBLIC BANK THAT TAKES A LOOK
AT THE PUBLIC GOOD. WILL THEY
BE PROFIT DRIVEN THE- COULD
MAKE A PROFIT YES. UP BUT AT
THE CORE GROUP THAT HAS TO BE A
PUBLIC INTEREST AND WE'VE SEEN
THIS- AND I DON'T THINK WE CAN
TURN A BLIND GUY- ON ON ON THE
NEAT. TO HAVE A TO REENTER. A
FINANCIAL SYSTEM THE PUTS THE
PUBLIC GOOD. BEFORE AND WE NEED
BROKE. AND I THINK RESPOND SEE
THAT AND RE IMAGINATION OF WHAT
ECONOMIC SYSTEM COULD LOOK
LIKE. ACROSS THE COUNTRY. IS IT
A IS IT A BIG CHALLENGE TO DO
THIS YES IS IT WORTH DOING
ABSOLUTELY. A 100% WE HAVE TO
DO THIS AND SOME MIGHT SAY WELL
WHY SHOULD WE HAVE A PUBLIC
BANK AND I'M GOING TO BORROW
THE WORDS MY COLLEAGUE MR CHU
BUT THESE ARE THE EXACT SAME
ARGUMENTS. THAT WERE USED. ONE
ONE NINE WHEN INDUSTRIES TRIED
TO PREVENT A PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. AND
THESE ARE THE SAME ARGUMENTS
THAT WERE USED. A ONE WE NEED
TO GET A PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM- AND IT'S THE SAME
ARGUMENTS THAT WE USED. ONE
PRESENT OBAMA TRIED TO. TRIED.
YOUR REFORM OUR HEALTH CARE.
AND IT'S THE SAME ARGUMENT WERE
GONNA YOU YOU THAT THAT ARE.
YOU TO SUPPRESS. ABOUT FOR. AND
SO WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK
TRANSFORMING AND WE- THE WAY WE
BANKING. I THINK IT'S IMPAIR.
THAT WE START HEARING HELLO. SO
THE OF THE NAY THAT THANKS. BOB
COULD DO IT. GOOD AND WE SEEN
THAT ARE WITH YOU WILL PAVE THE-
TO AND OUR CAN- INSPECTOR- WITH
LOCAL. BANKS THAT HAVE DONE
GREAT GOOD TEMP WORKING. AND
OUR- INTEREST BEFORE. BEFORE
THE PROP AND WE LOOK. TO
PARTNERING WITH. A CREDIT UNION
AND JIMMY BANKS ARE TO CONTINUE
THEIR HARD WORK. SOME OF THIS
ARE. WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
THE BANK IN ORDER TO- AND YOU
AT IT PUBLIC GOOD PARTNERS.
WITH SOME BANKS A COMMUNITY AND
YOU AT IS. WITH YOU AND UP THE
PUBLIC GOOD AT THE A WAY THAT
WE CAN- THOSE- AND I THE MORE-
MORE NOW TO EVER BECAUSE- OF
THE NINETEEN HAS SHOWED. OF THE
WEEK IN OUR FINAL SYSTEM- SO I
WILL ASK. I WOULD IS THE KEY AN
OPEN. CAN TAKE A LOOK AT. THE
WAY WILL REMAIN. CERTAINLY
REMAIN. THE WAY WE CAN LONG FOR
WE REIMAGINE- I'M AREAS BUT WE
TO RE IN. A PUBLIC BAY SO THAT
IS MORE AT. AND LOOKS TO THE
PUB GOOD PARTICULARLY TODAY
WHEN WE SEE COMMUTER OF COLOR.
LEFT THE- I REPRESENT ONE THE
HIGHEST. COBIT RAY. THE WORST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES. ARE THE
RENTER CONTINUED GO UP PEOPLE
ARE. UP FOR FOOD- WOULDN'T BE
NICE TO HAVE A BIG SYSTEM THAT
SAYS. HEY THAT THAT IS THAT IS
IN. AND WE SHOULD THE BEST. IN
THOSE AREAS LUCKLESS THOSE CAN
AND AT THE WE SEE. EVEN IN
THERE A AND IN THE- NORTH WITH
PUBLIC BANG ARTICLE THAT THAT
WE SAW LESS OF AN- RATE.
BECAUSE THEY WAS ABLE TO
LEVERAGE. SOME OF THE RELAY.
WITH ITS LOGO BANKS. INVEST US
TO INVEST IN SMALL BUSINESSES
TO KEEP THEM. I THINK WE CAN DO
THAT- AND I DO WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT AFFORDABLE. YOU CAN
TAKE A LOOK AT. STUDENT LOAN.
YOU COULD TAKE A LOOK AT IN.
DEVELOP YOU COULD TAKE A LOOK
AT. A SPACE IN AND THE WEIGHT
OF. CLIMATE I THINK. TO START.
OF WHAT WILL WORK ABOUT. I'M
STRUGGLING YOU DO HIM WAY WE DO
YOU CAN. IN CAL. AND WE- OF
WHAT NEEDS. IN LOOK ECONOMIC
SYSTEM CAN LIKE ALMOST YOUR
RACE. SYSTEM REYES- AND THE
SURPRISE THAT WE SEE. IN
COMMUTER OF COLOR AND A THINK
IT COULD START WITH REIMAGINE.
AND ECONOMICS AND IT STARTS
WITH ME NEXT WEEK. A SYSTEM AT
STARTS WITH ESTABLISHING CAL.
PUBLIC BY. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIR AND A LOOK. TO A
ROBOT DISCUSSION- THIS NEXT
SECTION. AND THOSE WHO I AM. I
WOULD. YOU TO TED TED TED. TO
HAVE THAT. OVER NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS COULD GONNA GET ON IT AND
THE STAKEHOLDERS WILL LOOK.
THAT CONVERSATION I DIDN'T
THINK MR WIENER WHO IS A-
STRONG PROPONENT- IN HUESO FROM
UPON OPPONENTS. OF THE PUBLIC
BANKS ACTIVE THE. WHEN ASSEMBLY
VIRTUE HAVE BEEN CANDIDLY
WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH- TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION- THEY ARE WILLING TO
BE ABLE TO COMPROMISE AND
THEY'RE COMMITTED TO THIS
ISSUE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU NOW WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO. TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO SOME
NUMBER CHU GOOD MORNING MR CHU
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THEN WILL
GO. TO THIS POWER MISTER
HERBERT AT WE AGAIN WILL NEED
TO BE ABLE TO ADJOURN THIS.
SPECIFIC PANEL AT NINE FIFTY
SIX DUE O THE TIGHT TIME LINE
THAT WE HAVE WITH HEALTH%
COMMITTEE IN THE CUPBOARD
PROTOCOLS WILL TURN IT OVER TO
US AND NUMBER TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING
SENATORS AND LET ME START WITH
THE RECORD MISTER SANTIAGO AND
I CLEARLY DID NOT SHARE MEMOS
ABOUT OUR COMMON SARTORIAL A
TIRED THIS MORNING. BUT WE HAVE
A STRONG SHARED PERSPECTIVE ON
THE FUTURE OF THE STATE'S WELL
WHEN IT COMES TO BANK. I AS MR
SANTIAGO ALLUDED TO LAST YEAR
OUR LEGISLATURE PASSED AND OUR
GOVERNOR SIGNED AB EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN. TO ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO APPLY FOR
LOCAL PUBLIC BANKING CHARTERS
WHICH DID MAKE CALIFORNIA THE
FIRST STATE IN A HUNDRED YEARS.
TO ALLOW THE AUTHORIZATION OF
PUBLIC BANKS. IT WAS A
MONUMENTAL FIRST STEP AND I
ALSO IN ADDITION TO BANKING
AMAZING ADVOCATES AND A PUBLIC
BANKING COALITION. AS WELL AS
SENATORS WHO ARE ON THIS CALL
WHO WERE EARLY SUPPORTERS OF
THAT MEASURE. I REALLY DO WANT
TO THANK THE DEEP PARTNERSHIP
AND WORK THAT WE DID WITH THE
CHAIRS OF THE RELEVANT SENATE
COMMITTEES- CENTER MCGUIRE
CENTER BRADFORD CENTER
PORTANTINO AND CERTAINLY MANY
OTHERS. THIS LAST YEAR'S
CONVERSATION WAS ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF LOCAL PUBLIC
BANKS. TODAY'S CONVERSATION IS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
VISION OF A STATE. A STATE
OTHER BANK THAT KEEP THE PEOPLE
BY NASH POWER. IN OUR STATE TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE JUMP
STARTING OUR STATE'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. TO CATALYZE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF. LOCAL FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
PROVIDING INFRASTRUCTURE
CAPITAL AND SUPPORT. WE DON'T
KNOW THAT'S FAR RECOVERY
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN DRIVEN BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT CHOSE
TO USE AS INTERMEDIARIES. THE
WORLD'S LARGEST COMMERCIAL
BANKS. THESE RECOVERY EFFORTS
THAT HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
INADEQUATE. I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ESTABLISH THIS YEAR SOMETHING
THAT BILLS ARE WORKING HISTORY
OUR EXISTING AYE BANK. AYE AND
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WITHOUT A
STATE PUBLIC BANK OU STATE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE DEPENDENT
ON OUTSIDE FOR PROFIT ACTORS.
AND WILL BE CHALLENGING
INSURING THE LONG TERM. AND
ACCOUNTABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
RECOVERY. THE VISION OF PUBLIC
BANKING IS TO PROVIDE
INVESTMENT IN FINANCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO PROMOTE THE
PUBLIC GOOD. PUBLIC GOODS- THAT
INVOLVED DEVELOPING STANDARDS
TO PREVENT DISCRIMINATION IN
OUR FINANCIAL SERVICES MARKET.
ENSURING THAT WORKERS AND
BUSINESSES BENEFIT FROM THE
VALUE OF THEIR WORK. WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE PUBLIC
BANK I WOULD GO BEYOND ECONOMIC
RECOVERY THIS IS AN INVESTMENT
TO CREATE A LEGACY OF LONG TERM
FISCAL SUSTAINABILITY FOR OUR
STATE. CREATION OF A BANK WOULD
BE THE FIRST STEP TO CREATE A
SHARED INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE
DEGREE BETWEEN LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND OUR STUDENTS.
AS MR SANTIAGO ROUTED TO THE
BANK OF NORTH DAKOTA HAS BEEN A
CLEAR EXAMPLE IN THIS AREA.
THEIR BANK HAS CONSISTENTLY
DELIVERED DOUBLE DIGIT RETURNS
IN EQUITY TO THEIR STATE EVEN
DURING THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
FINANCIAL CRISIS. THIS YEAR THE
BANK OF NORTH DAKOTA
FACILITATED NORTH DAKOTA HAVING
THE LARGEST P. P. P. LOAN
FUNDING FOR WORKFORCE IN THE
COUNTRY. HELPING TO GET THOSE
LOANS TO THE BUSINESSES THAT
NEED THEM THE MOST THROUGH
COMMUNITY LENDERS. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT STATE PUBLIC BANKS WOULD
BRING REVENUES AND PROFITS TO
RURAL AND URBAN COMMUNITIES
LIKE THAT REPRESENT BIBLE
BANKING MARKETS THAT ARE OFTEN
IGNORED BY WALL STREET. NOW I
KNOW WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME
THIS PAST YEAR TO GET THE
DETAILS RIGHT AND THAT I WOULD
SUGGEST IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THAT WE COULD BE ENGAGING
RIGHT. I REALLY APPRECIATE. THE
FACT THAT I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF SHARED VISION ON HOW WE DO
THIS BUT AS WE KNOW THE DEVIL'S
IN THE DETAIL AND THAT'S
ENGAGEMENT THEY WERE HOPING TO
HAVE TODAY. CHAIRMAN REQUIRE
TALKED ABOUT THE CHALLENGE OF
DOING THIS DURING THIS PANDEMIC
IN RECESSION WHICH I GREATLY
APPRECIATE. WHAT I SUGGEST
THOUGH IS THAT WE ALSO FOCUS ON
THE CHALLENGES OF NOT MOVING ON
THIS DURING THIS TIME. AS WE
ARE HOPING AND PRAYING FOR A
SPEEDY AND FAIR RECOVERY. I
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN CRYING
OUT FOR HELP. FROM THE LARGEST
BANKS IN AMERICA AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT HELP HAS NOT
YET COME. ONE FINAL OBSERVATION
ON OUR WEB VICE CHAIR MORLOCK
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
WAS HEARING THAT. AND I KNOW WE
ALWAYS HAD HEALTHY DEBATES ON
THESE ISSUES AND ALWAYS HELP.
TO ENSURE THAT WHATEVER WE DO-
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD THE BEST
POLICIES AND HE REFERRED TO THE
PRIVATE BANK THAT. I WOULD NOTE
THAT THE BILL THAT WE MOVED
LAST YEAR PUT IN SO MANY
REQUIREMENTS FOR LOCAL PUBLIC
BANKING FROM OUR FRIENDS NOW
SEES PUBLIC SCRUTINY. THE
APPROVAL REQUIRES FOR ANY
PRIVATE SECTOR FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING FDIC
DEPOSIT INSURANCE COLLATERAL
REQUIREMENTS EXAGGERATE. THAT
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT IT WILL BE
VERY DIFFICULT FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS. AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE PERSPECTIVE THAT
THERE ARE PLENTY OF THINGS THAT
THE PRIVATE SECTOR CAN DO
BETTER THAN THE PUBLIC SECTOR.
BUT IN THIS FIELD OF BANKING
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE SERVING
THE PUBLIC. YOU LOOK AT THE
MORTGAGE FORECLOSURE CRISIS THE
STUDENT LENDING CRISIS THE
PREDATORY CONSUMER LOAN CRISIS
THE FAILURE OF BANKING SERVICES
FOR MILLIONS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES DURING THIS
RECESSION. THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THE FACT THAT WE HAVE THE
LARGEST BANKS IN THE WORLD IN
OUR COUNTRY SERVING CALIFORNIA
ALLEGEDLY THAT HAVE BEEN MAKING
UP. FAKE BANK ACCOUNTS THAT
HAVE BEEN INVESTING IN THE GUN
INDUSTRY THE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY BAD LABOR PRACTICES
THAT ARE DENYING OUR
CONSTITUENTS AT THIS MOMENT-
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FROM ET.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT REAL
ALTERNATIVES SO WITH THAT AGAIN
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
THE ENGAGEMENT IN THIS
CONVERSATION NOW MORE THAN EVER
IS THE TIME TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION. ON HOW WE BUILD A
CHIU EQUITABLE. ACCOUNTING
THANK YOU MISTER. SEPTEMBER
THANK YOU MUCH IN A WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
PARTNERSHIP SIR THANK YOU-
TODAY HE AND ONGOING. THAT
YOU'VE BEEN WONDERFUL TO WORK
WITH AND IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PARTICIPATING. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF COMMITTEES WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO MOVE ON
TO HEAR FROM MR POWER HE'S FROM
THE OPEN SOCIETY FOUNDATIONS
THAT BUT HE'S A PUBLIC. A
BANKING INSTITUTE ADVISORY
BOARD MEMBER AND OF COURSE THE
FORMER ALDERMAN IN CHICAGO THEN
WE'RE GONNA TURN OVER TO MISTER
HERBERT VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS.
MAJORITY THAT WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY AT TEN TWELVE
MINUTES LEFT IN THIS PANEL THAT
SENATE OVER HIS POWER AND WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SIR FOR
PARTICIPATING THE FLOOR IS
YOURS AND GOOD MORNING. SHARES
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE PRESENT
HERE TODAY INCLUDING THE
CENTERS IN THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS- AND BACKGROUND. YEAH
AND THE LEADERSHIP IN
GOVERNMENT FELLOW WITH. THE
OPEN SOCIETY FOUNDATIONS AND
I'M WORKING ON- SCALING LOCAL
AND STATE PUBLIC DRINKING
AFTERWARDS- I ALSO SERVED TWO
TERMS ON THE CITY COUNCIL THE
CITY CHICAGO TO RUN STATEWIDE
BEFORE- AND I. REALLY COMMEND
ALL OF YOU FOR HAVING THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT. BUILDING
THE FINANCIAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
ADVANCE THE PUBLIC GOOD- AND TO
FILL IN THE GAPS THAT ARE
REALLY CREATED BY. EX EXTREMELY
THAT'S WHAT THIS AT THIS
PROPOSAL REALLY DOES- WHEN I
SERVED IN THE CITY COUNCIL I
SAW THE LIMITS OF LEGISLATION
IN THE LIMITS OF MARKET BASED
TOOLS TO SOLVE PROBLEMS I GOT A
CHANCE TO LEAD EFFORTS TO RAISE
THE MINIMUM WAGE AND GUARANTEED
PAID SICK LEAVE. WORK WITH
TOOLS SUCH AS LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS AND
ENTERPRISE ZONES IN TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING YOU KNOW
THESE TOOLS THAT WERE CREATED
TO REALLY RESPOND TO THE
IMPACTS OF THE EXTERNALITIES
CREATED BY PRIVATE BANKS WHAT I
FOUND IS NEITHER OF THESE TOOLS
NECESSARILY BOTH LEGISLATION
AND A MARKET BASED TOOLS
NECESSARILY HELP. ALL OF YOU
MEET THE MOMENT IN THAT WAY
SORT OF ADDRESS. THE PROBLEMS
OF THE SCALE OF THE ISSUES-
TRULY WHAT. BANKS RE HAVE THE
POWER TO DO. IS THEY CREATE
MONEY. 97% OF ALL THE MONEY
THAT GETS CREATED IN THE U. S.
ECONOMY IS CREATED BY BANKS.
AND THAT IS A LICENSE THAT IS
PROVIDED BY THE STATE. AND
NORMALLY WE WOULD ASK SOMETHING
IN EXCHANGE FOR THAT LICENSE A
PUBLIC GARDEN YOU KNOW THERE IS.
INVESTMENT ACT ANOTHER MARKET
BASED TOOLS BUT AGAIN TO GIVE
YOU PERSPECTVE. LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS ARE ONE
FORM OF- TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THEY CREATE ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS OF
HOUSING NATIONALLY EVERY YEAR.
AND THERE'S A NATIONAL SHORTAGE
OF SEVEN MILLION UNITS RIGHT IT
WOULD TAKE SEVENTY YEARS. TO
USE THIS TOOL TO BUILD. AND WE
NEED TO ASK. SO WHAT PUBLIC
BANKS REALLY DEALING WITH THIS
PROPOSAL THAT IS PERFORMED-
SPONSORS IT IS A IS A MIDDLE
GROUND IT'S IN BETWEEN
UNFETTERED MARKETS. AND IT'S IN
BETWEEN STATE CONTROL IT ALLOWS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
BILL THE FINANCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. SYSTEM CAPACITY
TO LED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO ACCESS
THAT THE MUNICIPAL LIQUIDITY
FACILITY WHICH CHARGES PENALTY
RATES TO PROVIDE DEPOSITS TO
CDFI IS AND- COMMUNITY BANKS SO
THAT THEY CAN LEND TO SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND ALSO FLIPS THE
NARRATIVE IN THE CONVERSATION
RUN WHO ACTUALLY MAKES MONEY
FROM LENDING TO GOVERNMENT AND
FROM LENDING TO SMALL BUSINESS.
WE CAN'T GO BACK TO THE PRE
KALRA CONNIE. THAT KIND OF ME
WASN'T WORKING FOR WORKING
PEOPLE. BUT IN ORDER FOR US TO
FINANCE THE TYPE OF.
INFRASTRUCTURE THE KIND OF
HOUSING THE KIND OF THINGS. C.
TO REALLY TRANSFORMER
COMMUNITIES WE REALLY NEED A
FINANCING PARTNER THAT ALIGNS
WITH ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AGENDA THAT IS A FOUR BUT STATE.
AND SO- THINGS THAT I THINK WE
SHOULD BE ALL THINKING ABOUT AS
YOU HAVE IN THE BANK AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK THAT HAS
BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. WHAT YOU'RE ABLE TO
DO HERE IS EXPAND ITS CAPACITY.
AND EXPAND ITS ROLE AND EXPAND
ITS MANDATE SO THAT STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO ARE.
PRESSED FOR. YOU KNOW IN TERMS
OF DEALING WITH A- STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT AND DEFICITS COULD
CONNECTED TO. DIMINISHING
REVENUES THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ACCESS THE DOLLARS AT A
LOWER RATE OF FROM AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK. GOING TO
THE MARKETS AND PAYING A HIGHER
INTEREST RATE SO THE QUESTION
WE HAVE TO ANSWER IS DOES IT
MAKE SENSE. A HIGHER INTEREST
RATE SCOTT IN STATE LEVEL WAR
SHOULD THE STATE PROVIDE THOSE
DOLLARS AT A LOWER RATE STILL
MAKE A RETURN STILL HAVE THE
FULL FAITH AND CREDIT BACKING
FOR THOSE LOANS AND MAKE SURE
THAT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DON'T HAVE TO CUT SERVICES OR
CUT STAFF CAN WE LEARN TO SEE
THE ADVISING COMMUNITY BANKS TO
LEND IN COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED. BY INSTITUTIONAL
RACISM BY DISINVESTMENT BY
OTHER ISSUES THAT WE'VE SEEN
THEIR HISTORICAL IN NATURE. AND
THEN ALSO DOES THIS- STATE BANK
ALSO CREATE THE CAPACITY TO
DRIVE TRANSFORMATION IN THE
LONG TERM. THIS IS A REALLY
FANTASTIC THE PROPOSAL- AND I
JUST WANT TO AND CLOSE BY
SAYING. THE LICENSE TO CREATE
MONEY THAT IS WHAT THE PUBLIC
PROVIDES PRIVATE SECTOR BANKS
THERE IS NO REASON WHY THE
PUBLIC SECTOR COULD ALSO OBTAIN
A LICENSE TO CREATE MONEY TO
FILL IN THE GAPS THAT ARE
CREATED BY PRIVATE SECTOR
BANKS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS IF YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY WERE HONORED
THAT YOU'RE WITH US THANK YOU
VERY VERY GRATEFUL LAYS IN
GERMAN WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ROUND OUT OUR FINAL
SPEAKER IN OUR FIRST PANEL
THAT'S MARK HERBERT VICE
PRESIDENT IN CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY. HERBERT
WE'RE GONNA PROVIDE AT FIVE
MINUTES WILL GO A LITTLE OVER
OUR TIME BUT FIVE MINUTES SIR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND I'LL
GIVE YOU A ONE MINUTE PROBLEM
TO GET CLOSE TO THAT FIVE
MINUTE MARK MISTER HERBERT.
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU AND MEMBERS
OF THE SPECIAL COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE THE A JOINT HEARING
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY JOIN
YOU- I WILL I WILL TRY TO BE
BRIEF BECAUSE I AND I IMAGINE
THERE ARE QUESTIONS AS WELL AS-
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE-
RESPECT EVERYONE'S TIME. MY
NAME IS MARK HERBERT I AM VICE
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA FOR SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY WE ARE
NATIONAL SMALL BUSINESS
EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION- AND WE JUST
FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE THAT
ENTREPRENEURS AND SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE CENTRAL
BUILDING BLOCKS. TO HEALTHY
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY AND
ECONOMY. AS WE ALL KNOW HERE
BECAUSE IT HAS AN ABSOLUTELY
DEVASTATING FOR CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES. AND WE'VE
SEEN CLOSURE RATES ESPECIALLY.
IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SOME
PARTS OF THIRTY TO FORTY
PERCENT. AND WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S SIMPLY NOT SUSTAINABLE
AND IF WE'RE LOOKING TO
ACTUALLY RECOVER AND BUILD AN
INCLUSIVE ECONOMY AT COMING OUT
OF THIS PANDEMIC- WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE CAPITAL
NEEDS OF THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES. ARE DRESSED AS WE
KNOW THE FED STEPPED IN TO PUMP
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE
SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY- BUT
IT WOULD AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU REFERENCE IT WAS VASTLY
UNEVEN. MEANT MOSTLY IT WAS
MEDIUM TO LARGER BUSINESSES
THEY GOT THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
BECAUSE IT WAS BUILT ON TOP OF
THE EXISTING STRUCTURE. OF HOW
SMALL BUSINESSES ACCESS IS
CAPITAL- AND IT'S- PRIMARILY
THROUGH BANKING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH MANY OF THE VERY SMALL
BUSINESSES. SIMPLY DIDN'T HAVE
AND WE KNOW FROM SOME OF OUR
SURVEYS THAT EVEN NOW AS WE
LOOK FORWARD IN THE COMING
MONTHS. I ROUGHLY 40% OF
ENTREPRENEURS OF COLOR I'M
AREN'T QUITE SURE THEY'RE GOING
TO MAKE IT. INTO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND BEYOND- AND THAT THE
KEY PIECE HERE IS THAT
FUNDAMENTALLY HOW ARE CAPITAL
MARKETS ARE BUILT FOR THE VERY
SMALL BUSINESSES. IT DOESN'T
WORK IT'S NOT BUILT FOR THAT.
AND SO WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
HOW DO WE BUILD BETTER MARKET
PLACE THAT ACTUALLY MEETS THE
NEEDS OF THE VERY SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND THAT WE SEEK TO
SERVE THAT ARE CRITICAL TO THE
LIVELIHOOD AND TO A CRITICAL
ATTITUDE THE VITALITY OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS- AND FINALLY WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE.
DE. RISKING CAPITAL IT CAN BE A
EXPENSIVE A MAKE ONE. TO REAL
SMALL BUT- AND YOU CAN BE REST
AND WE NEED TO DELIVER. AND
MAKE SURE THAT- THERE ARE SOME
SORT OF BACKSTOPS INSULTS OR
SUBSIDY AVAILABLE FOR THOSE.
VERY SMALL BUSINESSES WE ARE
YOU KNOW AS THAT COMMUNITY
LENDERS. DO THIS DAY IN AND DAY
OUT OFTENTIMES NONPROFIT
LENDERS LIKE CDFI IS ARE
RAISING MONEY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT CAPITAL. IS GETTING TO
THOSE VERY SMALL BUSINESSES SO
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
GIVING THE TOOLS FOR SEE IF I
COMMUNITY BANK FRIENDS. THAT
THEY CAN MAKE THESE LOANS TO
THE VERY SMALL BUSINESSES AND
OUR COMMUNITY I'M THRILLED TO
SEE THAT SOME OF OUR GOOD
FRIENDS FROM THE CDFI
COMMUNITY. WILL BE SPEAKING A
LITTLE LATER TODAY I THINK OF
THEIR ROLE. IN MAKING SURE THAT
THE VERY SMALL BUSINESSES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS TO
THE CAPITAL THAT THEY NEED TO
SURVIVE. I'M IS GONNA BE AT
ESSENTIAL. WHERE WERE PLEASES.
THAT THE STATE ALREADY STEPPED
UP. TO PROVIDE A NUMBER OF-
FINANCIAL INVESTMENTS THROUGH
THE AYE BANK AYE WE APPRECIATE
MR WILLING HIS TEAM AND ALL THE
WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE- TO
ATTACH. TO ADDRESS AND THE
CHAO'S THE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE FACING- BUT SOME
ESTIMATES PUT THE SMALL
BUSINESS CAPITAL NEEDS IN THE
TENS. OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
NOT AND WHILE WE HAVE SEEN-
TENS OF MILLIONS INVESTED AND
WE HOPE TO LEVERAGE THAT'S
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS IN SMALL
BUSINESS LENDING CAPITAL. AND
THE SCALE IN THE NEED OF THE
PROBLEMS JUST. THINKING IS
SIGNIFICANT AS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE THINKING ABOUT
SCALABLE SOLUTIONS- WE
APPRECIATE THE CREATIVITY THAT
THE CALIFORNIA REBUILDING FUND.
AND AS CREATED IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH I THANK IN PHILANTHROPY
AND PRIVATE INVESTORS. A NEW
PROGRAM JUST CAME ONLINE ON
FRIDAY. THAT WILL GET
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS. TO SEE IF
IS TO THESE COMMUNITY LENDERS
TO GET. SMALL DOLLAR LOANS TO
THE BUSINESS OWNERS ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THIS PANDEMIC.
ALLEN SO WE APPRECIATE THAT
CREATIVITY WHY THINK ABOUT
WAYS. THAT THAT COULD BE SCALED
WE THINK THAT THE PROMISE OF A
PUBLIC BANK HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO THINK ABOUT. HOW DO WE GET
MORE TOOLS AND MORE RESOURCES
AND MORE CAPITAL- TO THE
SMALLEST BUSINESSES. AND BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT NOT JUST THIS MOMENT. AND
MEETING THE SIGNIFICANT NEED TO
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND OUR
STATE FACES. HOW DO WE BUILD A
MORE EQUITABLE ECONOMY IN THE
FUTURE. ONE MIN EVEN BEFORE
BECAUSE OF IT. EVEN BEFORE
COVER THE CHALLENGES THAT SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS FACE FOR
SIGNIFICANT- AND- CODE SIMPLY
EXACERBATED THAT. WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE MORE
TOOLS BETTER INFRASTRUCTURE TO
REALLY MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
SMALLEST BUSINESSES. HERE IN
THE STATES SO. WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT.
HAVE BEEN CREATED IN THE PILOTS
AND BEEN CREATED WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT THIS CONVERSATION WHAT IT
MEANS FOR CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THIS THIS TO. CONTINUE
DISCUSSION. AND LIVING FOR SO
WITH THAT I'M I WILL TURN IT
BACK TO THE CHAIR. THE SERVER
THANK YOU SO MUCH- WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE WITH US
TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO. THE
SENATORS FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. AT ONE REMIND FOLKS
THAT WE WILL BE TO TAKING
PUBLIC COMMENT. AT THE END OF
TODAY CHECK A- THAT CALL THE
NUMBER YOU WANT TO. PUBLIC
COMMENT A EIGHT FOR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
WITH THE CODE SIX ZERO FIVE.
SEVEN SIX FIVE THREE. LAYS IN
GERMAN LET'S TURN TO OUR-
SENATORS FROM BOTH COMMITTEES
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS NOW FROM- THE NUMBERS
OF BOTH COMMITTEES. I CURRENTLY
DON'T SEE ANY HAND SEPARATE DO
A FINAL CALL FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FINAL CALL FIRST PANEL NUMBER
ONE FROM SENATORS ON THIS
COMMITTEE. LET'S GO TO THE VICE
CHAIR VICE CHAIR MARLA GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU MISTER I
DON'T WANT TO MAKE A BIG DEAL
OUT OF THE BANK IN NORTH DAKOTA
I JUST WANNA POINT OUT THAT-
THE POPULATION OF NORTH DAKOTA
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY SIX.
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN WHICH IS ABOUT ONE. FIFTY
A THOROUGHBRED ONE FIFTY TWO-
IS THE SIZE OF. CALIFORNIA IT
IT IT WE HAVE FOUR CITIES GROUP
WITH GREATER POPULATIONS ONLY A
FIFTEEN COUNTIES WITH GREATER
POPULATION SOME LITTLE. KILL
NERVOUS. ABOUT USING A BANK OF.
NORTH DAKOTA WHICH PRIVATE THE
ONLY STATE THAT'S DONE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS. AS AN
EXAMPLE BUT I DON'T WANT TO GET
INTO THE DEBATE OF IT I JUST
WANT TO POINT IT OUT FOR
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND MISTER VICE
CHAIR APPRECIATE THAT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN I'M LOOKING AT
OUR SCREEN WE'RE GONNA DO A
FINAL CALL FINAL CALL FOR ANY
INDIVIDUAL THAT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO CENTER DRIVE SO GOOD MORNING
SENATOR FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK
YOU- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
NOT ALL MY COLLEAGUES. THE
QUESTION IS. WHAT IS IT. ABOUT
A PUBLIC BANK HOW WILL THE
STATE INSURER. THAT FOR
COMMUNITIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL HAVE ACCESS.
TO THESE- SAME FINANCING-
OPPORTUNITIES AS WEALTHIER
ONES. HOW DO WE MAKE HOW IS IT
HOW IS IT THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT THE BENEFITS OF THIS NEW.
SYSTEM. ARE ACTUALLY SHARED
EQUITABLY. THANK YOU SENATOR
WE'RE GONNA FIRST TURN IT OVER
TO A SIMMER SANTIAGO THEN WE'LL
GO TO OUR TO PUBLIC BANKING
EXPERTS THERE I MISS POWER AND
MISTER HERBERT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IS SANTIAGO AND I DO WANT TO
LET FOLKS KNOW THAT IS A MEMBER
CHIU HAS A MEETING AT TEN AM
VERY GRATEFUL S. IN THE BIRD
THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING BUT
I JUST WANNA GIVE FOLKS A HEADS
UP ON THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND
CENTER DRESSES QUESTION. AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ABOUT THE
SOLUTIONS- DOING THIS VIRTUALLY
IS. IS A NEW TO ME SO I
APPRECIATE YOU DOING IT THAT
WAY- AND- SENATOR ALSO WHEN WE
DID THE- FIRST ACT. A PUBLIC
BANKS. EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN WE INCLUDED IN OUR
LANGUAGEHAD TO- YOU HAVE TO
STATE YOUR PUBLIC PURPOSE. TO
THE EXISTING BANK. BY THE LOCAL
MOST VALUABLE TO DO ONE. AND
WE'RE TAKE A LOOK AT THE STATE
PUBLIC BANK- WE HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE. A
WITNESS WITNESS CHARTER EIGHTY
PUBLIC GOAL. OF BEING SMALL%
BUSINESSES- D. A- AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- BUT BUT ALSO IN ITS IN
ITS GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE. COULD
BE EMBEDDED. A GAME AT THE
PUBLIC GOOD- AND HELD
ACCOUNTABLE- TO THE PUBLIC GOT
SETTLED AT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION BUT BUT- THERE
CERTAINLY IS THE OPPORTUNITY
INCLUDE LANGUAGE IN THERE- TO
TAKE. FOR SPECIFIC PURPOSES.
THAT'S THE DEBATE WE HOPE THAT
WE WILL HAVE. ON AND WHEN YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT THE THREE- THE
THREE- CITIES OR AREAS THAT ARE
LOOKING AT PUBLIC BANKS. AND
THEY'RE DEVELOPING THE PROCESS
CURRENTLY AS TO WHAT PUBIC
GOOD THEY'LL UNDERTAKE INTERNAL
REFERENCE OF THE BAY AREA. SAN
FRANCISCO AND ALSO. THE L. A. I
THINK THEY'LL BE MORE DOUBLE
MORE- THE NEXT COUPLE. YOU HAVE
THE ABILITY TO IDENTIFY WHAT
TYPE PURPOSE GOOD GUN COULD.
GLAD TO. THANK YOU SENATE SO
ANY COMING BACK AND IF IT'S
ALRIGHT AS CENTER RAWS A WILL
THEN GO TO- IT TO OTHERS SENSE
POWER ANY COMMENT ON SENATOR
EYES IT WAS A QUESTION. YES
THANK YOU- I THINK YOU KNOW
THIS IS A MATTER OF HOW YOU
SCHOOL YOU KNOW. COULD IT-
SCOPIA DISEASES. BANDON YEAH
THE ROLE OF THE I. BANTING
CLUED FOR A HOUSING OR-
DEPOSITS TO CDFI IS- THAT DO
LENDING TO X. Y. NZ BUSINESSES
A LOT OF THIS CAN BE SCOPED ON
THE FRONT END AND CERTAINLY I
THINK- GIVEN SORT OF THE EQUITY
SO. THAT I HEAR FROM THE
SPONSORS I THINK THAT IS KEY IN
SORT OF MAKING SURE THAT THAT
SORT OF LANGUAGE IT'S KIND OF
FIND IT BOTH IN THE- AND THE
LEGISLATION BUT ALSO IN MANDATE
OF THE I. BANK AND THEN. AND
THEN- AS THERE IS OVERSIGHT
FROM THE LEGISLATURE OVER THE
IRAQ AND TO CONTINUE THAT
YOU'RE MEETING THOSE WORKERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF WHAT WE GO
TO MISTER HERBERT AND WE'LL SEE
IF S. AND RAZA HAS ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS AND WILL SEE. IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER SENATORS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO MAKE A
COMMENT OR ASK A QUESTION.
MISTER HERBERT PLEASE FOR
RESOURCE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER AT INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AT TO THINK ABOUT HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT. THAT THE
ORGANIZATIONS ALREADY DOING SO
FROM A SMALL BUSINESS
PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE AMAZING.
ENTITIES ORGANIZATIONS DOING
THEIR SMALL BUSINESS SMALL
DOLLAR LENDING. ALREADY IN
COMMUNITIES- BUT MENTIONED CDFI
THEIR CRITICAL COMPONENT. THE
MORE THAT THOSE HE ADVICE CAN
BE GIVEN THE LIQUIDITY THAT
THEY NEED. AND THE CAPACITY
THAT THEY NEED. BECAUSE THEY
ARE ALREADY TARGETING THE
MARKET. THAT WE NEED TO SEE
RECEIVE THESE DOLLARS AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE THE- EXISTING
SMALL BUSINESS LENDING
MARKETPLACE. ISN'T REALLY
FUNCTIONING WELL FOR THE
SMALLEST BUSINESSES THAT WE
CARE ABOUT. IS THE MORE THAT WE
CAN SCALE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NECESSARY. FOR CDFI IS TO MAKE
THOSE LOANS. TO WORK WITH THE
LENDERS WHO ARE ALREADY DOING
THAT WORK. AND THE MORE THAT WE
CAN ENSURE THAT THESE DOLLARS
GETS OF THE COMMUNITIES. THAT
CAN BENEFIT THE MOST. THANK YOU
MISTER HERBERT I'D LIKE TO BE
TO SEE CENTER DRIVE SO DO YOU
HAVE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TERRORISM.
DON'T THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
COULD. LISTEN TO THE FOLLOWING-
PANELISTS BUT I GUESS I'M
LOOKING FOR AND IN THE FUTURE-
PRESENTATIONS. IS WHAT GIVES
TEETH TO WHAT WE WANT TO GET
OUT OF A PUBLIC BANK. SO WE'LL
LEAVE THAT FOR THE FOLLOWING
QUESTION A PANELIST THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER DRIVE SO. THAT WE'RE
GOING TO A FINAL CALL FINAL
CALL FOR ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM SENATORS FROM EITHER
COMMITTEE. THAT IT WOULD LIKE
TO SEE HANDS UP IF THERE ARE
ANY FINAL CALL FINAL CALL FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
SENATORS. ALL RIGHT HERE IN C.
NINE LAYS IN GERMAN WE WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO OUR FIRST
PANEL- IF YOU CAN GIVE US ONE
MINUTE AND APPRECIATE THE
PATIENCE OF ALL WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WE'RE
GONNA. TURN THE DIETS OVER TO
SENATOR BRADFORD THE CHAIR. OF
THAT BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS I'M GONNA TURN
THIS OVER TO HIM WE'RE GONNA DO
A QUICK DISINFECTING AND THEN
WILL RUN. PANEL NUMBER THREE AT
WHICH IS GOING TO BE WITH OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS IN IN
HEARING FROM STATE AGENCIES
GIVE US SIXTY SECONDS WILL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU. AS WE
DISINFECT.
THANK YOU TO YOUR
REQUIRE FOR AND ARE POWERLESS
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE FIRST
PANEL THEN MOVE OVER TO. OUR TO
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS WE HAVE
TWO AMAZING. WOMEN WHO HAVE
SERVED- THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
VARIETY OF CAPACITIES ON THE-
STATE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION AS
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE'S WHILE. AND I'M
HONORED TO CALL BOTH FRIENDS-
FIRST WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
ON. OUR STATE CONTROLLER BETTY
WHO'S THE CHIEF. FISCAL
OFFICER- HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- SHE MAKE SURE ALL
BILLS ARE. PAID- MOST IMPORTANT
IF YOU'RE STATE AND- YOU MAY
SURE YOUR- ON. AND THAT'S HER
SIGNATURE A FIX TO. EVERY
PAYCHECK AB GOING TO GIVE- MISS
E. HOW. TEN FIFTEEN MINUTES TO.
GIVE A PERSON ON PUBLIC BANK IN
THEM MOVE TO OUR TRADE. FIONA
MA SO. CONTROLLER YOU YOU'RE
READY FLOORS YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GERMAN MCGUIRE
MEMBERS- GOOD MORE AND THANK
YOU FOR THE EVENT TO BEFORE YOU.
ENTER BY PER AS CALPERS
CONTROLLERS RELATED TO THE
SUBJECT OF THE STATE BANK OF
FIRST I'D LIKE TO START OUT BY
JUST- ACKNOWLEDGING THE MEMBERS
OF THE FIRST PANEL AND TO JUST
SAY THAT I SHARE VERY MUCH THE
CONCERNS THAT WE NEED TO. BUILD
A MORE JUST AND EQUITABLE
ECONOMY AND JOBS THIS IS ONE
WHERE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY OUR LOW INCOME
BLACK AND LATINO COMMUNITIES
HAVE ACCESS TO CAPITAL AND ARE
BETTER SUPPORTED DURING AND
AFTER CERTAINLY- EVENTS LIKE
THIS PANDEMIC. YOU KNOW I'VE
AWARE OF SEARCHES ARE STILL
OFFICER THAT OUR ECONOMY IS NOT
WORKING FOR EVERYONE-
SPECIFICALLY FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND LOW WAGE WORKERS- WE
CERTAINLY MUST DO MORE TO
REMOVE THE CURRENT BARRIERS-
THAT ARE BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES AND BUSINESSES FACE
AND- ACCESSING. BUDGET CAPITAL
AND FINANCIAL SUPPORT- HOWEVER
OF THE STATE BANK IS SIMPLY NOT
THE SMARTEST MOST DIRECT WAY TO
SERVE PEOPLE WHO NEED IMMEDIATE
SUPPORT- I. BUT IT'S A COMPLEX
ENDEAVOR AND I AM GOING TO GO
INTO SOMEBODY A TECHNICAL
DETAILS IN A MOMENT. BUT CHAO
ITS BOTTOM LINE UP FRONT WITH
THE REST OF THE STATE
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO MEET
OUR EXISTING AND FUTURE
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS. AND AS I
WILL OPERATE- SHORTLY- WE DON'T
NEED TO REINVENT THE WHEEL
GIVEN THAT THERE IS ALREADY AN
EXISTING NETWORK OF FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE. TO
ACCOMPLISH THESE GOALS AND I'M
VERY HAPPY TO SEE THAT THE
AGENDA TODAY IS COMPREHENSIVE-
I AM. DELIGHTED THAT WE ARE.
MENTIONING CD ADVICE AND ALSO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO HEAR FROM
ABOUT THE STRUGGLES FROM THE L.
I. BANKS LATER ON TODAY. YOU
KNOW MY PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY
AS SUCH IT'S JUST OFFICERS TO
PROTECT THE STATE'S FISCAL
HEALTH. AND MY OFFICE ANALYZES
OF THE STATE'S CASH FLOW NEEDS
ON A DAILY BASIS AND WE WORK
WITH THE TREASURER'S OFFICE TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
SUFFICIENT FUNDS AVAILABLE TO
MAKEPAYMENTS. AS THEY ARE DUE.
PURSUANT TO THE ANNUAL BUDGET
ACT. BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC THAT
WAS. JUST SOME OF OUR ECONOMIC
SECTORS AND BUSINESSES IN OUR
STATE- CAUSING SOARING
UNEMPLOYMENT. VOLATILE
FINANCIAL MARKETS AND UNCERTAIN
TAX REVENUE- I AND MY TEAM ARE
MORE COMMITTED THAN EVER TO
MONITORING THE SITUATION. AND
YOU CURRENTLY MANAGE OUR
FINANCIAL POSITION OVER
PARTICULARLY AS THE NEXT TWO TO
THREE YEARS. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
WE CAN PAY THE STATE'S BILLS.
STYLISH CAPITALIZE AND MAINTAIN
A STATE BANK. BY FORCING
DEPOSITS OF THE STATE'S FULL
MONEY INVESTMENT ACCOUNT THE
PMI A- REMAINS A DANGEROUS GAME
A PUTS CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS AT
ENORMOUS RISK. THE PMI A SHOULD
REMAIN INVESTED IN SECURE
COLLATERAL SUCH AS US TREASURY
DEBT AND SAFE INSTRUMENTS WITH
SUFFICIENT LIQUIDITY AND YIELD
TO PROVIDE THE STATE AND THE
THOUSANDS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
INVESTED IN THE PMI A- THE
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY TO WITHDRAW
FUNDS AS STATED. REQUIRING THE
TREASURE TO THE BEST BEYOND
MADE FUNDS IN SHORT TERM DEBT
ISSUED BY THE CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BANK I BANKS. A
WHICH WOULD SERVE AS COLLATERAL
I WILL BE BACK BY THE STATE IS
ACTUALLY VERY CIRCULAR
PROPOSITION AS IT MEANS WE
WOULD BE REPLACES THE CARE
COLLATERAL SUCH AS US. TREASURY
DEBT WHICH THE PM I AM
CURRENTLY IN THE US WITH A NEW
UNTESTED JUST ADDED EXTRA MEANT
FOR WHICH THERE IS NO CURRENT
MARKET AND NO WAY TO ENSURE
ANTI LATE LIQUIDITY. MEANING
THAT WE NEED. AT THIS MONEY WE
COULDN'T GET IT IN TIME.
MOREOVER THIS OKAY. TAXPAYERS
WOULD BE AT RISK FOR THESE NEW
UNTESTED INVESTMENTS. IN FACT
IN RESPONSE TO QUESTIONS RAISED
FROM A COMMITTEES BACKGROUND
BRIEF. PUBLIC BANK ADVOCATES
STATES THAT IF THE BANK
RECEIVED A FEDERAL GUARANTEE
FOR ITS ASSETS IT MAY BE ABLE
TO ATTRACT INVESTMENT FROM THE
SURPLUS MONEY INVESTMENT FUND
ORTHE PMI. OF THIS IS A MUCH
MORE PRUDENT COURSE OF ACTION
ABOUT ESTABLISHING A NEW BANK
BASED ON THE PREMISE THAT THE
STATE WILL INVEST ITS FUNDS AND
AN UNTESTED FINANCIAL-
BANG DEMONSTRATE THAT IT OFFERS
COMPETITIVE RATES A COMPARABLE
SECURITY BEFORE DEPOSITING.
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FUNDS. SH UP MY OFFICE AND I
HAVE BEEN A TO A MAN THE
STATE'S CASH FLOW FOR THE LAST
SIX YEARS WITHOUT EXTERNAL
BORROWING. AND WE ARE NOW
CLOSELY MONITORING THE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. ALTHOUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST RECENTLY
REPORTED STATE REVENUES ARE
TWENTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS
HIGHER THAN ORIGINALLY FORECAST
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. WE
CANNOT LOSE SIGHT OF THE
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES AHEAD FOR THE STATE.
THIS IS A ONE TIME SURPLUS OF
BIDS FACT MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET SHORTFALLS THROUGH
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. THAT WOULD LIKELY
REQUIRE THE STATE TO SELL
REVENUE ANTICIPATION NOTES. AT
A PURCHASE TO PAY THE STATE'S
BILLS. AND I WOULD JUST CAUTION
YOU FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
FOLLOWING US A TIME- THE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT RECESSION- WHICH
PUTS THE STATE IN A PRECARIOUS
FINANCIAL POSITION. RESULTING
IN THE ISSUANCES OF SEVERAL
INCHES SUFFICIENT NOTES OUT
REVENUE JUST PATIENT LAWRENCE.
I'LL USE A CREDIT RATING
DOWNGRADE TO TROUBLE DAYS.
DURING THAT PERIOD THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE COUNTED
EVERY PENNY OF THE DAILY BASIS
IN ORDER TO PAY OUR BILLS.
USING THE PMI A FUNDS OTHERWISE
INTENDED TO BE INVESTED IN
SHORT TERM LIQUID INSTRUMENTS
IN ORDER TO MAKE HIGHER. TO
MAKES LONGER LONG AS A
MISALIGNED OF PURPOSES AND
COULD LEAD TO EVEN HIGHER
BORROWING COSTS FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. IF THE SIZE OF
THE REVENUE INTEREST PATIENT
OUT HAD TO BE INCREASED DUE TO
ILLIQUID INVESTMENTS. AND I.
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY
SOMETHING BECAUSE I KNOW WE'VE
BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT THE
BANK OF NORTH DAKOTA. AND JOBS
FROM ONE LAST POINT ASIDE FROM
SKILLS. ADDING TO THIS POINT-
YEAH I THINK WHAT WE EACH
OTHER. WITH THOSE OF THE
FOUNDING PRINCIPLES UPON WHICH
THE BANK OF NORTH DAKOTA I WAS
ESTABLISH AD. WHICH STIPULATED
THAT THE BANK OF NORTH DAKOTA
ASSIST IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
LOCAL BANKS NOT OFFER A
COMPETITIVE ALTERNATIVE. AND SO
I'M LIKE WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED
IN THE OF LEGISLATION BEFORE US
OF THE BANK OF NORTH DAKOTA
DOES NOT PROVIDE BANKING
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS OR
BUSINESSES- INSTEAD A LOCAL
BANK MUST APPLY TO ACCESS ONE
OF THEIR LENDING PROGRAMS ON
BEHALF OF THE CUSTOMER. BECAUSE
IT RECOGNIZES LOCAL BANKS
UNDERSTAND THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE. BETTER THAN A STATE
ENTITY BECAUSE- AND BEYOND THE-
RED OF THE FOR FROM THE- AIDS
AS A STATE BANK COULD BE
SUBJECT TO CHALLENGE FOR
VIOLATING VARIOUS PROVISIONS OF
THE STATE CONSTITUTION. ALSO
THAT PROVIDES THE PLEDGE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FULL FACE AND
CREDIT TO DEPOSITORS IN THE
STATE BANK. ARGUABLY VIOLATES
PROVISIONS OF ARTICLE SIXTEEN
RELATED TO PUBLIC FINANCE
RESTRICTIONS. WELL I DO WANT TO
SAY UP AND TOOK BOTH OF MR CHIU
AND- WELL AUTHORED THE
SUCCESSFUL AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
AND- WE ARE REALLY ANXIOUS TO
SEE HOW OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WILL BE PURSUING A ITS OWN-
PUBLIC BANK AND ALSO TO-
SANTIAGO. YOU KNOW I THINK OF
ALL THE DISCUSSIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN CITIZENS FILED I'LL
CERTAINLY AB THREE TIMES HAS
BEEN INTRODUCED IN ARE
DELIBERATED UPON I REALLY-FOCUSED ON- JUST OUT HOW TO
KEEP THE STATE OUT OF REST- SIR
THAT'S BEEN YOU KNOW KIND OF MY
FOCUS BUT THERE IS A BETTER
ALTERNATIVE HERE- OF. THE
BANKING SYSTEM THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED AT. THIS BILL I WOULD
ARGUE ALREADY EXISTS. OTHER
THAN STARTED NEW. HIGH STATES
ENTITY. ALSO CAL INSTEAD JOINED
THE DOWN PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
FINANCIAL COMMITMENTS SUPPORT
AND ATTENTION DIRECTED AT THE
EXISTING NETWORK OF. HE
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL AND
MINORITY DEPOSITORY
INSTITUTIONS TO WHICH I WILL
COLLECTIVELY REFERRED TO SCDF
EYES FOR THE PURPOSES OF THIS
HEARING- AND THE START
INSTITUTIONS THAT ALREADY
EXISTS THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE ARE AIMING
CHAU SERVES. CDFI OUR PRIVATE
SECTOR ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ATTRACT CAPITAL FROM PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC SOURCES WE HAVE OVER
EIGHTY ONE CD ADVISIG
CALIFORNIA EACH WITH DEEP REACH
INTO UNDERSERVED MINORITY
COMMUNITIES. HELPING TO DEVELOP
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS SUPPORT
THEIR BUSINESSES AND DRIVE
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. THESE LOCALLY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ARE WELL
SUITED TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE. OFFERING MULTIPLE OTHER
PUBLIC POSITIVE BENEFITS TO
THESE COMMUNITIES THAT REACH
FAR BEYOND THE FINANCIAL BOTTOM
LINE. CITY OF US FOR ORIGINALLY
ESTABLISHED TO SPECIFICALLY
PROVIDE FINANCIAL SERVICES TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THAT'S
STATE OF TROUBLED BANKS FOR NOT
ASSISTING IN ANY SUBSTANTIAL
WAY. THE FEDERAL COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ACT OF
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR CREATED A
CDFI FUND ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE TREASURY. AND
THE PURPOSE OF THIS WAS TO
PROMOTE ECONOMIC REVITALIZATION
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT BY
INVESTING IN. AND ASSISTING
CSI'S THROUGH EQUITY
INVESTMENTS CAPITAL GRANTS
LOANS AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONAL CAPACITY
BUILDING. CDFI SUPPLY FROM
LIMITS ON THROUGH A COMPETITIVE
PROCESS THAT REQUIRES THE CDFI
IN MOST CASES TO PROVIDE AT
LEAST A ONE TO ONE BATCH OF NON
FEDERAL FUNDS TO RECEIVE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. THE FUND
ALSO REWARDS BANKS AND THRIFTS
FROM MAKING INVESTMENTS THE
CDFI IS A DISTRESSED
COMMUNITIES THROUGH ITS BANKING
ENTERPRISE AWARD PROGRAM. AT
THE NEW MARKETS TAX CREDITS
PROGRAM INITIATED IN TWO
THOUSAND TO ENCOURAGES PRIVATE
SECTOR INVESTMENT BY OFFERING
TAX CREDITS FOR QUALIFIED
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
INVESTMENTS. CITY HAVE ALWAYS
USED THE MONEY AWARDED THROUGH
THE CDFI FUND PROGRAMS TO
LEVERAGE PRIVATE SECTOR
RESOURCES INTO DISTRESSED
COMMUNITIES AND TO SUPPORT AN
ARRAY OF COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING HOUSING
FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
BUSINESSES OWNED BY WELCOME
PEOPLE BASIC FINANCIAL SERVICES
COMMERCIAL FACILITIES THAT
PROMOTE JOB CREATION OR
RETENTION AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. AND CDFI SUPPLY THE
TOOLS INCLUDING PROVIDING
FINANCIAL SERVICES LOANS AND
INVESTMENTS. OFFERING TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SERVICES TO ENABLE ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS TO
BECOME SELF SUFFICIENT
STAKEHOLDERS AND THEIR FUTURE.
AND I WANT TO JUST ADDRESSED IN
PART CENTER DRAWS US QUESTION
WHICH I THINK WAS EXACTLY HOW
THE QUESTION ON POINT AND THAT
IS HOW DO WE ENSURE. THAT WHAT
WE ARE ENDEAVORING TO UNDERTAKE
REALLY REACHES OUT HAS THE
IMPACT INTENDED FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE ARE
TARGETING- AND WHAT I WILL SAY
IS IT SIGNIFIES CULTIVATES
SPECIALIZED KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY DO
BUSINESS- THEY FORGE DEEPER
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS. THIS TRANSLATES INTO A
WILLINGNESS AND COMMITMENT TO
SPENDING TIME ON INDIVIDUALIZED
SERVICE A SPECIALIZED PROGRAM
SO OFTEN ARE TOO TIME CONSUMING
OR COSTLY FOR MAINSTREAM.
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. RE BILL
DOES. COMMITTEE AND MAKE A
LOANS TO PAY WITH LOW OR CREDIT.
REQUIRES MORE THAN SIMPLY
PROVIDING ACCESS TO
CONVENTIONAL LOANS. REQUIRES
FLEXIBILITY CHAD DAPT LENDING
GUIDELINES TO THE NEEDS OF
BORROWERS. SHOULD STEP I'M
CONVINCED AND CONVENTIONAL
COLLATERAL FOR LOANS. AND TO
PROVIDE EDUCATION TRAINING AND
ASSISTANCE TO POTENTIAL
BORROWERS. MAINSTREAM FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS INVEST OUR OWN
CAPITAL DIRECTLY INTO CITY
ADVISED RECEIVING COMMITTEE OF
REINVESTMENT ACT CREDIT A
POTENTIAL CASH AWARDS UNDER THE
SEAT IF I FUNDS BANK AT A PRICE
AWARD PROGRAM. CDFI WAS CREATED
FUTURE MARKER FROM MAINSTREAM
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES. THANK YOU DEBATE
BUSINESSES AND PEOPLE HELPING
THEM TO GROW AND PROSPER. ONCE
OUR CUSTOMERS HAVE ACHIEVED
SOME SUCCESS ESTABLISH A GOOD
CREDIT HISTORY AND REACHED A
SUBSTANTIAL SIZE. THEY CAN THEN
PROCEED TO ACCESSING CAPITAL
AND LARGER AMOUNTS OF CAPITAL
AVAILABLE FROM MORE MAINSTREAM
LENDING INSTITUTIONS. THE
DEVICE ARE TRAILBLAZERS IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS AND BRING
PEOPL INTO THE ECONOMIC
MAINSTREAM AS CONTRIBUTORS TO
THE ECONOMY. NOW THE NUMBER OF
CD ADVISE CONTINUES TO INCREASE
NATIONWIDE THERE ARE NOW OVER
NINE HUNDRED FIFTY CITY ADVISED
ARE CERTIFIED BY THE CDFI FUND.
THE OPERATE IN EVERY STATE ND
THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA
SERVING BOTH RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES. AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT LOAN FUNDS OF LAND
TO BUILD BUSINESSES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
FACILITIES. YEAH I KNOW WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE PROPONENTS OF
THE PUBLIC BANKING ARGUE THAT
AMONG OTHER THINGS A PUBLIC
BANK COULD SUPPORT CD ADVISE
WITH FUNDING FROM THE POOL
MONEY INVESTMENT ACCOUNT AND
THE IDEX. I ADDED WHAT I WOULD
SAY TO THAT IS WE DON'T NEED TO
ESTABLISH A STATE ACTIVITIES
THE STATED GOALS. OF THE
LEGISLATURE COULD SIMPLY
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS DIRECTLY THROUGH A ONE
TIME DEPOSIT FROM THIS YEAR'S
INCREASE REVENUES IDENTIFIED BY
THE L. A. L. ARE USED BOND
PROCEEDS TO GENERATE ADDITIONAL
WORKING CAPITAL. IN FACT I
BANKS HAS ALREADY INITIATED THE
NEW PUBLIC PRIVATE EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT CDFI IS MAKING MORE
LOANS TO SMALL BUSINESSES AND I
KNOW THE STRUGGLE WILL BE
COVERING ABOUT IN A MOMENT. ADD
DOES SHOULD THIS PROGRAM- PROVE
SUCCESSFUL IN MEETING ITS GOALS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE
OPTION. OF INCREASING FUNDING
FOR THAT PROGRAM. WE SHOULD
ALSO INTEREST AND NOW BANK TO
AND THE NEXT THEIR FINAL
SUPPORT FOR CDS. THAT ALREADY
IT'S JUST YOUR IN CALIFORNIA-
AND ARE HERE TO SERVE UNDER OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO
PROVIDE SPECIALIZED FINANCIAL
SERVICES. TO INDIVIDUALS AND
BUSINESSES WATCH ADDITIONAL
ACCESS. TO CREDIT AND CAPITAL.
THERE IS A NATIONAL EFFORT
UNDERWAY I DO APOLOGIZE FOR THE
NATION'S TOP BANKS COMMITTING A
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR PROFITS TO
SEE DEFIES AS WELL AS
TECHNOLOGICAL AND MENTORING
SUPPORT. AND I WOULD URGE ALL
OF MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO FOCUS ON AND
GET FAMILIAR WITH THE SEPARATE
AND ENGAGE WITH THAT REALLY
HAVE CALIFORNIA STEP IN. OUT OF
THIS- CALIFORNIA'S NOT
TRADITIONALLY BEEN A BIG PLAYER
WITH RESPECT TO- NATIONAL
EFFORTS LIKE THIS RELATED TO
CITY APPLIES AND I THINK IT'S A
THIS IS AN EFFORT THAT IS ALL
WELL WORTH THAT. GAUGING
OURSELVES. AND THAT THIS SO GET
THE MOST. SUSTAINABLE TARGETED.
DEVELOPMENT SUPPORT TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES THE SAFEST MOST
PRUDENT AND IMPACTFUL MANNER.
AB OUT FOR MORE INFORMATION ON
THIS I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE A
LINK TO THE COMMITTEE. OF THAT
IS THERE IS A SIGN NEWS FDIC
REPORT CALLED INVESTING IN THE
FUTURE OF MISSION DRIVEN BANKS.
AND OTHER IS ABUNDANT
INFORMATION IN THERE ABOUT
THAT. SO LET ME JUST CONCLUDE
BY- JUST TALK ABOUT WHAT
CALIFORNIA CAN DO TO GROW CITY
FIIS AND THEIR CAPACITY. AND I
THINK THERE ARE MANY CHALLENGES
CERTAINLY LISTED ADVICE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE FRANKLY
THEY'VE BEEN THE COLLECTED. IN
TERMS OF HOW WE LIFT THEM UP TO
DO THE WORK THAT THEY I HAVE
BEEN CHARGED TO DO. END UP
PROVIDING BROAD REACH INTO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. FIRST
ACCESS THE CAPACITY OF
CALIFORNIA BASED CD ADVISED TO
MANAGE CAPITAL- MEET
OPERATIONAL BENCHMARKS AND THEN
USES METRICS TO IDENTIFY
SUFFICIENT CAPITAL MOUNTS THE.
TO SCALE UP NEAR MONDAY.
SECONDLY CAN CALL THE LORD
BANKS DEPLOY AND CAP. I CAN BET.
THE ORDER OF TWO. OF PROFITS
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS TO THE
BEST A CITY ADVISED. AND
ADDRESS EQUITY ISSUES. A LARGE
BANKS COULD ALSO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT THROUGH ASSET
MANAGEMENT FUNDS ANOTHER WAY TO
SUPPORT CAPITAL INVESTMENT.
ADVICE THIRD WE WANT TO RESOLVE
THE TECHNOLOGICAL AND
MODERNIZATION CHALLENGES OF CD
UP EYES AND THEIR OVER RELIANCE
ON PAPER PROCESSING. WHICH
OBVIOUSLY IMPEDES THE ABILITY
OF THOSE INSTITUTIONS TO
QUICKLY PROCESS TRANSACTIONS.
FOURTH WE'RE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THE TECH CAPITAL OF THE WORLD I
WOULD ALSO BE CALLED COUNT
CALIFORNIA'S TECH COMPANIES TO
COLLABORATE WITH CITY ADVISED
TO DETERMINE THEIR SOFTWARE
TECHNOLOGY UPGRADE NEEDS AND
CALL UPON LARGE BANKS TO HELP
FUNDTHESE UPGRADES ARE
REQUISITE STAFF TRAINING. IF WE
CAN SUPPORT CITY ADVISED- YOU
STILL THERE STAFF CAPACITY AND
TALENT BY CALLING UPON LEADING
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS TO.
DONATE AND SUPPORT INTERNSHIP
AND FELLOWSHIP SERVICES THAT
SUPPORT RISING STARS TO CREATE
SYSTEMS TO SUCCEED LONG TERM.
AND THE LAWS LATE WE WANT TO BE
SURE THAT WE EVALUATE HOW WELL
THE STATE'S FINANCIAL GIANTS
ARE FULFILLING THEIR
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE FEDERAL
COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT ACT. AND
SOME CONCLUSION OF GERMAN
BRADFORD REQUIRED AND MEMBERS
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFIED BEFORE
TO TESTIFY BEFORE YOU TODAY ALL
I WANT APPLAUDS THE VISIONS AND
CERTAINLY THE GOALS THAT ARE
BOTH OUT OF. MR SANTIAGO MR
CHIU OF THE PUBLIC BANKING
COMMITTEE ARE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE- I WOULD JUST LEAVE YOU
WITH THIS AND THAT IS- YOU KNOW
ANY SOLUTIONS TO CREATE
ECONOMIC EQUITY FOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES. MUST BE
INTENTIONAL AND URGENT ABOUT
DELIVERING RESULTS- AND THEY
MUST INVOLVE THE COMMUNITIES OF
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THESE
SOLUTIONS A BILL LASTING
RESILIENCE THIS COMMUNITIES
AFTER ALL IS SAID AND DONE. AND
I BELIEVE STRAIGHTENING CDFI IS
OF THIS. WAIT LOOKING ARTICLE
TO OF COLOR. AND PROMISES TO
DELIVER RESULTS MORE QUICKLY
THAN A LATE DATE COSTLY AND
RISKY PROCESS. OF ESTABLISHING
A STATE. IS COMMUNITIES THAT
WAY A LONG AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANY. AND CERTAINLY PLEDGE MY-
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS IS.
AND ALSO WANTED TO NOTE THAT I
HAVE ON HAND- WOULD TAKE WHEN
AND IF YOU'RE A MCDONALD'S.
ALWAYS FOR THE BEST OF
LEGISLATION. FOR QUESTIONS. AS
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU CONTROL ARE KEY FOR THAT
THE REPRESENTATION NEXT UP IS
OUR STATE TREASURER- INDIVIDUAL
WHO SERVED IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE ALSO. A FORMER
MEMBER THE STATE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION- SERVES NOW AS OUR-
CHIEF BANKER- OUR ASSET
MANAGER- CONTROLS ALL
INVESTMENTS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT IN THE PERSON
OF CHARGER FIONA MA MISS SMALL.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD AND
THANK YOU CENTER MCGUIRE FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING TODAY I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR MORLOCK FOR HIS LONG
TIME SERVICE ARE WE HAVE WORKED
TOGETHER ARE HAND IN GLOVE FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AND AS A CPA.
HI HE UNDERSTANDS A LOT OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE BROUGHT FOR
ITSELF THANK YOU SENATE-ROOM
BARLACH BUT ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AND IS
A MEMBER CHIU FOR. BRINGING UP
THIS ISSUE AND ARE WORKING ON
THE NUMBER OF BILLS THAT THEY
HAVE WORKED ON OUR I KNOW SCOTT
WILL- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
I. BANK IS GOING TO BE SPEAKING
NEXT AS WELL AS MANY ALVAREZ
COMMISSIONER ON THE FINANCIAL
PROTECTION IMPLEMENTATION. OF
CHIU PARTNERS THAT WE WORK WITH
VERY CLOSELY WE ALL SIT ON
SIMILAR BOARDS ARE BEING I'M
THE FINANCE TEAM AS WELL AS THE
CONTROLLER YEE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF FINANCE
AND SO ON IT'S GREAT I LOOK
FORTY HEARING YOUR COMMENTS
AFTER. I ALSO WANT TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO MARK ROBERT- OF
THE SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY.
THIS PANDEMIC STARTED ON PEOPLE
SIXTEEN ARE WE HAVE DONE OVER A
HUNDRED DIFFERENT ZOOM WEBINARS
MOSTLY FOCUS ON SMALL BUSINESS
OUR WITH OUR SPEAKERS FROM THE
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY AND
THEY ARE VERY VERY WELL VERSED
ON WHAT IS- OUT THERE WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND WHAT'S
AVAILABLE FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
SO THANK YOU. ARE YOU- TO THE
SMALL BUSINESS HRA AND THANK
YOU TO CONTROL YOUR ABILITY ARE
WE WORK HAND IN HAND TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THE OF THE BANKER
I'M COLLECTING ALL THE MONEY
AND THAT. THE CONTROLLER IS
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN PAY ALL
OF OUR BILLS- I KNOW SHE TALKED
EXTENSIVELY ABOUT THE PMI A
ACCOUNTS. AND THE BANK OF NORTH
DAKOTA I WON'T COVER THAT- BUT
WE ALSO AYE SHE TALKED ABOUT
EXPANDING THE ROLE OF THE CDFI
WHICH WE ARE VERY VERY SUPPORT.
ABOUT HERE IN THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE- ON JUST A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT ME IN MY BACK. I AM THE
OLDER CHILD IMMIGRANT PARENTS.
ARE I AM A SEAT. AT TAX
ACCOUNTANT- TRAINED- STARTED MY
PROFESSIONAL CAREER WITH MY THE
BIG ACCOUNTING. BACKED AND- MY
OWN PRACTICE THE AGE OF TWENTY
EIGHT AND BECAME PRESIDENT OF
THE ASIAN BUSINESS ASSOCIATION.
AND THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME I
EVER GOT INVOLVED IN POLITICS-
AND STARTED TO REALIZE THAT
ALTHOUGH SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
THE BACKBONE OF. THE ECONOMY
AND MANY OF OUR OUR RELATIVES
AND FOR FATHERS AND MOTHERS
CAME TO THIS COUNTRY. ARE
STARTING A SMALL BUSINESS
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE.
NECESSARILY THE EDUCATION OR
THE SKILLS- DIFFERENT TYPE OF-
JOBS. ARE THAT LOVES ARE THE
BACKBONE OF THE ECONOMY BUT
IT'S SO HARD. TO RUN AND
OPERATE AND BE SUCCESSFUL AS A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND SO
THAT'S WHERE MY PASSION FOR
PUBLIC SERVICE STARTED REALLY-
MAKING SURE THAT. I'M A VOICE
FOR SMALL BUSINESS AND TRYING
TO. DO AS MUCH OUTREACH AND
AWARENESS AND EDUCATION. TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES BUT ALSO
TO HELP KEEP THEM OUT OF
TROUBLE. NOW AS YOUR STATE
TREASURER- I OVERSEE THREE MAIN
DIVISIONS THE FIRST IS OUR CASH
MANAGEMENT SO ALL OF THE
REVENUES TAXI BY. OUR PENALTY
INTEREST COMES INTO OUR BANK
TOTALING ABOUT TWO POINT SIX
TRILLION DOLLARS A YEAR- I'M
PLEASE STAND. WHATEVER THE
CONTROLLER NEEDS ARE TO PAY
OUR- BILLS AND THEN THE REST I
INVEST OUR THROUGH OUR
INVESTMENTS DIVISION SO WE HAVE
ABOUT A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
IN SHORT TERM. OUR PORTFOLIO
70% OF THAT IS THE STATE'S IDLE
FUNDS. AND ONLY 30% REALLY
ISN'T THERE- 18% 80% OF THAT
70% IS THE GENERAL FUND. AMOUNT.
AND THE CONTROLLER TALKED ABOUT
HOW WE NEED THAT MONEY- RAINY
DAY OR EMERGENCY. OUR THIRTY-
THE PORT. IS FOR LOCAL GOT. ARE
WE MANAGE- THE IDLE CASH FOR
ABOUT TWO TWO WILL BECOME
ENTITIES. ARE AND SO THEY
ENTRUST THEIR MONEY WITH US IN
THE LOCAL AREA INVESTMENT BOND
AND WE CANNOT TOUCH THAT MONEY
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN- APPROPRIATE AFTER THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- I ALSO-
SHARE THE- PUBLIC FINANCE. OUR
DIVISION WHICH ISSUES ALL OF
THE STATE BONDS THE GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS REVENUE BONDS
AS WELL AS THE AGENT OF SALE
BORN B. HI. UC'S MSTS USE AMONG
OTHERS. ARE AND OUR BOND
PORTFOLIO IS ABOUT NINETY
BILLION DOLLARS RIGHT NOW AND
THE GOOD NEWS EVEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC IN APRIL WITH THE
FIRST STATE TO GO BACK INTO.
THE MARKET TO SELL OUR BONDS WE
WERE A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS BUT-
THE MARKET- BUT STRONG AND
INVESTORS HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SINCE THEN WE'VE
ISSUED ABOUT TEN DIFFERENT.
BONDS THAT HAVE BEEN HIGHLY.
SOUGHT OUT BY INVESTORS SO
THAT'S THE GOOD NEWS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I ALSO
CHAIR FIFTEEN DIFFERENT BOARDS
AUTHORITIES AND COMMISSIONS-
AND MANY OF THEM ARE FUNDING
AND FINANCING HOSPITALS
SCHOOLS. PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GREEN ENERGY
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING. AND THE
LIGHT AND I JUST WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE LISTENING- ON
THIS CALL. ARE IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. OUR
FIRST UNDER MY- JURISDICTION IS
OUR CAL CAP FOR SMALL BUSINESS-
WE PROVIDE A LOAN LOSS
GUARANTEED TO CERTAIN FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. ARE SO THAT THEY
WILL BE ENCOURAGED TO LOANS TO
THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAVE MAYBE.
YOU KNOW WHAT- THE CREDIT ISN'T
THAT GOOD OR THEY'RE HAVING-
PROBLEMS ACCESSING THE MARKET
SO THINK OF THE CAL CAP OR
SMALL BUSINESS AB THE LENDER OF
LAST RESORT. THEN I ALSO SIT ON
THE AYE BANKING THINK SCOTT WE
MAY TALK ABOUT THIS BUT THE
GOVERNOR EARLIER APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY PUT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. IN CHIU THE I THANK A
SMALL BUSINESS PROGRAM. WHICH
IN THE LONG GETS. PRO AND THAT
IS ALL VERY POP AND OVERS
SUBSCRIBED AND AGAIN HEALTH
THOSE UNDER COMMUNITIES HARD TO
ACCESS. OF BOTH- WHO ARE JUST
HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME.
ACCESSING THE PPP OR EVEN THE
E. IDL LOAN SO THOSE TWO
PROGRAMS ARE AVAILABLE. FOR A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS. THEN
SOMEONE DID MENTION- LAST WEEK
LAST FRIDAY THE GOVERNOR. OPEN
UP A NEW PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA
BE BUILDING FUNDS AND THIS IS
ALSO TO HELP SMALL BUSINESSES
WILL EMPLOY LESS THAN FIFTY
EMPLOYEES. ARE WITH REVENUES OF
LESS THAN TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION THE LOWER PAYMENT TIME
IS THREE TO FIVE YEARS WITH A
FOUR POINT 25% FIXED RATE OF.
INTEREST IN IT ARE AN APPLICANT
I DOES QUALIFIED THEY WILL BE
MATCHED UP WITH THE CBF FIVE TO
HELP THEM THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF THE LOAN PROCESS. AS WELL AS
MANAGING THEM UP THROUGH- BE
PAYMENT A LONG TERM SO THAT IS
A NEW PROGRAM WE THANK THE
GOVERNOR. FOR PUTTING MORE
MONEY INTO THAT. AND WE ARE
ALSO UNDERSTOOD THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY LACKS ANY
STATE SUPPORTED PROGRAM TO
INCENTIVIZE BANKS AND CREDIT
UNIONS TO OPEN UP BANKS.
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
HOWEVER. MY INVESTMENTS
DIVISION HAS A TIME DEPOSIT
PROGRAM WHERE WE PUT MONEY INTO
LOCAL HEADQUARTERED CALIFORNIA
BANKS. ARE WE PUT ANYWHERE FROM
TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WITH THE BANK SO THAT
THEY CAN LOAN IT OUT. TO THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES- WE EXPANDED
OUR THE POOL TO INCLUDE MORE
BAGS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY THE
CENTRAL COAST. ON THE NORTH
STATE AS WELL AS THE SOUTHERN
STATES- AND ESPECIALLY WHEN
THERE IS A DISASTER EVENT LIKE
A FIRE. MY FOLKS ARE CALLING TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THE BANK THE
LOCAL BANKS WHETHER THEY NEED A
LITTLE BIT OF ASSISTANCE ARE WE
CAN INFUSE MONEY AND THEY CAN
LEARN HOW TO GET. OF THE
COMMUNITY ARE BACK ON TRACK ARE
CURRENTLY. THE AMOUNT THAT IS
DEPOSITED IN LOCAL AGAIN LOCAL
HEADQUARTERED COMMUNITY BANKS
IS ABOUT. FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS. THIS AND ONE
OF THE THAT WE NEED WITH THE
WAS SENATOR BRADFORD BUILT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN SB SIX SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN. THIS WOULD HAVE
CREATED BANKING DEVELOPMENT
DISTRICTS SUPERVISED BY THE DPO
OR THE NEW DECAF PI SIMILAR TO
WHAT NEW YORK HAS ARE SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN AND IT
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF BANKS. OF BANK
BRANCHES OFF THAT WOULD SERVE
DEMONSTRATED NEEDS- TEN MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD GO TO EACH OF
THESE- BRANCH BANKS THAT OPENS.
AND WE THINK THAT THAT IS A
GOOD IDEA GOOD BUILT SINCE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS UNDERSTAND
THE NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
THE BEST. AND SO I JUST WANT
TO- YOU KNOW CONCLUDE BY SAYING
THAT- AB THREE TEN- IN THAT
LETTER I SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE I AM NOT AGAINST
EXPLORE RIGHT. THE BY BILITY
UPSTATE BANK BUT WANT TO BORROW
APPROPRIATE STUDY AND HOW WE
CAN DO THIS WITHOUT PUTTING
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET AND CREDIT
RATING AT BEST. WE WERE NEUTRAL
ON AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN I MEAN.
BUT WE THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS A
GOOD IDEA- BECAUSE DID NOT WORK.
A IN THE FINDINGS SOURCES IN
WAS GOING TO BE SOUTH. AND WERE.
ANDERSON LOOKING TO ONE LA R.
SAN FRANCISCO AS WELL AS THE
EAST BAY CITIES THAT ARE GOING
TO TAKE THE LEAD BUT CREATING
THESE MUNICIPAL BACK SO I AM
AVAILABLE. THANK YOU CAN ANSWER
ANY OTHER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
TREASURE MALL BEFORE WE MOVE TO
THE NEXT FOUND ARE GOING TO
OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS FROM
ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE. IN
THE CHAMBER REMOTELY- WHICH
ANYONE HAVE QUESTIONS FOR
EITHER A CONTROLLER OR
TREASURER. MISTER CHAIRMAN- JIM
NIELSEN ABOUT MIKE I'VE BEEN
HERE FOR A COMMENT GO RIGHT
AHEAD SOONER. MISTER CHAIRMAN
THAT I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THIS MOST RECENT TESTIMONY.
FROM OUR STATE ELECTED
OFFICIALS RESPONSIBLE OF THIS
VERY. GENERALLY I WILL NOTE
THAT THIS IS A LOT HAS A LONG
HISTORY. THE LAST TIME THAT
THIS GAINS TRACTION THAT
CALIFORNIA WAS THE LATE
SEVENTIES. I STATE BANK. IT WAS
LOOKED AT AT THE TIME IS YOUR
CURIOSITY. BUT THEN NOT IS A
GOOD IDEA. AND IT DID NOT
ADVANCE. I. I AM REMINDED THAT
WE ARE TRYING HERE TO REINVENT
THE WHEEL. AND IS THAT
NECESSARY I THINK NOT EDT IT
WAS MENTIONED. EARLIE IN THIS
TESTIMONY TODAY IF THERE'S ANY
AGENCY OF GOVERNMENT THAT DOES
NOT WORK. IT CDD NOW THERE ARE
MANY WHO DO NOT WORK TO THOSE
WHO PUT THEIR CONFIDENCE IN ALL
OF THE ANSWERS BEING A STATE
ENTITY IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
A STATE BANK. THAT IS FRAUGHT
WITH GREAT DANGER. EDIT
SUBJECTS THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH IF YOU WILL.
TO A ROLL OF LEGISLATION KNOW
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT. A BIG PART
OF THIS. EARLIER AFTER THE
STATE BANK WAS TOUTING SOCIALLY
CONSCIOUS INVESTING. THAT IS
RISKY BUSINESS TO SAY THE LEAST.
ANYONE WILL ATTEST TO THAT. IF
WE'RE GOING TO DO POLICY THEN
LET'S DO IT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHICH IS
MUCH MORE DELIBERATE PROCESS IN
SETTING UP AN AGENCY OF
GOVERNMENT WHO GUIDED
ADMINISTRATIVELY. MERELY BY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE REGULATIONS
EARLY SUBJECT TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
BUT THAT SHE GET FROM JACK'S
THE CITIZENS TO GREAT. GREAT
POLICY AND ECONOMIC RISK.
CALIFORNIA IS A NO GOOD
POSITION TO BE PROBLEMS MANY
THANKS. WE ARE TOUTED TO BE FOR
EXAMPLE THE HIGH TECH CAPITAL
OF THE WORLD. AND ALMOST NONE
OF THESE MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
HI TECH PROJECTS. IT BRACED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
COME IN ON TIME. NOR ON BUDGET.
IT'S BEEN A HUGE EMBARRASSED.
AND ALL THE STATE HAS DONE IS
TREATED AGENCIES SUPPOSEDLY TO.
STRAIGHTENED THE MESS OUT IT'S
BEEN AROUND I THINK SIX YEARS
SEVEN MAYBE EVEN EIGHT YEARS.
AND ALL IT'S MOSTLY
ACCOMPLISHED IS TO CHANGE ITS
NAME. TWO OR THREE TIMES. IF
CALIFORNIA CANNOT GET CHECKED
RIGHTS. THAT'S A PRETTY SAD
STATE. THANK YOU MY POINT IS IT
BE WARY TO PUT A LOT OF TRUST.
IN OUR FUTURE AND BANKING IN A
QUOTE STATE BANK. AND EVEN
MENTION NORTH DAKOTA. AS
RELATIVE TO AN ARGUMENT OR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IN
CALIFORNIA IS LUDICROUS. THERE
IS NO COMPARISON. AND I WOULD
ARGUE THAT NORTH DAKOTA IS
DEFICIENT SYSTEM IN THE SOUTH
BUT THAT SAID IT IS MINUSCULE
COMPARED TO THE COMPLEXITIES IN
THE MAGNITUDE OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE CALIFORNIA. SO WHEN
WE GET EXCITED ABOUT THE
GENERAL WE'RE GONNA. SO WE CAN
STILL HARM. PARDON WE'RE JUST
GONNA SHOULD YOU EVER QUESTION
SO WE CAN STAY ON TIME WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO STAY ON NO NO
I'M SORRY MR CHAIRMAN NO I DO
NOT I WAS MAKING AN OBSERVATION
BUT I THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE AN
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR THAT
OBSERVATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE I MAY HAVE SOME
COMMENTS I WILL COME BACK TO
YOU FOR SURE I SEE I HAVE
SENATOR CAFIERO WOULD QUESTION
AND THEN I WILL GO TO SENATOR
RUSSELL CENTER PROBABLY ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR I ATE I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I AM. THIS IS REALLY BEEN
A GREAT HEARING AND HAVE.
HAVING SUCH TALENT. AND AND
EXPERTISE. IN ALL OF THE
WITNESS THIS IS- IS REALLY
INCREDIBLE AND I AND I SAY THAT
BECAUSE- I- I THINK THERE ARE
REALLY GOOD ALTRUISTIC REASONS
FOR HAVING A STATE BANK. BUT I
ALSO FEEL JUST AS STRONGLY THAT
IT'S ALWAYS FRAUGHT WITH DANGER
WHEN THE STATE OR GOVERNMENT
WALKS INTO THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
ARENA AND SAYS WE THINK WE CAN
DO A BETTER JOB OF IT THAN YOU-
OR WE HAVE A DIFFERENT GOAL IN
MIND BY DOING IT OUR WAY AND-
I. I WAS INVOLVED IN THE
BEGINNING OF A BANK. AND I'VE
SEEN THE STRUGGLES. AND MAKING
DECISIONS AND CHOICES-
THANKFULLY THE BANK STILL
EXISTS BUT- WE SET IT UP TO BE
AN ALTRUISTIC BANK AND IN THE
END I THINK. IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET THERE- FOR
SOME REAL PRACTICAL FINANCIAL
REASONS AND SO IF A PRIVATE
INDUSTRY BANK HAS A HARD TIME
OF IT- THEN WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT. WHAT THE SOLUTION IS
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
REALLY- I'M INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT INFORMATION AND- AND-
THIS IS NOT GOING TO GO AWAY I
THINK THEY'LL CONTINUE TO BE A
DISCUSSION BUT THERE ARE SOME
LESSONS LEARNED. I THINK THAT-
THAT THAT WE'LL SEE IN- IN THE
MUNICIPAL BANKING. ARENA SO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT'S
ALL I HAVE. THANK SENATOR.
UNEXCEPTIONAL DORADO. THANK YOU-
MISTER- NOT A QUESTION BUT JUST
MAYBE IN SOME OTHER WAY WE
COULD ADDRESS THIS I UNDERSTAND
THAT- THE CURRENT LEGISLATIVE
VERSION DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
PMI. M. I. A. FUNDS- SO AT SOME
POINT WE SHOULD CLARIFY THAT
BUT- IT IS BOTH A AND R. IS
STEAMED AND I. THE DOOR OUR
CONTROLLER AND I TREASURE YOU
ALL YOUR HISTORY IS SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF YOU STAND FOR OUR
COMMUNITY I GUESS MY BASIC
QUESTION IS- IF THAT THE STATE
BANK DOESN'T WORK I'D LIKE TO
HEAR MORE ABOUT AGAIN DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE NOW BUT IN THE
FUTURE MORE ABOUT WINE. OR HOW
TO MAKE SURE IT CAN WORK WHAT
SHOULD WE DO TO MAKE IT WORK
FOR US BECAUSE FRANKLY TO SAY
THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM. EVEN
THE FINANCING THAT GOES FROM
BANKS TO THE CDFI. THAT'S NOT
WORKING- I GUESS SOMEONE FROM A
PANELIST MENTIONED SOMETHING
THAT IT WOULD TAKE US SEVENTY
YEARS AT THIS RATE AT THIS
PACE- TO GET THE- FINANCIAL
TOOLS THAT ARE NEEDED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR POOR
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. SO I DON'T GET. I'M
SORRY FOR THE POINT OF VIEW
THAT IS NOT WORKING WE'RE NOT
GETTING THE FUNDING- THAT WE
SHOULD IN OUR COMMUNITIES
PERIOD UNLESS WE HAVE SOME REAL
TEETH INTO IT. IT IS IT'S GOING
TO GO ON AND ON LIKE THIS
FOREVER THIS IS BEEN GOING ON
SINCE YOU KNOW I WAS A HIGH
SCHOOL OR COLLEGE ACTIVIST I
MEAN THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN OUT
THERE FOR YOU. YOU KNOW DECADES
AND DECADES WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO COME UP WITH EIGHT COUNTY
SYSTEM TO THE WAY THE CURRENT
BANKING SYSTEM- ADDRESSES OUR
NEEDS IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
IT'S OUR PUBLIC FUNDING. SO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TAKES ADVANTAGE
OF OUR FUNDS BUT DOESN'T
RECIPROCATE IN THE WAY THAT IT
SHOULD WITH OUR COMMUNITY SO.
IT'S A BROAD QUESTION. BUT I
DON'T GET THAT WE THAT OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM. WAS WORKING AT
ALL IT'S FAR FROM WORKING AND
OF THE BANKS ALWAYS SEEM TO BE
IN THE PLACE OF BEING PART OF
THE CULPRIT AND THE PROBLEM AS
TO WHY OUR COMMUNITIES DON'T
GET WHAT THEY NEED. ESPECIALLY
SMALL BUSINESSES. GREAT THANK
YOU. MY BROTHER WEAPON I'M
SORRY NOT RESPOND CENTRE
BRADFORD. YEAH TRIDUUM. THANK
YOU- SO YES TO SENATOR D'AMATO-
YOU KNOW COME FROM- A MINORITY-
COMMUNITY WE KNOW THAT IF-
FOLKS ARE NOT- DELIBERATES.
ABOUT NEEDING CERTAIN GOAL WELL
THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN AND
THAT'S WHY THE CALIFORNIA
REINVESTMENT ACT UP PASSED TO
ENCOURAGE MORE INVESTMENT IN
CERTAIN UNDER SERVED
COMMUNITIES I KNOW THAT WHEN WE
PUT MORE MONEY INTO CERTAIN
PROGRAMS THEY REALLY DO WORK
AND I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROGRAMS
I THANK GOD SENATORS. I MEAN
WHICH YOU MENTIONED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT GOVERNOR NEWSOM
LAST FISCAL YEAR ALLOCATED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IN LOW INCOME
STATE TAX CREDITS ANY ALLOCATED
ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
THIS YEAR AND BECAUSE OF THAT
WE ARE OVERSUBSCRIBED IN OUR
BONDS BECAUSE THOSE 4% TAX
CREDITS HAVE TO BE MATCHED WITH
OUR BONDS AND WE HAVE A LIMIT
OF FOUR POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN HOW MUCH BOND
CAPACITY WE HAVE BUT. BECAUSE
OF THAT EXTRA BOOST. WE NOW ARE
GOING TO. BE ALL AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COME TO MARK. QUICKER
THAN IN PAST SO WE APPRECIATE
THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE BANK FOR SMALL BUSINESS.
THE ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE
MILLION BUT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION RIGHT
THAT'S WHAT IS GOING TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING YOU CAN SEE
THAT MONEY DOES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN MOVING THE NEEDLE.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN AB
SIDE YES SO. RESPOND TO CONTROL
YOUR AUTHORITY THANK YOU-
SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS AND IT IS- YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT YOU KNOW OVER
TIME WE HAVE NOT SEEN MUCH
IMPROVEMENT BUT I THINK THAT
SUB BECAUSE OF REALLY- NOT
ASSISTING- FRANKLY STRATEGY OR
INVESTMENT IN TERMS OF HOW WE
STRENGTHEN AND COULD YOU
DESCRIBE THE CITY OF EYES. AND
I'M ACTUALLY VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THE- RECOVERY FUND BECAUSE OF
THIS IS ONE WHERE- YOU KNOW
OVER TIME I COULD SEE THAT I
BANKS- THE FUND THAT'S JUST
BEEN LAUNCHED BUT I BANKS BEING
CLOSER TO WHAT THE BANK OF
NORTH DAKOTA- ACTUALLY IS DOING
IN TERMS OF PETITIONS AND SO
YOU KNOW WHAT. I THINK REALLY
THAT THE- YOUR INITIAL QUESTION.
RESONATED WITH AND OUT OF SOME.
OF THESE OUR COMMUNITY THAT.
WHERE OF ONE SIZE FITS ALL
DOZEN WORK- THESE ARE
COMMUNITIES HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS
THIS ARE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED-
INDIVIDUAL ATTENTION. AND IT
IS- RELATE I THINK IMPORTANT TO
HAVE INSTITUTIONS THAT
UNDERSTAND AND ARE ABLE TO HELP
AFFECTED REACHED. INTO THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT. AND OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CDS LIES
BUT FRANKLY FOR NOT GOING AFTER
THAT CAPITAL ONE THESE LARGE
BANKS ARE LIKE. THEIR TRIPLE
OVER THERE. TRYING TO- GET
PROFITS TO WORK FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES A CALIFORNIA'S TO
STEP UP AND GET OUR SHARE. AND
I ONCE WE DO WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO- REALLY ELEVATE THE
CAPACITY OF THE CDFI SEMI
TECHNOLOGICALLY. SOME OF THEM
WERE VERY- HELPFUL IN TERMS OF
BEING THE CONDUIT FOR PDP
ASSISTANCE- DURING THE-
PANDEMIC- WITH THAT PROGRAM WAS
IN PLACE ON BECAUSE THEY DID
NOT HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
TRADITIONAL. BANKING
INSTITUTIONS BUT MANY WERE NOT
HELPFUL BECAUSE- THEY DON'T
HAVE THE ECONOMIC STILL IN
TERMS OF DOING THE LOAN
PROCESS. AND SO THIS IS WHAT WE
HAVE TO ELEVATE IS JUST THE
CAPACITY. OF BEING SURE THAT
WE'RE DIRECTING I MEAN THE BIG
BANKS OF MONEY TO GET FOR THIS
I SAY TAKE. A START REALLY
USING IT TO THE STRENGTHEN THE
INSTITUTIONS WE KNOW ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS AT LEAST
THE COMMUNITIES OF THE FLEXIBLE.
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GETTING THAT
ASSSTANCE OUT THERE. THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM.
C. NINE WE'RE GOING MOVE ON
CHIU THE NEXT. WHILE I'M IN SEE
IF- CAN G. AN TREASURY ARE YOU
SHOULD GOING TO STAY ON AFTER
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THAT COME
UP. YES THANK YOU YES ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- NEED TO RUN ITS
THERE ARE OTHER- TO STATE
AGENCIES- THIS. ONE THAT HAS
BEEN A REFERENCED ALREADY-
SCOTT WILL WHOSE EXACT DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA FOR STRUCTURING
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BANK
BETTER KNOWN AS I. BANK AND
THEN WE'LL HAVE YOUR FROM-
MANUAL ALVAREZ TO COMMISSIONER
FOR FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION SO FIRST UP. IS
MISTER WILL. HERE'S BRADFORD
AYE MCGUIRE AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE
BACKGROUND. ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA STRUCTURE AND
ECONOMIC BUILDING BANK OR AYE
**** I WAS APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF AYE BACK JUST UNDER
A YEAR AGO. PRIOR TO THAT I
WORKING PRIMARILY IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND A STINT IN
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION ON
ISSUES RELATED TO INVESTMENT
FINANCE. AND INNOVATIONS IN
COUPLE ACCESS. I'M HERE TODAY
TO RESPOND TO QUESTIONS FROM
YOUR COMMITTEES BUT WHAT MAKES
I BEG PROGRAMS ESSENTIAL TO
CALIFORNIA. THROUGH TOOLS LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING IN THE
SMALL BUSINESS FINANCE CENTER.
DURING THE COURSE OF THIS YEAR
I'VE BEEN QUICKLY IMMERSED IN
SHORT IN IN THE SHORT AND LONG
TERM NEEDS. OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
WE WORKED ON ESTABLISHING THE
GOVERNOR'S VISION FOR CLIMATE
CATALYST REVOLVING LOAN FUND
THROUGH THE STATE BUDGET. AND
GRATEFULLY RECEIVED THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT ON THIS
FRONT. IN APRIL AS MENTIONED WE
QUICKLY ESTABLISH THE KOBE
NINETEEN DISASTER RELIEF LOAN
GUARANTEE PROGRAM TO FILL GAPS
FOR BUSINESSES THAT HAD
DIFFICULTY QUALIFYING FOR
FEDERAL FUNDING THROUGH THE
CARES ACT. AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
COLLABORATING ON A PUBLIC
PRIVATE FINANCING PROGRAM JUST
MARKS SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESSES
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT REMAIN
UNDERSERVED AND UNDERBANKED.
ALL OF THESE ACTIVITIES TOOK
PLACE WELL I BAY CONTINUED ITS
DAY TO DAY BUSINESS OF
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE FINANCING
FOR PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE AND
PRIVATE ACTIVITIES. THAT
PROMOTE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND REVITALIZE COMMUNITIES. SO
WHAT PROGRAMS DO WE OFFER.
AFTER I BANK WAS CREATED IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR WE STARTED
WITH THE INFRASTRUCTURE STATE
REVOLVING LOAN FUND COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS I SURF. WHICH
PROVIDES LOW COST PUBLIC
FINANCING TO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES INCLUDING
DISPARITIES UNIVERSITIES
SCHOOLS AND HOSPITALS. AS WELL
AS NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
SPONSORED BY PUBLIC AGENCIES
FOR A WIDE VARIETY OF PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC
EXPANSION PROJECTS AND WHICH
ALSO CREATE JOBS. FINANCING
AMOUNTS RANGE FROM FIFTY
THOUSAND UP TO TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WITH LOAN TERMS FOR THE
USEFUL LIFE OF THE PROJECT
ABOUT TWO THIRTY YEARS.
EXAMPLES OF AYE IR FINANCED
PROJECTS INCLUDE WATER AND
WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANT
UPGRADES VENUE OR AIRPORT
CONSTRUCTION AND STREET REPAIRS
AND UPGRADES. I BEG ALSO BEGAN
ISSUING BONDS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER
QUALIFYING PROJECT FINANCING.
FUNDS FROM THE MUNICIPAL BONDS
ISSUED TO FINANCE PROJECTS THAT
BENEFIT CALIFORNIANS SUCH AS
COMMUNITY CENTERS SCHOOLS
BRIDGES MUSEUMS THEATERS IN
QUALIFYING EDUCATIONAL
FACILITIES. AS A CONDUIT BOND
ISSUER I BANK ISSUES FOR TYPES
OF TAXABLE AND TAX EXEMPT BONDS
ON BEHALF OF THE BORROWER. THE
INDUSTRIAL DEVELOPMENT BONDS
FIVE OH ONE SEE THREE BONDS
PUBLIC AGENCY REVENUE BONDS
EXEMPT THE SILLY BONDS. I THANK
HAS EXPANDED ITS PROGRAMS
INCLUDE SPECIALIZED GREEN
FINANCING SOLUTIONS AS WELL.
I'VE BEEN FINANCES DREAM
PROJECTS THROUGH THE AYE SIR
FOR BOB PROGRAMS BUT ALSO HAS
THE CALIFORNIA LENDING FOR
ENERGY AND ENVIRONMENTAL NEEDS
THE CLEAN CENTER. THE CLIMATE
TECH FINANCE PROGRAM AND THE
CRIME CALIFORNIA. THE CLEAN
CENTER PROVIDES DIRECT LOANS TO
THE SAME TYPE OF QUALIFYING
BARS AS I SERVE PROGRAM TO HELP
MEET THE STATE'S GOALS FOR
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION WATER
CONSERVATION ENVIRONMENTAL
PRESERVATION FINANCING CAN BE
THROUGH DIRECT LOAN FROM MY
BANK IN AMOUNTS FROM FIVE OR
THOUSAND. UP TO THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS. I'M A TECH FINANCE
PROGRAM IS A PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT THAT OFFERS
HIGHER LOAN GUARANTEES OF UP TO
NINETY PERCENT. FOR PROJECTS
THAT HELP REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GASES AND GO THROUGH IT AND
EXPERT TECH REVIEW. THE CLIMATE
HEALTH FUND WAS DESIGNED TO
OFFER FLEXIBLE WILL COST CREDIT
IN TRANSPORT TO STIMULATE
COMMERCIAL INVESTMENT PROJECTS
TO HELP MEET THE STATE'S GOALS
FOR GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION.
THIS PROGRAM WAS LAUNCHED WITH
AN INITIAL FUNDING REQUEST FROM
THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND BUT
WAS APPROVED WITHOUT FINDING
BECAUSE OF KOBE NINETEEN IS
IMPACT ON THE STATE'S BUDGET. I
BANK HOWEVER IS SEEKING TO
CAPITALISE CALLOUS FUND IN NEW
AND CREATIVE WAYS BECAUSE OF
THE URGENT NEED. THE CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS THEME HAS BEEN
PERVASIVE FOR US OVER THIS
ENTIRE YEAR AS WE ALSO FACE THE
CHALLENGE OF PROVIDING FOR THE
SUPPORT FOR SMALL BUSINESSES.
AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC BEYOND
OUR EXISTING SMALL BUSINESS
PROGRAMS WHICH I WILL DISCUSS
SHORTLY. NEEDLESS TO SAY EVEN
WITH THE ADDITION OF THE KOBE
NINETEEN IS ASTER GUARANTEES.
THANKS TO THE ALLOCATION OF
FUNDING FROM LEGISLATURE FOR
PANDEMIC RESPONSE. SMALL
BUSINESSES NEED FOR MORE. SO WE
HELP CREATE THE CALIFORNIA
REBELLING FUN. JUST LUNCH ON
FRIDAY THIS PROGRAM WILL RELY
ON A NEW PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP COLLABORATIVE TO
ADDRESS THE CAPITAL ADVISORY
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES AS THEY REOPEN AND
RECOVER FROM PANDEMIC. AMONG
AYE BANKS GREATEST ASSETS IS
THE EFFICIENCY AND EFFICACY OF
A SMALL TEAM OF FEWER THAN
FORTY STAFF I THINK IS TRULY MY
NEW TEAM OF EXPERTS TO HELP
MAKE TYPICALLY EXHAUSTIVE
FINANCING PROCESSES MORE
EFFICIENT AND LESS
OVERWHELMING. I BACK OFFERS IN
HOUSE LEGAL IN UNDERWRITING FOR
ITS CLIENTS STREAMLINING
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS AND
SAVING THE BORROWER VALUABLE
DOLLARS. WE'RE ABLE TO FINANCE
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS AS QUICKLY AS FORTY
FIVE TO SIXTY DAYS. AT BELOW
MARKET RATES WITH HASSLE FREE
CUSTOMER SERVICE AND TECHNICAL
SUPPORT FROM START TO FINISH.
EACH FINANCE APPLICATION IS
REAP REVIEWED EXTENSIVELY BY
BACK UNDERWRITERS BEFORE FULL
pPRESENTED TO THE BOARD.THE
BOARD MEMBERS ARE ALL CROSS
SECTOR EXPERTS IN THEIR OWN
RIGHT SEEKING THE RIVER
PRESERVE THE ADMISSION FISCAL
HEALTH RESPONSIBILITY AS WELL
AS PROMOTE PUBLIC BENEFIT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. I BACK HAS BEEN A
SELF SUSTAINING ENTITY ADDRESS
NO I KNOW DOLLARS IN THE
GENERAL FUND. FINALLY WHEN
YOU'RE STANDING YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THE SMALL BUSINESS
FINANCE CENTER IN THE
CALIFORNIA REBUILDING FUND.
I'LL START WITH THE SMALL
BUSINESS FINANCE CENTER WHICH
IS HOUSED WITHIN I MAKE AN
OPERATES THROUGH ITSOWN
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS POLICIES.
WE RYAN WITHIN THAT A SMALL
BUSINESS LOAN GUARANTEE PROGRAM
THAT OFFERS ELIGIBLE LENDERS A
MECHANISM TO PROVIDE LOANS TO
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT MAY
OTHERWISE NOT BE ABLE. AND THEY
MIGHT NOT OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN. UNDER COMMERCIAL
UNDERWRITING. IN THIS PROGRAM
LENDERS ARE PROVIDED UP 280%
COVERAGE I GUARANTEE BOND
DEFAULTS. I BANK WORKS WITH
PARTICIPATING LENDERS IN OUR
NETWORK OF FINANCIAL
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATIONS THAT
COVER THE ENTIRE STATE TO HELP
ENSURE SMALL BUSINESSES CAN
BENEFIT FROM THIS CREDIT HAS
BEEN PROGRAM. REGARDLESS OF
THEIR SIZE OR LOCATION. THE
SMALL BUSINESS FINANCE ARE ALSO
BENEFITS FROM A DIVERSE STAFF
AND FINANCIAL EXPERTISE HELD BY
THE PARTICIPATING LENDERS. WELL
I BANK APPROVES LOAN GUARANTEES
FARMERS WORK WITH THESE PARTNER
LENDERS DIRECTLY FOR THE LOAN
AS WELL AS WITH FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. TO PARTICIPATE N.
B. SMALL BUSINESS LOAN
GUARANTEE PROGRAM LETTERS MUST
POSSESS SUFFICIENT COMMERCIAL
AN EXPERIENCED. FINANCIAL AND
MANAGERIAL CAPACITY AND
OPERATIONAL SKILLS. IN WONDER
CAN APPLY FROM ROMAN INTO
GUARANTEE PROGRAM BY COMPLETING
OF UNDER STRICT CATION TO
PARTICIPATE AND I THINK WE'LL
EVALUATE THEM UNDER ACCORDINGLY.
THE CULMINATING DISASTER RELIEF
LOAN GUARANTEE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
ESSENTIALLY A SPECIAL I'M SORRY
ESSENTIAL ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
BUSINESSES THAT MAY NOT HAVE
QUALIFIED FEDERAL FUNDS. AS OF
FRIDAY IT HAS SUPPORTED SEVEN
EARNED TWENTY BUSINESSES
TOTALING MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS OF
CONDITIONALLY APPROVED LOANS.
OF THOSE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
SEVEN HAVE BEEN FOR MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES. HOW TO SAY
THAT 83% OF THE COVE IN
NINETEEN GUARANTEES SO FAR HAVE
GONE TO TARGET BARS. FEMALE
OWNED MINORITY OWNED OR
BUSINESS IS LOCATED IN THE LOW
TO MODERATE INCOME TRACKS. WITH
EITHER THE TRADITIONAL RECOVER
NINETEEN VERSIONS LOAN
GUARANTEES ARE OFTEN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BUSINESSES
BEING DENIED ALONE OR BEING
ABLE TO RETOOL REBUILD AND
REOPEN WITH ACCESSIBLE
AFFORDABLE CREDIT. AS MENTIONED
EARLIER THE CALIFORNIA
REVEALING FINE ORIGINATED FROM
MEMBERS OF THE RECOVERY TASK
FORCE AND IS A UNIQUE
COLLABORATION AGGREGATING
FUNDING FOR PRIVATE
PHILANTHROPIC AND PUBLIC SECTOR
SOURCES. INCLUDING AN
ENCOURAGEMENT A TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FROM THE STATE. THE
GOAL OF THE FUND IS TO ADDRESS
THE CAPITAL ADVISORY NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES AS
A SAFE WAY AND CREATIVELY
REOPENED AND RECOVER FROM THE
COLD NINETEEN AND ECONOMIC
CRISIS. THIS PROGRAM IS BUILT
TO SERVE THE SMALLEST A SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT MAKE UP AN
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR ECONOMY
WILL FOCUS ON HISTORICALLY
UNDER RESOURCED COMMUNITIES. TO
BE CLEAR I BANKS ROLE IS ONLY
IN PROVIDING MULTIPLE SOURCES
OF CREDIT SUPPORT TO CROWD IN
PRIVATE CAPITAL AND TO KEEP THE
COST OF FUNDS THE SMALL
BUSINESSES AFFORDABLE.
ADDITIONALLY THE NETWORK OF
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS SUPPORTED BY THE OFFICE
OF THE SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE
WITHIN GOBIZ. WILL BE ACTIVATED
TO PROVIDE TAILORED TECHNICAL
SUPPORT IN BUSINESS ADVISORS
SUPPORT TO THE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY RELATED TO THIS FUND.
OUR PARTNERS OFFER OTHER
SERVICES LENDING OUTREACH
TRAINING GOVERNANCE IN CAPITAL
MANAGEMENT. THE EFFORT IS BEING
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF ADVOCATES GRASSROOTS AND
BUSINESS SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE CALIFORNIA HISPANIC
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE CAL ASIAN
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE THE SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MICRO
ENTERPRISE OPPORTUNITY
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER NETWORK AND
CALIFORNIA'S WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTERS. I HOPE THIS ADDRESSES
YOUR QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT EXISTING UP
AND PROGRAMS BUT I SHOULD ALSO
LET YOU KNOW EVERY PUBLISHER
ANY REPORT FRIDAY AND THE SMALL
BUSINESS FINANCE CENTER THAT
INCLUDES MUCH OF HIS BACKGROUND
AND DETAILS ON THAT. ARE ON THE
SANTA. THESE ARE POSTED TO OUR
WEBSITE AND ALSO SENT TO THE
SECRETARY AND SENATE AND CHIEF
CLERK ASSEMBLY ANNUALLY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MR
WILL NEXT UP IS MISTER ALVAREZ.
IN MORNING SENATORS GERMAN
CHOIR AND SURE BRADFORD THANK
YOU COMMISSIONER THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
INVITATION TO MEET WITH YOU
THIS MORNING TO DISCUSS HOW.
THE NEWLY RENAMED DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION OVERSEES AND
REGULATES STATE CHARTERED BANKS
CALIFORNIA. I WILL OUTLINE HOW
THE DEPARTMENT ENSURES
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW AND
MAINTAINS CONSUMER SAFETY. I
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DISCUSS
WORLD BEHIND ON BILLS THAT WE
HAVE NOT SEEN OR ON BILLS THAT
ARE OUTSIDE OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
REGULATORY CURFEW. AS YOU KNOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION
FORMERLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT. IN THE
STATE'S MAIN FINANCIAL SERVICES
REGULATOR AND WE OVERSEE A
VARIETY OF FINANCIAL PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES. INCLUDING STATE
CHARTERED BANKS IN CALIFORNIA.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO THIS
MORNING IS ADDRESS A COUPLE OF
TOPICAL AREAS THAT WERE
SURFACED BY THE COMMITTEE.
NUMBER ONE I'M GOING TO REVIEW
THE DEPARTMENT'S TYPICAL
APPLICATION PROCESS IN
REVIEWING APPLICATIONS FOR
STATE CHARTERED BANKS. THEN I
WILL DISCUSS OUR TYPICAL
EXAMINATION PROCESS FOR FUTURE
BANKS. THEN I WILL TURN TO HOW
WE TYPICALLY RESOLVE ANY ISSUES
THAT ARE SURFACED DURING THE
EXAMINATION PROCESS. SO LET ME
START TODAY BY GIVING YOU ALL A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
APPLICATION PROCESS THAT ON YOU
BANKS ARE SUBJECT TO. WHEN THEY
DECIDE TO DO BUSINESS IN OUR
STATE. IN ORDER FOR NEW BANKING
TO OPEN IN CALIFORNIA. THEY
MUST SUBMIT AN APPLICATION FOR
A BANK CHARTER TO THIS
DEPARTMENT. USING THE AUTHORITY
AND GUIDANCE IN THE STATUTE WE
REVIEW THE APPLICATION TO
DETERMINE THE CHARACTER THE
REPUTATION AND THE FINANCIAL
STANDING OF THE ORGANIZERS
SEEKING TO OPERATE THE BANK. WE
ALSO REVIEW THE CHARACTER
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
BANKING EXPERIENCE AND BUSINESS
QUALIFICATIONS OF THE PROPOSED
BANK OFFICERS STAKEHOLDERS AND
DIRECTORS. WHEN APPLYING FOR A
BANK CHARTER THE DEPARTMENT
REQUIRES A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF INFORMATION INCLUDING BUT
CERTAINLY NOT LIMITED TO. THE
PROPOSAL BUSINESS PLAN THE
PROPOSED A SLATE OF DIRECT.
ACTORS PROPOSED OFFICERS
EMPLOYEES ANY ANY ADVISORS THE
NAMES OF THOSE ORGANIZING THE
PROPOSED BANK. PROPOSED PROCESS
AS WELL AS PROPOSED OPERATIONS
AND PRE OPENING EXPENDITURES.
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD REVIEW
SUCH AN APPLICATION AND APPROVE
OR DENY IT BASED ON A VARIETY
OF FACTORS AGAIN INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO. THE PUBLICATION
BEING INSTANT ADVANTAGE WHETHER
THE APPLICATION POSES A
REASONABLE PROMISE OF
SUCCESSFUL OPERATION. WHETHER
THERE'S ADEQUACY IN THE CAPITAL
STRUCTURE AND WHETHER PROPOSED
OFFICERS AND DIRECTORS HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE OF THE REQUISITE
SKILLS TO LAUNCH SUCCESSFUL
OPERATION. THIS APPLICATION AND
APPROVAL PROCESS GIVES THE FBI
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE THE
BANKS PROPOSED BUSINESS PLAN
ITS FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES THE PROPOSED MARKETS
THEY PLAN TO SERVE AND WHETHER
OR NOT SUCH OPERATIONS WOULD BE
SUSTAINABLE AND MEET THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. IN THE AREAS THEY
PLAN TO SERVE. BELLAMY DISCUSS
A LITTLE BIT- THE EXAMINATION
PROCESS ONCE AND ONCE- TWENTY
APPLICATION IS APPROVED AND
BECOMES PART OF OUR PORTFOLIO.
WHAT THE BANK APPLICATION IS
APPROVED THE BANK WILL THEN
HAVE TO UNDERGO REGULAR
EXAMINATIONS. TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW. FOR
THE FIRST THREE YEARS OF
OPERATION THE DEPARTMENT
CONDUCTS A YEARLY ASSESSMENT.
AFTER THAT WE MOVED INTO AN
EXAM CYCLE BASED ON ASSET SIZE
OF THE INSTITUTION. THANK THAT
ARE LESS THAN THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN TOTAL ASSETS ARE
EXAMINED EVERY EIGHTEEN MONTHS
AND THOSE WITH MORE THAN THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN ASSETS ARE
EXAMINED EVERY TWELVE MONTHS.
THOSE WITH MORE THAN TEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ASSETS ARE
EXAMINED ANNUALLY. AND WITH
SEVERAL TARGETED REVIEWS THAT
ARE PERFORMED THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR. IF A BANK AT ANY TIME
BECOMES TROUBLED AND WE DEFAULT
BACK TO A MORE AGGRESSIVE
ANNUAL EXAMINATION CYCLE THAT
INCLUDES IN THE NORMAL COURSE
OF COURSE IN PERSON VISITS
EVERY SIX MONTHS UNTIL
OPERATIONS RETURN THREE
SATISFACTORY LEVEL. BUT
TROUBLED BANK IS ONE THAT
EXISTS TO SOME DEGREE OF
SUPERVISORY CONCERN IN AREAS
THAT ARE RELATED TO CAPITAL
ASSET MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
EARNINGS BUT QUALITY. AND
SENSITIVITY TO MARKET RISK. THE
MAY HAVE SEVERAL VIOLATIONS OF
LAW AND ARE NOT ADEQUATELY
COMPLIED WITH THE LAW. A BANK
BECOME SATISFACTORY WHAT WE ARE
SURE THAT THE BANK IS
FUNDAMENTALLY SOUND AND CAN
WITHSTAND BUSINESS FLUCTUATIONS.
AND THE INSTITUTION ALIGNS
COMES IN SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE
WITH THE LAW. I MEAN I'LL TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT TYPICALLY DOES WITH
ANY ISSUES THAT ARISE
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
EXAMINATION PROCESS. IF THE
DEPARTMENT FINDS THAT A BANK
LICENSEE IS ACTING
INAPPROPRIATELY. WE QUICKLY
IDENTIFY HOW BEST TO RESPOND WE
HAVE SEVERAL DIFFERENT OPTIONS
AND TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL. ONE
OPTION IS TO CONDUCT AN
INFORMAL ENFORCEMENT ACTION
THROUGH A MEMORANDUM FROM THE
OF UNDERSTANDING BUT OUTLINES
FORMAL RECOMMENDATIONS THE
DEPARTMENT IS ASKING THE BANK
TO TAKE IN ORDER TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE. WELL THESE ARE NOT
PUBLICLY NOR THE LEGALLY
BINDING THEY DO ENSURE THAT A
BANK EXPLICITLY UNDERSTANDS THE
STEPS IT NEEDS TO TAKE IN ORDER
TO. BECOME A IN ORDER TO COME
INTO GOOD STANDING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. ALTERNATIVELY THE
BANK THE DEPARTMENT CAN ALWAYS
TAKE FORMAL ACTION. AGAINST AN
INSTITUTION IF THE SEVERITY OF
ISSUES THAT THE INSTITUTION OF
RISE TO THAT LEVEL SUCH FORMAL
ACTION CAN INCLUDE ANY OF THE
FOLLOWING. PLACING THE BANK
UNDER A FORMAL ORDER EITHER
INDEPENDENTLY OR ALONGSIDE THE
FDIC. ORDERING THE BANK TO
CEASE AND DESIST FROM VIOLATING
THE LAW OR ACTING IN AN UNSAFE
OR UNSOUND MANNER. THESE
ACTIONS MAY CAUSE INSOLVENCY-
SIGNIFICANT DISSIPATION OF
ASSETS OR EARNINGS. WEAKENED
CONDITIONS OR PREJUDICE
CONSUMER INTERESTS. WE MAY ALSO
SEND AN ORDER RELATING TO AN
ACTOR BOOKS OR RECORDS.
ALTERNATIVELY WE CAN ORDER THE
SUSPENSION OR REMOVAL OF A
PERSON OR A OR PROHIBITS
PERSONS PARTICIPATION AND THE
BANK'S OPERATIONS. IN
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES THE
DEPARTMENT CAN EVEN TAKE
POSSESSION OF THE BANK. ALL OF
THOSE VARIETY OF TOOLS OKAY
SURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT CAN
ENFORCE CALIFORNIA LAW AND
PROTECT CONSUMERS. LASTLY THE
COMMITTEE TODAY AFTER TO
DISCUSS ANY APPLICATIONS THAT
WE'VE RECEIVED FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WISHING TO CREATE A
LOCAL PUBLIC BANK PURSUANT TO
BE A FIFTY SEVEN. AS AS OF
TODAY WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY
APPLICATIONS I SHOULD ALSO NOTE
HOWEVER THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
NOT YET COMPLETED REGULATIONS
RELATING TO LOCAL PUBLIC BANK
APPLICATIONS UNDER AB EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN. WELL WE CAN'T
ACCEPT APPLICATIONS WE CANNOT
ACT UPON AN APPLICATION UNTIL
THE APPLICATION IS FULLY
COMPLETE. THE REGULATIONS THAT
WERE WORKING ON WOULD HELP
CLARIFY WHAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
GOING TO NEED- WHO IS GOING TO
BE LOOKING FOR AND OUT FOR A
COMPLETE APPLICATION. THE
NOTICE OF PROPOSED RULEMAKING
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE ON FRIDAY
DECEMBER FOURTH. FROM THAT
POINT ON WE WILL HAVE FORTY
FIVE DAYS OF PUBLIC COMMENTS
AND WE EXPECT THE RULES TO BE
FINALIZED- WITHIN THE YEAR.
ONCE THOSE REGULATIONS ARE
FINALIZED WE MAY SEE APPLICANTS
BEGIN TO FILE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT- AND I SHOULD
CLARIFY MORE SPECIFICALLY I DID
NOTICE IN THE BRIEFING
MATERIAL- IN ONE OF THE- ONE OF
THE Q. AND A.'S- THERE IS A-
THERE IS A RESPONSE TO ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS INDICATING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HAD. INDICATED
THAT WE WOULD NOT ACCEPT
APPLICATIONS UNTIL THE
REGULATIONS WERE COMPLETE AGAIN
I HOPE TO HAVE I HOPE THAT I'VE
CLARIFIED THAT POINT- WE
CERTAINLY WILL REVIEW
APPLICATIONS WE CERTAINLY WOULD
REVIEW APPLICATIONS AND WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO DO SO. BEFORE
ANY REGULATIONS ARE COMPLETE-
HOWEVER ANY SUCH APPLICATION
WOULD ITSELF NEED TO BE
COMPLETE- AND WE THINK IT IS
LIKELY PRUDENT FOR ANY PROPOSED
ORGANIZER'S TO WAIT UNTIL- THE
REGULATION PROCESS IS COMPLETE.
IN ORDER TO- IN ORDER TO BEGIN
FILING SUCH AN APPLICATION.
WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK-
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE TIME AND
I AND MY STAFF STAND READY TO.
PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION OR ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER DOES ANY SENATOR
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
COMMISSIONER ALVAREZ OR
DIRECTOR. WHAT THE STOCK. SEEN
NONE IN THE CHAMBER. SEEING NO
HANDS IS UP. ON THE SCREEN.
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
MOVING AND WE'RE GONNA. TURN AT
THE PODIUM BACK OVER TO SENATOR
MCGUIRE SHOW HE CAN BRING FORTH.
OUR FINAL GROUP WHICH SPEAKERS
ARE STAKEHOLDERS PERSPECTIVE.
AND THEN WE'LL OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT ANSWERING
QUESTIONS AT THE TIME CINNABAR
OKAY I WILL HAVE A QUESTION-
ONCE YOU FINISH.
THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER BRADFORD AND AGAIN
GRATEFUL FOR THE PARTNERSHIP
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE BOTH
COMMITTEES WERE NOT TO BE
MOVING ON TO OUR FINAL OUR
FINAL. PANEL OF THE DAY WE WANT
TO REMIND FOLKS IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING AND WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO OFFER A COMMON
UNDER PUBLIC COMMENT THAT'S
GONNA BE COMING UP AFTER THIS
FINAL PANEL WE'RE GOING TO
INVITE YOU TO BE ABLE TO CALL
IN EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR WE'RE
LOOKING FORTY HEARING FROM YOU
AT. 844-291-6364 YOU'RE GONNA
WANT TO ENTER THAT CODE. SIX
ZERO FIVE SEVEN SIX FIVE THREE
AGAIN WILL BE GETTING THE
PUBLIC COMING RIGHT AFTER THIS
FINAL PANEL. ALL IGHT NUMBERS
AND THIS IS WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR FROM STAKEHOLDERS
REPRESENTING INDUSTRY AS WELL
AS DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM NONI
RAMOS IS A SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER FROM ENTERPRISE
COMMUNITY LOAN FUND WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR FROM ROBERT WILSON HE'S
A FIGHT THE VICE PRESIDENT
STATE. GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS IN
THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION
LEAGUE WILL THEN BRING IN JASON
LANE VICE PRESIDENT AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
TINA VERNON. NEVER NEVADA
COUNTY TREASURER AND PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTY TREASURERS AND TAX
COLLECTORS LET'S GET INTO IT
THAT WE'RE GONNA ASK THAT TO
EACH OF OUR PANELISTS HERE IN
THIS FINAL FINAL PANEL PLEASE
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO FIVE
MINUTES FOR RUNNING JUST A BIT
BEHIND. FOR FIRST GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO NONI RAMOS AGAIN
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT AND CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER FOR THE
ENTERPRISE COMMUNITY LOAN FUND-
NONI WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU A
PROMPT WHEN YOU HIT BUT A
pMINUTE AWAY FROM THAT FIVE
MINUTES. THE FLOOR'S YOURS IN
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING AND
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M TONY RAMOS
AND ON BEHALF OF ENTERPRISE
COMMUNITY LOAN FUND ON THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION. FOR
COMMUNITY INVESTMENT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY REPRESENTING THE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION SECTOR OR CDFI.
SIGNIFIES ARE MISSION DRIVEN
LENDERS AND INVESTORS COMMITTED
TO IMPROVING ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. HEALTH
FACILITIES SAFE DRINKING WATER
SMALL BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. SIGNIFIES INCLUDE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT LOAN
FUNDS BANKS VENTURE CAPITAL
FUNDS AND CREDIT UNIONS. CDFI
UNDERSTAND AND CAN QUICKLY
RESPOND TO THE NEEDS OF
CONSUMERS AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND ARE UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO RESPOND TO RELIEF
AND RECOVERY DURING CRISIS AS
WE DID DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION AND MORE RECENTLY
DURING THE COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. CITIFIED ENABLE
COMMUNITIES TO ACCESS CAPITAL
THAT CREATES JOBS BUILDS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUPPORT
SMALL BUSINESSES CULTIVATE
HEALTHY FOOD AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. C. DEFIES ON PORTEN
PART OF THE COUNTRY'S FINANCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WORKING IN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE UNDER
SERVED BY TRADITIONAL LENDERS.
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
COMMUNITY INVESTMENT IS A
COALITION OF FORTY C. DEFIES
WHICH PROVIDE INVESTING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. OUR COALITION
INCLUDES AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SMALL BUSINESS LENDERS CREDIT
UNIONS MICROLENS- IS HOUSING
TRUST FUNDS AND OTHER MISSION
DRIVEN FINANCIAL SUPPORT
PROVIDERS. ENTERPRISE COMMUNITY
LOAN FUND IS A NATIONAL
CERTIFIED CDFI WHOSE MISSION IS
TO DELIVER INNOVATIVE FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO MISSION ALIGNED
ORGANIZATIONS. ARE BORROWERS
ACQUIRE DEVELOP AND PRESERVE
QUALITY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT'S CONNECTED TO GOOD JOBS
FIRST RATE SCHOOLS
TRANSPORTATION AND HEALTHY
LIVING ENVIRONMENTS. SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY WE HAVE
INVESTED MORE THAN ONE POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLARS IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WELL DESIGNED AFFORDABLE HOMES
MAKE UP THE FOUNDATION OF OUR
INVESTMENT APPROACH. AND WE
HAVE BUILT OR PRESERVED OVER A
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE HOMES. WE CONNECT
THOSE HOMES TO COMMUNITY ASSETS
THAT EXPAND RESIDENT
OPPORTUNITY WITH OUR FINANCING
HELPING TO CREATE OVER SIXTEEN
THOUSAND EDUCATIONAL SEATS AND
FACILITATING ROUGHLY SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND HEALTH CARE
VISITS. FOR EXAMPLE RECENTLY
WORKED FOR THE CALIFORNIA BASED
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER TO PROVIDE A ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLAR RE
DEVELOPMENT LOAN TO CONSTRUCT A
FIFTY THREE UNIT PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FACILITY FOR
HOMELESS VETERANS. AND THOSE
FORMALLY EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. ARE PRE
DEVELOPMENT LOAN ALLOWED
DEVELOPER TO COMPLETE CRITICAL
PRE CONSTRUCTION WORK LIKE
ARCHITECTURAL DRAWINGS AND COST
AND- USING A COST ESTIMATE FOR
WHICH THERE IS NOT OTHERWISE
READILY AVAILABLE FUNDING. THE
DEVELOPER PLANS TO PROVIDE ON
SITE SERVICES THAT INCLUDE
EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT.
ASSISTANCE SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
HEALTH TEATMENT AFTER SCHOOL
ACADEMIC SUPPORT AND COMMUNITY
ACTIVITIES. ANOTHER GREAT
EXAMPLE OF THE WORK OF
SIGNIFIES IS SMALL BUSINESS
LENDING LIKE THAT OF CDC SMALL
BUSINESS FINANCE THE CALIFORNIA
CDFI. THEY RECENTLY HELPED ARMY
VETERAN ORLANDO TELEPHONE WANT
HIS OWN BUSINESS AFTER TWENTY
YEAR CAREER IN THE MILITARY. IN
THE BEGINNING WITHOUT A STEADY
REVENUE STREAM HE WAS UNABLE TO
SECURE OPERATING CAPITAL HE
NEEDED FROM A TRADITIONAL
LENDER. BUT CDCSMALL BUSINESS
FINANCE WAS ABLE TO OFFER A
SMALL BUSINESS LOAN AND ONGOING
TRAINING AND ASSISTANCE TO HELP
HIM BUILD HIS BUSINESS. OUR
CITY IF I COALITION IS WATCHING
CLOSELY THE DISCUSSION
REGARDING THE POTENTIAL
FORMATION OF A PUBLIC BANK IN
CALIFORNIA. CDFI IS WORK TO
BRING CAPITAL TO LOW INCOME AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
FINANCIAL RESOURCES FROM THE
PUBLIC GET BANK COULD BE
LEVERAGED BY CEDIA FIGHTS.
THESE FINANCIAL RESOURCES COULD
INCLUDE CREATING A SECONDARY
MARKET FOR CDFI ORIGINATED
LOANS RESULTING IN GREATER
LIQUIDITY. AND DIRECTLY
INVESTING INCENTIVIZE TO
STRENGTHEN OUR BALANCE SHEET.
BOTH OF THESE ACTIVITIES WOULD
ALLOW CDFI IS TO HAVE EVEN
GREATER IMPACT IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE WORK ONE
MINUTE THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY AND PROVIDE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE CDFI SECTOR. THIS
FROM US THANK YOU SO MUCH GREAT
JOB DO APPRECIATE YOUR WORDS
TODAY AND THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR BEING WITH US ON THIS
THANKSGIVING WEEK IS FROM US IS
GONNA BE HANGING OUT AND TO IF
WE HAVE QUESTIONS. FROM
SENATORS HERE IN JUST A FEW
MOMENTS WILL BE ABLE TO ASK-
HERE AT BUT FIRST WE'D LIKE TO
BE RETURNED TO ROBERT WILSON.
MISTER WILSON IS THE VICE
PRESIDENT STATE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION LEAGUE HE'S GOING
TO BE TESTIFYING FOR FIVE
MINUTES O THIS ISSUE. MISTER
WALKER MISTER WILSON WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS OR- GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND SENATORS ARE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
SPEAK WITH YOU ALL TODAY- AS
CHAIR JUST THAT I'M VICE
PRESIDENT STATE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AT THE CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION LEAGUE. THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
REPRESENTS NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
CREDIT UNIONS. AND THEY'RE OVER
TWELVE MILLION MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I WANT TO
TOUCH ON TWO MAIN POINTS DURING
MY TESTIMONY TODAY. THE FIRST
IS A TIME DEPOSIT PROGRAM. HOW
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ARE
INVOLVED AND THE SECOND IS THE
WORK IS BEEN DONE THUS FAR
PUBLIC BANKING IN THE STATE.
THE PILOT THE TIME DEPOSIT. WAS
CREATED IN NINETEEN FORTY FIVE
AND ALLOWS THE STATE TREASURER
TO PLACE DEPOSITS WITH ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. ELIGIBLE
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDE FEDERALLY
INSURED COMMERCIAL BANKS
SAVINGS BANKS AND CREDIT UNIONS
OR AUTHORIZED TO ACCEPT
DEPOSITS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE GOAL THE TIME
DEPOSIT PROGRAM IS TO STIMULATE
LOCAL ECONOMIES BY SUPPORTING
LOCAL FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
THAT SERVE THE INTERESTS OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES. AS OF AUGUST
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY NEARLY
88% OF THE INSTITUTIONS
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM
WERE UNDER TEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN ASSETS MEANING SMALL
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. THIS
PROGRAM BENEFITS THE SMALLER
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS BY
PROVIDING THEM WITH ANOTHER
SORTS OF DEPOSITS THAT THEY MAY
NEED TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND THE PROGRAM
GENTLY OFFERS BETTER RATES AND
AVAILABLE FROM OTHER SOURCES.
THE TIME DEPOSIT PROGRAM
BENEFITS THE COMMUNITIES BY
STIMULATING GROWTH IN SMALL
BUSINESSES AND HELPING
COMMUNITIES THRIVE BY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
MORTGAGE LOANS AUTO LOANS AND
OTHER LANDING IN THE COMMUNITY.
THE PROPOSAL TO CHANGE THE
STATE I MAKE A DEPOSIT A PUBLIC
DEPOSITORY INSTITUTION WE'RE
TAKING THESE IMPORTANT POSITIVE
WAY FROM THE SMALL LOCAL
FINANCIALS ACCUSED WITHIN FIVE
YEARS. AND THAT'S THE WAY FOR
SOME OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY SERVE. THE GOAL OF PUBLIC
BANKS TO SERVE THE COMMUNITIES
WHICH WHAT CREDIT UNIONS AND
COMMUNITY BANKS AND SEE IF AYE
AYES ARE CURRENTLY DOING WITH
THESE DEPOSITS. I WANT TO SHIFT
GEARS AND BRIEFLY DISCUSS THE
WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE THUS
FAR PUBLIC BANKING. AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT A LITTLE BIT
ALREADY LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN WHICH ALLOWS CITIES
AND REGIONS TO CREATE THEIR OWN
PUBLIC BANKS AFTER SUBMITTING A
PLAN. DEPARTMENT FINANCIAL
PROTECTION INNOVATION. THIS IS
A MONUMENTAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ONE THAT PRETTY
MUCH EVERYONE IN THIS VIRTUAL
ROOM BARS WORKED VERY
DILIGENTLY ON. ALL FOR A GREAT
LEAGUE WAS NO DIFFERENT WE WERE
ABLE TO MOVE TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION AFTER A FEW ROUNDS
AMENDMENT ON EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN. WE APPRECIATE. WHEN THE
I. BANK PROPOSAL POPPED UP LAST
YEAR MY MEMBER CREDIT USE HAVE
ONE BIG QUESTION WHY NOW. EVEN
IF WE ARE NOT IN A COVERT
SHORTENED SESSION MY MEMBER
PARTIES WERE STILL LEFT
WONDERING WHY DO WE NOT SEE HOW
AB FIFTY SEVEN PANS OUT. NOT
EVEN A YEAR POST ENACTMENT DATE
WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE WELL IN
PUBLIC BANKING. ARE WE CLING
LOCAL PUBLIC BANKS A SUCCESS
ALREADY. OR WAS IT REALIZED
WITHOUT THE STATE PUBLIC BANK
THE LOCAL MODELS NOT POSSIBLE.
WITH AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN THERE
IS POTENTIAL FOR A PARTNERSHIP.
BETWEEN LOCAL FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. AND THE LOCAL
BANKS. AND WE STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT WE SHOULD WAIT AND SEE HOW
THAT PLAYS OUT BEFORE EXPAND
THE SCOPE PUBLIC BANKING
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THIS
WILSON THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US
HERE TODAY THAT MISTER WILSON
WILL ALSO BE HANGING OUT IF WE
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM. THE SENATORS IN JUST A
FEW MOMENTS WE'VE TO ADDITIONAL
PANELISTS WHO WILL BE
PARTICIPATING IN THIS FINAL
PANEL LET'S GO TO JASON LANE
HIS LINE IS VICE PRESIDENT
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS. THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION MISTER LANE
WE WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE
YOU ONE MINUTE PROMPT SELLING
THE FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. SHE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ON THIS
MATTER WE AGREE WITH THE PRIOR
COMMENTS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS ALREADY ADDRESSED THE ISSUE
OF PUBLIC BANKING. LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES ASKED FOR THE
ABILITY TO CREATE PUBLIC BANKS
AND THE LEGISLATURE GRANTED
THEM THAT AUTHORITY THIS VERY
LAST LEGISLATIVE SESSION. WELL
THE PROPONENTS OF PUBLIC BANKS
OF DISCUSSES VIRTUES WE STILL
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
PERCEIVED- BENEFITS OUTWEIGH
THE RISKS PARTICULARLY WHEN WE
CONSIDER THE GENERAL FUND IS
THE RESCUE. TO HELP ILLUSTRATE
THIS VIEW I'D LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
CURRENT ENVIRONMENT THAT BANKS
FIND THEMSELVES IN RIGHT NOW
AND- I APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE FOR
USING BANK TERMINOLOGY. WELL
THERE ARE PLENTY OF BANKS
OFFERING SERVICES TO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES THERE'S A GREAT
DEAL OF CONSOLIDATION WITHIN
THE INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW.
INTEREST RATES ARE AT HISTORIC
LOWS AND THEY LIKELY WILL BE
FOR QUITE SOME TIME THIS IS
RESULTED IN AN INDUSTRY WIDE
DECREASE IN NET INTEREST INCOME
WHICH IS AN INDICATOR OF THE
BANKS PROFITABILITY. ONE OF
BANKS NET INTEREST INCOME
DECREASES WHILE THE BANK IS
TRYING TO MAINTAIN ADEQUATE
CAPITAL RATIOS ONE OF THE ONLY
LOVERS OF BANK AND PULL AN
EFFORT NOT TO LOSE MONEY IS AN
EXPENSE REDUCTION. SO BANKS
EFFICIENCY RATIO BECOMES VERY
IMPORTANT. THIS RATIO IS A
MEASURE OF A BANK'S OPERATING
EXPENSE SO IT'S A VERY
CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW AND THE
STATE BANK IS GOING TO HAVE ALL
THE SAME CHALLENGES. ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE IS CAN A STATE BANK
BE EFFICIENT ENOUGH TO NOT LOSE
MONEY IN THIS ENVIRONMENT WHICH
CAN ABSOLUTELY HAPPEN. A PUBLIC
BANKS OVERHEAD IN COST OF FUNDS
OR GOING TO BE THE SAME AS A
PRIVATE ENTITY AND IF THAT
PUBLIC BANK IS. NOW GOING TO
MAKE LOW INTEREST LOANS AS IT
IS PROPOSED TO DO THAT IS GOING
TO HAVE EVEN MORE OF A
COMPRESSED NET INTEREST MARGIN
AND HAVE TO BE EVEN MORE
EFFICIENT. LAYER ON TOP OF THAT
THE FACT THAT THE PROPONENTS
ARE ADVOCATING FOR THIS PUBLIC
BANK TO ENGAGE IN SOME FAIRLY
RISKY LENDING ACTIVITY. SO NOW
THE BANK IS GOING TO HAVE TO
SET ASIDE EVEN MORE MONEY FOR
LOSS RESERVES. AND PROVISION
FOR IT ACCORDING TO REGULATION
AND THAT'S GOING TO EAT INTO
ITS CAPITAL. WE DON'T SEE HOW A
PUBLIC BANK OPERATING IN THIS
MANNER OUT LIKE BRED BY THE
PROPONENTS AND CERTAINLY AS
DESCRIBED. IN AB THREE TEN CAN
SURVIVE IN THIS ENVIRONMENT
CERTAINLY A PRIVATE ENTITY
COULD NOT. AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHY YOU'RE SEEING SO MUCH
CONSOLIDATION IN THE INDUSTRY
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IT'S A VERY
CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENT YOU
DON'T SEE A LOT OF NEW BANKS.
STARTING UP FOR THIS PARTICULAR
REASON. NO WE ARE CERTAIN
ENCOURAGE TO HEAR THAT PUBLIC
BANK PROPONENTS ACCEPT THE IDEA
THAT A PUBLIC BANK NEEDS TO BE
REGULATED THOUGH THERE SEEMS TO
BE SOME DISPUTE. AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT DEPOSITS WOULD BE
INSURED AS EIGHTY THREE TEN DID
NOT REQUIRE THAT. WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT REGULATION IS VITAL.
VITALLY IMPORTANT TO THE SAFETY
AND SOUNDNESS OF THE BANKING
SYSTEM BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
A PUBLIC BANK. MUST BE
REGULATED IN THE SAME MANNER AS
A PRIVATE INSTITUTION. S. TO
DEPOSIT INSURANCE SINCE THESE
ARE IN ESSENCE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
REALLY GENERAL FUND REVENUE
THEN THEY SHOULD ABSOLUTELY BE
INSURED. BUT WHAT YOU'RE BEING
ASKED TO DO AS A LEGISLATURE IS
NOT JUST CONSIDER THE FORMATION
OF AN INJURY THAT TAKES
DEPOSITS AND MAKES LOANS. WHICH
ARE ALSO BEING ASKED TO
CONSIDER THE ENTIRE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THAT
ENTITY. FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF THE
AREAS THAT THE BANKING INDUSTRY
HAS EXCELLED IN HIS
CYBERSECURITY. BANKS OFTEN KNOW
WHEN FRAUD HAS OCCURRED ON AN
ACCOUNT BEFORE THE CUSTOMER
DOES. THE IS VERY COMPLEX
ALGORITHMS AND FRAUD FILTERS TO
DETECT FRAUD. YOU JUST DON'T
SEE A LOT OF DATA BREACHES
OCCURRING IN THE BANKING
INDUSTRY. BUT THERE'S A COST TO
PROTECTING CUSTOMERS. THE
LARGEST BANKS ARE SPENDING
NORTH OF THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND IT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CYBERSECURITY. SO LEGITIMATE
QUESTION BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
NOW IS DOES THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE THE IT SYSTEMS
TO SUPPORT A BANKING NETWORK.
AGAIN THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE
OF THE NUMEROUS. CHALLENGES OF
PUBLIC BANK WILL HAVE. THEN THE
NOTION THAT A PUBLIC BANK CAN
BETTER SERVE ITS COMMUNITIES
THAN PRIVATE ENTITIES. BUT
STATE BANK WOULD HAVE NO BRICK
AND MORTAR PRESENCE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE PROPONENTS FOR PUBLIC
BANKING CONTEND THAT THEY WILL
PARTNER WITH LOCAL COMMUNITY
BANKS AND CREDIT UNIONS. BUT IN
ORDER FOR A PUBLIC BANK TO
EXIST IT WOULD NEED TO TAKE
DEPOSITS FROM STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND THESE DEPOSITS
ARE CURRENTLY USED BY COMMUNITY
BANKS PRIMARILY AS A SOURCE OF
LIQUIDITY WHICH IS THEN GOING
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITIES.
THROUGH LENDING PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES. THAT WOULD NOT BE A
PARTNERSHIP IN THAT SENSE AND
IN FACT IT WOULD BE DEVASTATING
TO SOME COMMUNITY BANKS. THEY
WON'T BE AROUND FOR THAT
PARTNERSHIP TO COME TO
FRUITION. AND THIS IS A POINT
THAT I CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH
WHAT IS BEING PROPOSED IT'S
JUST TAKE AWAY. VITAL LIQUIDITY
FROM COMMUNITY BANKS THAT
CURRENTLY HAVE A BRICK AND
MORTAR PRESENCE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND TRANSFERRING
IT TO A STATE ENTITY THAT HAS
NO BRICK AND MORTAR PRESENCE IN
THE COMMUNITY. THAT WE LOST TO
THE STATE BANKING CHARTER
SYSTEM. BUT IT'S ALSO OING TO
BE A MAJOR LOST YOUR
COMMUNITIES ONE MINUTE. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TODAY AND I'M AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER LEHMAN
LANE WE SPENT BEARD. THE DAYS.
MY GOODNESS SIR GOOD TO YOU.
IT'S BEEN AWHILE THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL UP
FOR YOU PARTICIPATING TODAY
SIR. THANK YOU. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WERE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO THE
TEAM THAT BURNING. SHE IS THE
TREASURE- IN. NEVADA COUNTY
PLUS SHE'S THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY TREASURERS AND
COLLECTORS. TREASURER AND TAX
COLLECTOR'S THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER PRESIDENT WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE WITH THIS MISS
VERNON. GOOD MORNING THE FLOOR
IS YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
AND I'LL GIVE YOU ONE MINUTE
PROBLEMS GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
WELL GOOD MORNING ON A BILL
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND SENATOR
BRADFORD- I AM DELIVERED IN
ABOUT A COUNTY TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR AND CURRENT CHARACTER
PRESIDENT. I AM HERE TODAY
THOUGH TO REPRESENT THE VIEWS
OF THE CHARACTERISTICS AS THE
ASIAN AND I DO THANK YOU FOR
HEARING OR TESTIMONY TODAY ON
THE SUBJECT OF PUBLIC BEING
FUNDING. OUR FIRST I WANT TO BE
CLEAR TO THE GROUP THAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY TREASURERS AND TAX
COLLECTORS IS NOT AGAINST THE
IDEA OF A PUBLIC BANK. AND WE
DIDN'T FULLY UNDERSTAND
MOTIVATION OF THE PUBLIC
BANKING ADVOCATES. OF THEIR
ACCOUNT IS RIGHT NOW WORKING
WITH PUBLIC BANK ADVOCATES TO
COMPLETE THE STUDY IS NEEDED TO
SEE IF A PUBLIC HEARING THANK
IS A VIABLE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. WE ALL SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH WE LIVE
AND WE CAN'T ENVISION THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS THAT A WELL
ESTABLISHED PUBLIC BANK CAN
PROVIDE TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHERE WE DO DIFFER THOSE STEMS
FROM HOW PUBLIC BANK IS FUNDED
AND THE RISK ASSOCIATED WITH
THE BIRTH OF A PUBLIC BANK. WE
HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF HOPING THAT-WORKS WE ALL HEARD ABOUT THE
BANK OF NORTH DAKOTA. AND THE
SUCCESSFUL BANK OF NORTH DAKOTA
WAS ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN
NINETEEN AND TOOK OVER THIRTY
YEARS TO BECOME SUSTAINABLE.
AND IT DOES NOT SERVE THE SAME
POPULATION OF CUSTOMERS OF THE
PROPONENTS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
SEEKING TO SERVE. AND LOCAL
AGENCIES CAN VOLUNTARILY
DEPOSIT FUNDS INTO THE BANK.
CURRENT RESEARCH SHOWS THAT A
PUBLIC BANKING CALIFORNIA ONCE
FORMED COULD TAKE ABOUT TEN
YEARS OR MORE TO BECOME
SUFFICIENTLY SOLVENT ENOUGH FOR
LOCAL AGENCY DEPOSIT. AND THIS
PROCESS OF BECOMING FULLY
REGULATED COULD TAKE YEARS AND
BE EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE. THIS
LONG AND EXPENSIVE PROCESS IS
WHAT OTHER PUBLIC BASE THE
FAILED AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE
HESITANT TO COMMIT LOCAL AGENCY
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. THROUGHOUT
THE DISCUSSIONS ON EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN AND THEN AGAIN WITH
EIGHTY THREE TEN WE'VE HEARD
PUBLIC BEING PROPONENTS PROPOSE
THE USE OF COUNTY DEPOSITS TO
FUND THESE BANKS. AND TIME AND
TIME AGAIN AND TOLD THEM THAT
WE JUST COULD NOT SUPPORT THIS.
EACH OF US TAKES AN OATH OF
OFFICE TO SERVE AND PROTECT.
TREASURES FROM AROUND THE STATE
ALSO TAKE AN OATH TO UPHOLD THE
PRUDENT INVESTOR STANDARD.
WHICH STATES THAT WE MUST
INVEST FUNDS OF THAT FIRST AND
FOREMOST. THE SAFETY OF
PRINCIPLES OF HEALTH. SECONDLY
THAT WE NEED A LIQUIDITY NEEDS
OF OUR COMMUNITIES SPECIFICALLY
OUR LOCAL SCHOOLS ARE FIRE
DISTRICT'S PUBLIC SAFETY
DEPARTMENTS COUNTY HOSPITALS
SUCH AS- THEY ALL MUST HAVE THE
NECESSARY FUNDING AT THEIR
FINGERTIPS WHEN NEEDED. TO PUT
A FINER POINT TO IT THINK ABOUT
THE COST COUNTIES IN SCHOOL THE
PER DURING THIS PANDEMIC ALONE.
THERE HAVE BEEN UNEXPECTED AND
EXTRAORDINARY COSTS FOR PP
HELLO WORKING SOCIAL DISTANCING
MEASURES EVERYTHING THAT
DISTANCE LEARNING REQUIRES. ALL
THIS REQUIRED MONEY AND WHILE
WE BELIEVE THERE'S GOING TO BE
REIMBURSEMENT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. IT IS RESPONSIBILITY OF
COUNTY TREASURERS TO ENSURE
THAT THIS LIQUIDITY AND ACCESS
TO CASH IS AVAILABLE
IMMEDIATELY IF NEEDED. AN
ENTITY OR INVESTMENT THAT WOULD
LOCK UP COUNTY OR SCHOOL CASH
FOR A DECADE OR MORE IS NOT A
PRUDENT WAY TO MANAGE THOSE
DOLLARS. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT FUNDS HELD IN COUNTY
TREASURER POOLS ARE NOT ACCESS
FROM. THERE I DON'T FUNDS THAT
WILL BE CALLED UPON AT SOME
POINT IN TIME TO PAY FOR
SALARIES CAPITAL PROJECTS AND
EQUIPMENT NEEDS TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY. THESE BONDS ARE PART
OF THE PUBLICLY ADOPTED BUDGET
DEVELOPED AND APPROVED BY OUR
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SCHOOL BOARDS CITY COUNCILS AND
GOVERNING BOARDS OF SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. IN ACCORDANCE WITH
STATE STATUTE COUNTY
TREASURER'S CANNOT INVEST IN
SECURITIES WITH MATURITY DATES
GREATER THAN FIVE YEARS DUE TO
THE SHORT TURNAROUND THESE
FUNDS. HI LIQUIDITY NEEDS
REQUIRE COUNTY TREASURER'S TO
HAVE TIGHTENED ACCURATE COUNCIL
PROJECTIONS TO ENSURE THAT CASH
IS SUFFICIENT FOR ALL
EXPENDITURES- JESUS COUNTIES
AND CITIES AROUND STATE DEPOSIT
MONIES INTO THE STATE LOCAL
AGENCY INVESTMENT FUND. A%
HIGHLY. PUBLIC ENTITIES AS I
UNDERSTAND THE PROPOSAL OF THE
LEGISLATION IS CONSIDERING
TODAY INCLUDES THE USE OF
COUNTY AND CITY DOLLARS THAT
ARE ON THE POCKET WITH PMA AND
LYFT. THE USE OF THESE FUNDS TO
PROVIDE THE CAPITAL NEEDS OF A
PUBLIC BANK WILL TIE UP OUR
LOCAL AGENCY FUNDS. LONGER THAN
THE FIVE YEAR STATUTORY LIMIT.
IT WOULD EXPOSE CAMPER FULL
LIVES TO LARGER RISKS AND
POTENTIAL LOSS OF PRINCIPAL. IT
WOULD RENDER THESE FUNDS ON
AVAILABLE PER MEDIA WITHDRAWAL
BY A LOCAL AGENCY LESS
THREATENING LOCAL AGENCIES
BUDGETS AND OUR SERVICES TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. RIGHT NOW WE'VE
SEEN INCREASED PROPERTY TAX
DELINQUENCIES AND WE WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY SEE MORE AS WE
PASSED THE DECEMBER TENTH
DEADLINE. AND YET WE'RE IN A
TIME WHERE CONSTITUENTS NEED
MORE SERVICES SO MANY MORE
SPEAKING MENTAL HEALTH PHYSICAL
HEALTH. AND PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN YOUR
LIFE. ONE MINUTE TREASURES.
THANK YOU TURN AROUND THE STATE
ARE SHIPPING THEIR PRIVILEGE TO
INCREASE BUT TWENTY LIQUIDITY
PREPARING FOR THE CASH FLOWS
CHARGES THAT WE WILL NEED AND
DEFINITELY SUFFERED THROUGH
FORM YOU KNOW GETTING TO THIS
PANDEMIC AND WILDFIRES. WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO TIE UP OUR
FUNDS. FOR LONG. TERM
INVESTMENTS IN A PUBLIC BANK.
IF THESE FUNDS WERE TO BE
GRANTED FOR THIS USE THE LIKELY
OUTCOME WILL BE THAT COUNTIES
AND LOCAL AGENCIES WILL REMOVE
THEIR DEPOSITS FROM LATE AND
PMI. EIGHT FUNDS. IF THIS
SHOULD OCCUR THE MONEY THAT A
PUBLIC BANK IS NEEDED TO
SUCCEED WILL NOT BE AVAILABLE
AND THE EFFORTS WILL FAIL. IT
IS IMPORTANT FOR PROPONENTS TO
LOOK FOR FUNDING ELSEWHERE AND
AFTER HEARING TESTIMONIES BY
CONTROLLER D. AND TREVOR MOCK.
THERE ARE SOME VIABLE
ALTERNATIVES OUT THERE. WE KNOW
PUBLIC BANKS PROVIDE WHERE THE
SERVICES THE FINANCING CAPITAL
PUBLICATIONS THE FUND IS NOT
PRUDENT. ACT ACT IS NOT
SUPPORTED IN THE CONCLUSION OF
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF MY
MEMBERSHIP. WOULD SIMPLY MOVE
THEIR MONEY OUT OF LIFE YOU
MIGHT BE SHOULD BE SPENT TO BE
SECURED FOR PUBLIC BANK. WE
REQUIRE CAPITAL WE DO NOT
PROVIDE CAPITAL. FOR THESE
REASONS CHARACTER RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSES THE USE OF FUNDS FROM
LATE AND PMI WHICH IS COMPRISED
OF STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE THE FUNDING
FOR CAPITAL BANK. IF I COULD
JUST TAKING ONE MOMENT BEFORE I
CONCLUDE TODAY I DID WANT TO
THANK SENATOR MORLOCK FOR HIS
WORK ON THIS COMMITTEE. A MUCH
OF WHAT THE COUNTY TREASURERS
AND TAX COLLECTORS DO IT'S HARD
EVEN SOMETIMES TEDIOUS WORK AND
COLLECTING TAXES DOESN'T ALWAYS
MAKE US THE MOST POPULAR
ELECTED OFFICIAL IN COUNTY
GOVERNMENT. BUT THE WORK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT IN WHAT WE DO
IS IN THE SERVICE OF EVERY
CALIFORNIANS. COUNTIES ARE
IMPLEMENTING ARM OF SO MANY
STATE PROGRAMS AND HAVE ANY
FORMER COUNTY TREASURER SERVE
IN THE SENATE ESPECIALLY ON
YOUR COMMITTEE SENATOR MCGUIRE.
WAS A STROKE OF LUCK FOR COUNTY
TREASURE'S. KNOWING THAT A
MEMBER OF YOUR COMMITTEE
INTIMATELY UNDERSTOOD THE WORK
WE DO AND HOW LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS WOULD WORK OR NOT
WHEN IT CAME TIME TO IMPLEMENT
THOSE PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
SENATOR WIRE FOR INVITING US TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR MORE LOCK FOR YOUR
SERVICE THANK YOU FOR ALL OF
YOUR TIME TO. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT THAT'S TINA
VERNON SHE IS PRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY TREASURERS AND TAX
COLLECTORS- WITH THAT A VERY
SPECIAL. SENDOFF TO VICE CHAIR
MORLOCK LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
AND COMMITTEE TO THOSE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WHAT WE
DE ACTIVATED DO IS TURN IT OVER
TO HAIR BRADFORD TO BE A KICK
US OFF. ON QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ON THIS PORTION OF THE HEARING
WILL THEN GO CHECK IN WITH VICE
CHAIR MORLOCK AFTER SENATOR
BRADFORD THAT DIDN'T WILL GO TO
THOSE ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. THEN WE'RE GOING TO
OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
COMMENT ON ANY OF THE ITEMS
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY HERE'S THE
PHONE NUMBER WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM YOU. THE NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 WITH A CODE OF.
SIX ZERO FIVE SEVEN SIX FIVE
THREE UP THERE ON YOUR SCREEN
NOW. SO WE'RE NOW GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO CHAIR BRADFORD CHAIR
BRADFORD HAS A QUESTION COMMENT
THAT FOR THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE. I BELIEVE THAT
CONTROLLER YOU MAY HAVE HAD TO
ADJOURN HERSELF FOR ANOTHER
MEETING BUT IF THAT'S THE CASE
WE'RE GOING TO ASK BOTH THE
LEAN IN INJURY TO PLEASE TURN
ON THEIR CAMERAS. THAT TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE THERE
WILL BE DANCE BY MISTER CHAIR
CHAIR BRADFORD THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND I DID HAVE A QUESTION I
APOLOGIZE REVIVAL ALLOWED TO
CONTROLLER TO. LEAVE AND IT WAS
REALLY ON- THE CDF. CITY OF
VICE AND SHE GAVE A GREAT-
PRESENTATION GIRL- THOROUGH
INFORMATION IN REGARDS TO. THEM
BEING A VIABLE ALTERNATIVE I
GUESS MY QUESTION WOULD BE. SHE
SEEMED TO STRESS THAT IN ORDER
TO STAND THESE ENTITIES UP THEY
NEEDED A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
BANKS AND MY CONCERN OR
QUESTION IS. IT'S THE BANKS OR
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY. NEEDING
ALTERNATIVE- ENTITY IN- A- OR
FOR. INSTITUTIONS TO SERVE
THESE CAN. SO WHY. DOES SHE
FEEL THAT THE BANKS WILL PLAY A
GREATER ROLE WITH CDI APPS
THEN- THEY'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
WITH THE ROOT DIRECTORY-
SCIENTER YOU KNOW BUSINESS
ENTITIES THAT NEED LOANS. AND.
WHAT ROLE SHOULD THE STATE PLAY
AND HELP STANDING UP- CD- FIVE
I SHOULD SAY I CITY ARE OUT
PROCEED FIVE- IN A FEW SO
THERE'S STATE HAVE A ROLE IN
HELPING STAND THE- THE SANITY
UP ENOUGH HOW DO WE GET THE
WORD OUT TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC
THAT THESE. FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE
AND THESE THESE ENTITIES ARE
AVAILABLE TO REACH OUT BECAUSE
MOST FOLKS JUST GO WITH
TRADITIONAL BANKS WHO ARE
TURNING THEIR BACKS ON. THESE
CUSTOMERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
RODRIGUEZ I'M HAPPY TO JOIN
AGAIN TO RESPOND YOUR QUESTION
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. IT
WAS. OUR THEY'RE SUPPORTED BY
DID SOURCES INCLUDING
MAINSTREAM THANKS OF THE WHAT I
WOULD IS THE BANKS TO BE A
SOURCE OF CAPITAL FOR CITY
ADVISED BUT I THINK WE OUGHT
NOT- JUST THEIR WAY FROM THE
UNIQUE ATTRIBUTES OF CITY
ADVISE US WAS SUCH AS PROVIDED
BY ALL. OF NOTING RAMOS BUT
THE- ENTERPRISE SON YOU KNOW
IT'S REALLY WHAT'S MISSING IS
THE EXPERTISE OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE TRYING TO
TARGET- IN THE TRADITIONAL
BANKS ARE I MEAN I'VE ALSO
GIVEN EXAMPLE- AT THE STOP OF
SANTA OF THE STRUGGLING WITH
BANKERS. BENCH I SEE THIS
HAPPEN TO TIME TO TIME. YOU
KNOW I REMEMBER OF MY OFFICES
LOWER IN A FINANCIAL AND
EDUCATION YOU KNOW WHAT I SEE
BANKS YEAH KIND OF TAKING UP
THAT SPACE AND GOING INTO
COMMITTEES PROVIDING FINANCIAL
EDUCATION. I MAY HAVE TO SAY-
SOME IT FEELS LIKE THIS SECOND
THE BOX. YOU KNOW FOR. A TO
COME INTO TO. DOESN'T RECOGNIZE
YOU KNOW WHAT THE ATTRIBUTES TO
THE COMMUNITY- ARE INCLUDING.
NON LEGAL SPEAKING AGAINST
PROVIDING THE SAID. THANK YOU
THAT'S A LITTLE DEAL SUFFER. I
MEAN THAT'S THAT'S IS JUST OF A
DISK. THAT I THINK REALLY THE
WHOLE THE CITY BIAS I ATTEMPTED
PLAY. THEIR SUPERVISORS
ETCETERA FROM OF THE SOURCES.
THE FEDERAL CITY A BY FONG. OUT
OF UP CAPITAL. AND DON'T. IT
HAVE DURING THIS TIME
DEMOCRATIC ABOUT YOU KNOW JUST
ALL OF OUR A CORPORATE CEO
STEPPING UP AND I OFTEN WONDER
WHAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED. IF
THEIR FINANCIAL CONTRIBUTIONS
SEVEN TARGETED AT DOES THAT
DIRECTOR JUST CDFI BUT ACTUALLY
TO GET DOLLARS TO THE MOST
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES. IN OUR
MINORITY COMMUNITIES THAT. HAVE
TO BEAR THE MOST
DISPROPORTIONATE ACTS OF. THE
PANDEMIC AND CERTAINLY THIS
RECESSION. AND SO I DON'T KNOW
THERE'S GOING TO. PROBABLY NEED
TO BE OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
TRADITIONAL BANKS AND YOU KNOW
FRANKLY CAPITAL IS KIND OF NOT
ALL THAT- THERE ARE ALWAYS MANY
SOURCES OF CAPITAL. AND WHAT
I'M TRYING TO THE- RELATE TO
THAT SO- THE COMMITTEE IS SET
UP THE CAPITAL THAT THE
PROPONENTS ARE LOOKING AT. IS
THE STATE'S WORKING CAPITAL FOR
MY FOR WHICH WE HAVE TO MEET
OUR CURRENT AND FUTURE
OBLIGATIONS. AT THE END I DON'T
I MEAN I DON'T THINK ANY OF US
WANT TO BE IN A POSITION OF.
HAVING TO DECIDE WHETHER WE'RE
GOING TO HELP A FAMILY. OF WITH
THEIR- YEAH THEY'RE THEY'RE
MEDICAID BENEFITS A COMPARE
JOBS NO DIRECTING DOLLARS TO
TELL A TO A CITY OF FIVE THAT'S
NOT THE- RIGHT QUESTION TO ASK.
BUT BUT BUT OVER TIM AND AGAIN
I WANT TO SAY THIS. THE BEAUTY
OF A CDFI AND IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EQUITY. THIS IS TRUE.
REGARDLESS OF- YOU KNOW JUST
TELL WHAT AREA WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. THE LONG TERM GOAL OF
EQUITY IS TO BUILD A LIVE
LOOKED UP COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO
TO BUILD RESILIENCE. THAT OVER
TIME I HOPE THEY SEE THEIR
BODIES ARE REALLY ROBUST.
INSTITUTIONS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO HELP US RIGHT THE- THAT ARE
GOING TO BE A PRESS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES UNDER. THAT YOU TO
EACH COMMUNITIES THAT WERE. A
WORKFORCE THAT ACTS COULD WORK
IN THIS FIIS FROM. NUMBER OF
THE COMMUNITY THAT WE HAVE- OF
THE- TO- LOOK AT THE PICTURES
OF TECH CAPACITY SO THAT THE
CAN. B. I PERFORM WITH THE OF
SCALE IN TERMS OF HOW THEIR
LOANS AND REALLY BE OF ALTERED
TO THE MAINSTREAM BANKS BUT I
WILL SAY THE TO YOUR QUESTION
CHIU BRADFORD. OF IT ALL I HAVE
TO SAY JAMIE DIMON OF JP FOR
CHASE TALKS OF. YOU KNOW A TENS
OF BILLIONS OF THAT ARE GOING
TO GO TO UNDERSERVED- I LOOK AT
THE AND SAY WORST. SHARE AND A
AND I THINK THAT'S WE HAVE TO
ABOUT TERMS OF HOW HOW TO BE
ACCESO. THE STOCK OR THE
STARTING COULD BETTER FOR HARD
TO DROP THIS. THIS RECORD DE
THE SEE THE STATE PLAN A ROLL.
SOME THE TECH OF ASSIST OUR
MONEY. HIS ARE GOING. YOU KNOW
WHAT I HAD A DREAM ABOUT GERMAN
BROWN I DROPPED A- OF- LIKED IT
ALLEGE TALK OR WHAT SAID COPY
ARE. YEAH I LEGISLATIVE. YEAH
JOINING CANCER ISSUE SHALL. TO
OUR TECH ARE. WHAT THEY CAN IT
YOUR HELP LIFT UP THE MUCH TO
PASS AS BUYS I MEAN FOR THAT BE
A CAL. WE HAVE. TOOLS OF THE
RISK SO I AND I WOULD SAY
THAT'S A PROBLEM THE SINGLE
MOST. IMPORTANT FIRST STEP YEAR
JUST HELPING OF THESE JUICES
BILL THAT CAPACITY AT AT TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE TOOLS SO THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY BE ON A
FOOTING WHERE THEY CAN SERVE
THEIR COMMUNITIES. LIKE ANY
TRADITIONAL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR IS YOU
BETTER CONTROLLER MUCH LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WERE
NOT GONNA TURN IT OVER TO THE
VICE CHAIR GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE CIDR MORE LIKE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK-
TINA VERNON NEVADA COUNTY
TREASURE TECHSELECT YOU'RE FOR
KIND REMARKS- I HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH ONE OF OUR
PREDECESSORS CHRIS DAVIS- WHEN
I SERVED AS A TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR A LOT OF FUN
MEMORIES. ALSO WHEN I THINK
JASON LANE- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION HE WAS
BRUTALLY HONEST REGARDING THE
CURRENT BANKING ENVIRONMENT AND
APPRECIATE HIS COMMENTS- SINCE
THE CONTROLLER IS ON ON THE
LINE THIS IS GREAT BECAUSE I
WANTED TO FOCUS AS WELL AS
SENATOR BRADFORD ON A COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS THE CITY ADVISE I
WAS JUST CURIOUS- CONTROLLER V.
IF THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE OR THE STATE AUDITOR.
HAS EVER DONE- A REVIEW OF THE-
CDFI SAID WE. MIGHT SEE IN
PRINT THAT WE COULD REVIEW.
MATADOR YES. AT THANK YOU- CHIP
REQUIRES TAKING SORT OF MORAL A
OF. I HAVE NO AWARE OF ANY
INCREASE- IT IS SORT SEPARATE
OF C. ADVISE- DUBBED BY THE
STATE. OF I- IT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING WE COULD- REQUESTED
SURPLUS LEGISLATURE COULD BE AS
PART OF SO. RECYCLES IS OUR
PRIDE ENTITIES THAT SIR WITH TO
HOW THEY HELP THEIR SERVER THAT
THE CAN IN WHICH THEY ARE- THIS
IS SOMETHING OF ABOVE BROAD
JUMPS LIKE INTEREST- AND I
WOULD VENTURE TO SAY THAT WE'RE
PROBABLY GONNA SEE A LOT OF
VARYING EXPERIENCES OF
DEPENDING ON. WHERE THE CITY OF
EYES ARE LOCATED WHAT THEIR
AREAS AND JUSTICE- ARE WITH
RESPECT TO HOW TO A LOOKED UP
THE TREATIES WHICH THE STUDENTS
THEY SERVE SO- BUT- SEVERAL
MORE LIKE I HAVE NOT SAID
ANYTHING RECENT- BUT THERE
PROBABLY ARE SOME SEVERAL I
WOULD SAY THAT THEY'RE PROBABLY
MORE LIKELY FEDERAL REVIEWS OUT
THERE ARE- STATE LEVEL. THANK
YOU CARP AND OF THINKING THAT
MAYBE THE WHO AND- ARE-
COMMISSION HOOVER INSTITUTION.
WOULD BE A GOOD. VEGAS ARE
THREATENING CHAIR IF WE COULD
ENCOURAGE THE HOOVER COMMISSION
TO. REVIEW AT CDFI SAYS YOU'RE
REVIEWING THIS THIS IS A PUBLIC
BANK IDEA YOU MIGHT- ARCTIC
BECAUSE WHAT'S COMING OUT OF
THE TESTIMONY MISTER CHAIRS AT.
AT THE ONLY BENEFITS OF THE
STATE BANK- WOULD BE LEVERAGING
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR SECONDARY
MARKETS AND OF THIS THAT'S WHAT
I HEARD FROM THIS ROSE- AND SO
I'M THINKING OF STATE BANK
BASED ON SOME OF THE TESTIMONY
IS REDUNDANT- AND- THE BENEFITS
IT COULD BE DERIVED SEEM. LIKE
A SMALL- BENEFIT- BASED ON. YOU
KNOW BUILDING AN INTIMIDATING
NEW BUREAUCRACY. AND YOU KNOW
THE BENEFITS PACKAGES FOR
EMPLOYEES AT THE STATE LEVEL OR
A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR SO- I JUST
WANTED TO BRING THAT UP BUT-
CONTROLLER YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY I LIKE TO QUOTE.
THAT IT'S REINVENTING THE WHEEL
AND THANK YOU PROPRIETY.
PROVIDING AN ALTERNATIVE IN.
GIVING US A SOME MORE TO DO.
THANK YOU MISTER. SO MISTER-
IT'S LIKE SAID JOHNNY JUST UP
PLEASE PROCEED MUCH I OF I JUST
TO ADD MY- BIEK. SO MORE FOR-
JUST REALLY I'M STILL. CAREER
PUBLIC SERVICE OUT AND JUST AS
AN ASIDE- HE REALLY WAS SOMEONE
TO- WAS SO- THE EX IN- OF MY CA
EARLY ON IN MY OFFICE. THAT WAS-
THE RESOLVER OR COUNTY THANK.
AT THE STATE. SO THERE WERE A
LOT- REPUTATION PRECEDES YOU I
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW- US WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RISKS WITH
RESPECT TO US SO. YOU HAVE THE-
BUT I PREFER EXPERT IN THIS
FIELD IT IT JUST A GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO THIS INTO THE
CALIFORNIA STATES OFFICE THANK
YOU CONTROLLER CREATE THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CONTROL A%
GREAT FOR THOSE WHO TO BE TRUE
THE THAT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE WITH HEARD FROM THE
VICE CHAIR WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
CHAIR WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE A
TO GO TO THOSE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SAY GOOD
MORNING ONCE AGAIN TO EACH OF
THE SENATORS WOULD LIKELY TO
SEE IF THEY'RE ANY SENATORS FOR
THIS PANEL HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS IT THEY'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE.
WILL GIVE YOU FOR A FEW MOMENTS
TO BE ABLE TO RAISE YOUR HAND
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE A COMMENT- YOU
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD ON THIS
FINAL PANEL. IT'S GONNA BE
FINAL CALL FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR PARTICIPATING
SENATORS FINAL CALL FOR.
PARTICIPATING SENATORS FROM
EACH COMMITTEE. CENTER DRAWS OR
DID YOU WANNA I CHIME IN ON
THIS. YES ALL RIGHT IS YOUR MAN
SENATOR. THANK YOU- I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE- PANELISTS-
AND YOUR YOUR POINTS OF VIEW-
HI IN THE NOTES OF THE
COMMITTEE BACKGROUND THERE WAS-
SORT OF THIS CHART OF THE
MODELS ONE TWO AND THREE AND
HOW MUCH MONEY AND- OVER HOW
MANY YEARS IT WOULD TAKE TO
BREAK EVEN- I WANT TO LOOK INTO
THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE BUT- I
WAS. HOPING THERE'D BE MORE OF
THAT KIND O A BREAKDOWN OF
WHAT IT WOULD TAKE A WHAT WOULD
BE THERE'S A LOT THERE IS A LOT
OF COMMENTS ABOUT THE RISK-
THAT THE STATE WOULD BE TAKING
AND OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO LOOK
AT THAT. BUT THAT WOULD SEEM
SOMETHING MUCH MORE THAT WE
SHOULD DIG IN. A LITTLE BIT
MORE WHAT DO THOSE MEAN WHAT DO
THOSE MODELS MAIN. AND IN ORDER
FOR US TO. YOU KNOW CONSIDERED-
IF THERE'S A RISK AND HOW MUCH
OF A RISK BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
THERE'S NOT MUCH OF A- F A
COMPETITION HERE WITH- WITH THE
BANKS AS FAR AS INVESTING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES INVESTING IN
THE ISSUES. THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SUFFERING FROM
BEING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY CRISIS.
HOMELESSNESS EXTRAORDINARY
CRISIS AND YET WE CAN'T USE.
SOMEHOW USE OUR FUNDS TO ASSIST
IN SOLVING THAT CRISIS AT LEAST
NOT ON THE LEVEL I SHOULD SAY
NOT USING AT ALL AT LEAST NOT
ON THE LEVEL THAT WE COULD BE
AND THAT WE SHOULD BE I HAVEN'T
HEARD ENOUGH ABOUT WHAT THOSE
RISKS ARE OTHER THAN. A GENERAL
WE'RE AT RISK OR AT RISK IT'S
KIND OF LIKE SPOOKINESS AWAY
FROM THE IDEA RATHER THAN
DIGGING IN WHAT THE ISSUE AND
LET'S SOLVE THAT ISSUE LET'S
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. WHAT WE CAN
DO IT WE CAN'T DO IT IS TOO
MANY OF THESE CAN'T DO. SO
THAT'S JUST MISTER CHAIR MIGHT
MY GENERAL- YOU KNOW- OUR
RESPONSE. TO DISSENT BUT I DO
APPRECIATE EVERYONE AND YOUR
POINT OF VIEW THAT YOU
CONTRIBUTED HERE AND. AND
LASTLY AND MAYBE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALA COULD ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF THE- PM P. M. I. A.'S-
BECAUSE THAT KEEPS COMING UP
AND I THOUGHT THAT WASN'T
INCLUDED IN THIS LEGISLATION SO
MAYBE IN YOUR FINAL REMARKS
COULD INCLUDE A REFERENCE TO
THAT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
SENATOR ALSO WE ALWAYS
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING NOT
GONNA LOOK TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO IF WE TAKE AT THE
CENTER OFTEN MEET THEIR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DO YOU WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT TO RESPOND TO
WHAT AT CENTER DRAWS- JUST ASK
YOU OR DO YOU WANT TO WAIT. FOR
CLOSING COMMENTS IT'S UP TO YOU
SIR. IN THE INTEREST OF
COMMITTEES TIME I COULD WAIT
TILL CLOSING COMMENTS. OKAY
ESCRITOR INET WE LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING THAT RESPONSE FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO TO
SENATOR RUSSELL HERE. IN HIS
CLOSING COMMENTS I DON'T NEED
TO KEEP LOOKING TO MY LEFT I
JUST WANNA I'M LOOKING AT THE
SCREEN HERE I DON'T MEAN TO.
THAT LOOK STRAIGHT AHEAD BUT I
WANTED TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE ELSE ANYONE ELSE ANY
SENATORS. WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ASK QUESTIONS. COMMENT
HAVE A COMMON. CONCERN ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO CENTER
CABALLERO. GOOD MORNING CENTER
CABALLERO. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
MISTER CHAIR I APPRECIATE IT-
LET ME JUST SAY THAT THAT- THAT
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL OF THAT
OF THE TESTIMONY- IN IT YET- WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE IT. THAT- THAT THERE
IS THERE IS THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- TO CREATE.
RESOURCES THAT WILL HELP- AND
MAKE THE MAJOR INVESTMENTS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR IN A
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND- AND
FINANCIALLY STRUGGLING
COMMUNITIES AND- IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT THIS PANDEMIC HAS
MAGNIFIED THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THOSE AT THAT HAPPENED
THOSE THAT HAVE NOT AND-
pSUFFERING THE HIGHEST INFECTION
RATES ARE THOSE THAT HAVE NOT
AND FOR A WHOLE VARIETY OF
REASONS- BUT- KNOW. WHAT I
HEARD HERE TODAY IS I GUESS
THIS IS JUST A SUMMARY IS THAT
WE'VE WE'VE SET UP SOME. SOME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SOME
MUNICIPAL BANKS. AND IT IT'S AN
EXPERIMENT REALLY TO SEE
WHETHER ANY ANY OF THESE-
ENTITIES ACTUALLY. BECOME
REALITY WHETHER THERE'S AN
INTEREST IN INVESTING IN- THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO BE
ABLE TO PUT ONE OF THESE
TOGETHER AND- AND LET'S BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT IT IT'S CITY
INTENDING INCREDIBLY HUGE
INVESTMENT. OF TIME AND
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO. CREATE AN ENTITY THAT HAS
THE OP THAT THAT HAS THAT THAT
THE WHERE WITH ALL TO BE ABLE
TO DO SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE THINK ARE IMPORTANT FOR OUR
COMMUNITY WHETHER IT'S-
FINANCIAL LITERACY WHETHER IT'S
LOW INTEREST LOANS WHETHER IT'S
SMALL BUSINESS LOANS- IT. IT'S
AN INVESTMENT AND IT'S GOING TO
COST AND- WHAT I THINK I HEARD
TODAY IT LEAST FROM FROM THE
PARTNER WELL AND THEN IF WE DO
THIS IT'S GONNA BE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT- ENTITIES WHETHER
THEY BE BANKS OR CREDIT UNIONS
AND THEN CITIES AND COUNTIES.
AND- AND SO THAT'S THE
FRAMEWORK THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THIS WORK
IN AND THEN- AND THEN THE
FINANCIAL PART OF BEING A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER HAVING BEEN A
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS- IS IT YOU WANT TO PUT
YOUR MONEY IN A PLACE. WHERE
YOU KNOW YOU CAN YOU HAVE THE
LIQUIDITY YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
THAT THE RESOURCES AT YOUR
FINGERTIPS WHEN IT COMES TIME
TO MAKE. THE PAYMENTS THAT ARE
REQUIRED OF YOU AND THAT YOU
KNOW- IT CAN BE IT. PHYSICALLY
VERY SOUND EASY YOU'LL HAVE
THAT RESPONSIBILITY. AND YOU
HAVE TO ASCERTAIN THAT IN SO
WHEN I HEARD IN TERMS OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS IS THAT THERE ARE
SOME REAL CONCERNS WITH THAT
THE STATE INCLUDING OUR OWN-
TREASURER AND CONTROLLER. IT IS
WADING INTO THIS AREA WHEN
THERE MAY BE SOME OTHER
ALTERNATIVES. THAT MAKE MORE-
SENSE AND THEN DON'T. PUT US AT
AT SUCH A RISK ARE REALLY A-
THAT BECAUSE I I'M LOOK FOR
SOMEONE I DON'T WANT. I'M A
LIKE CENTER DERIVES RIGHT I
DON'T WANT TO JUST YOU'RE RIGHT
YOU CAN'T DO YOU CAN'T DO IT
YOU CAN'T DO IT AT THAT HAVE TO
BE SOME ALTERNATIVES- AND I DO
APPRECIATE. WHAT CONTROLLER HE
HAD TO SAY WHICH IS THAT. MAYBE
IT'S TIME FOR ALL OF OUR
CAUCUSES TO GET TOGETHER AND TO
SAY WE WANT TO ANY INVESTMENT
WHETHER IT'S CRA OR CDFI
INVESTMENT. TO BE. RESPONSIVE
TO OUR NEEDS IN OUR COMMUNITY
TO BE VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT WHAT
OUR EXPECTATIONS ARE. AND AND
GO ANY IMMUNITY TO REALLY
PROCESO ANYWAY THAT'S I'M I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS HEARING
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S HELPED TO
CRYSTALLIZE IN MY- IN MY HEAD
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT- THAT
ARE ARE WE DID WE NEED TO TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION IF WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE. THIS STEP TO
MAKE A MAJOR INVESTMENT LIKE
THIS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIS CENTER
CABALLERO GRATEFUL FOR THOSE
COMMENTS. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF BOTH COMMITTEES WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO START YOU KNOW WHAT
MISTER CHAIR I MEAN VERY VERY
BRIEFLY I DO ALSO WANNA- GIVE A
VIRTUAL HUG THIS SENATOR MORE
LOCKER GIVE HIM A VIRTUAL
HANDSHAKE- IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
BEING AT- COMMITTEE MEMBER WITH
YOU. AND WE'RE GOING TO MISS
YOUR EXPERTISE SO THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
CALIFORNIA. SENATE YOU SO MUCH.
THAT THAT IS FOR GRATEFUL-
MISTER VICE DID YOU TO RESPOND.
WE ARE ALSO THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER KABIRA MINIMUS WORKING
WITH YOUR YOUR WONDERFUL. THANK
YOU MISTER PRICE JR ALL RIGHT.
AT CLOSING AT COMMENTS WERE
LOOKING FOR FINAL COMMENTS
FINAL COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
FINAL COMMENTS FROM SENATORS ON
THIS PANEL. HEARING SEEN NINE
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN OF
COMMITTEE WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
QUICKLY DESCRIBE HOW PUBLIC
COMMENT IS GOING TO WORK HERE
TODAY THERE'S GOING TO BE THREE
WAYS AN INDIVIDUAL CAN
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC COMMENT.
EACH INDIVIDUAL WOULD BE A IS
ABLE TO RECEIVE TWO MINUTES
I'LL KEEP TRACK IT'LL GIVE YOU
A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT PLEASE
DON'T TAKE ME BEING RUDE IF I
SAY THIRTY SECONDS I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW
WHERE YOU'RE AT IN REGARDS TO
YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE GOING TO
START FIRST HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS WE DO HAVE. A AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK HERE IN THE CHAMBERS THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE AND THEN WE'RE GONNA GO
ASK THOSE PARTICIPATING ON THE
PHONE LINE TO BE A PROVIDER
COMMENT IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CALL AND WE WLCOME YOUR
COMMENTS HERE. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
HIT US UP AT THE NUMBER IN THE
CODE ON YOUR SCREEN RIGHT NOW
WE'RE TAKING COMMENTS VIA THE
TELEPHONE. 844-291-6364 ALL
RIGHT. THAT IS IN GERMAN WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
FIRST SET OF PUBLIC COMMENTS
WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME AN
INDIVIDUAL HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS. TO COMMITTEE IF YOU
DON'T MIND SIR JUST GIVE US
YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US HERE ON THIS
THANKSGIVING WEEK THE
FORESHORES. DO NOT REGARD MAJOR
US. MCGUIRE AN VICE CHAIR
SENATOR MORE. YOU DON'T NEED MY
THANKS FOR THANK YOU. NONE I
SHOULD SAY I ADMIRE YOUR
COURAGE AND- OKAY- MY NAME IS
PAT. BANKER AND I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO. CALIFORNIA KERN.
JUST LIKE A ALL I LOVE FAMILY
COMMUTING COUNTRY AND THERE'S A
WOMAN WHO ARE LOVE TO THE- I
THINK THAT SOMETIMES BEING AWAY
FOR SOME LIVES MEXI RICE HOW
MUCH OF A ON OUR ON THE WAY
HERE AND I SEEN A COUPLE
SOLDIERS ARE HAVING ON ALLIANCE
AND- I SAW THEM. I WENT IN YOU
KNOW SO THERE ARE THEM FOR
THEIR SERVICE IN THE- COURAGE
FOR. WHETHER DON'T RECOMMEND.
AND I HAVEN'T HAD MY GUITAR AND
I AM. SO I. ASKED IF I SING A
SONG BECAUSE I HAVE A- HIM
FILING. BECAUSE LAST A BORN
SMALL TOWN STAFFS ARE MILLS A
SECOND HERE DIVISION. AND JUST
ABOUT FAMILY CAN COUNTRY. AND
AFTERWARDS THEY SAID THEY KIND
OF LIKE IT. AND IT MEANT A LOT
TO ME MEANT SO MUCH TO ME
BECAUSE- I WAS KIND OF
EMBARRASSED BECAUSE HE NO I'M
NO HERO. I'M ACTUALLY NOBODY
I'M NOBODY SPECIAL. BUT I'M
HERE I'M TRYING TO DO SOMETHING
THAT WORK FOR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITY AND NON. IN SOUTHERN.
AN THE DAY AS A- I SHOULD SAY
THAT WHAT. ALSO TO ME IS
WALKING THIS. AMONG THE CAP. IN
SAN THAT THE WAY. AND RANDOM.
SORRY AS A LOT OF. YEAH AND
ALSO A LOT OF. AN POWER HERE
AND I. THE GOVERNOR AND ARE
THEY MILITARY AND MARK
EVERYBODY DOES MUCH GOOD OUR-
YOU KNOW OUR COMMUNITY. AND.
THERE'S BEEN A SEVEN.
DIFFICULTIES IN MY LIFE AND I
AND I'M SORRY TO SAY THAT.
BASICALLY ON. IS NOT THE WHOLE
STORY ABOUT- FOR ABOUT FIVE
YEARS AS AN PEOPLE- GIVE ME A
HARD TIME AND- I THINK IT MIGHT
BE SOME INFORMATION SECURITY
ANALYSTS AND I DON'T I'M NOT TO
BE A FULL TIME TRYING TO WRECK
DO THE RIGHT THINGS I DON'T
HAVE ANYBODY ELSE. BUT BASS GOT
INTO. IN INDIA TERRENCE HORAN
HELPLESSNESS FOR- HIM AGAIN
THIS IS EMBARRASSING TO SAY
THAT YOU KNOW- IN ALIGNMENT
CHECK TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SIX
MYSTERY TWENTY FOUR SEVEN FIVE
MONTHS STRAIGHT TORMENT. AND A
PEOPLE BROKE INTO MY APARTMENT
AND- PUT INTO A- BOB WOODRUFF
MY DOORKNOB WAS KIND OF A- LIKE
A BRAIN VIRUS. BASICALLY
CREATED A KIND OF HAVOC N MY-
MY SAYS A REALITY MY LOVE FOR
GOD. FOR ABOUT TEN MINUTES AND
YOU KNOW IT MADE ME REALIZE IN
THIS ORDER THEM THAT- YOU KNOW
THERE ISN'T A SOLDIER AND I
THINK A LOT HE'S BEEN THROUGH
THAT KIND OF PAIN. AND I'M
NOBODY SPECIAL NOBODY BUT- LIKE
I SAID I'M DOING IS TRYING TO
WORKING FAMILIES COMMUTING
CONTRACT. CONTRACT TO DO WHAT'S
RIGHT. BY MARIO SO MUCH AND I
AND OUR THE- LET ME SPEAK. I
WAS A SECOND CENSORED INTERNET
THIRTY SECONDS HERE AT AND FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE GIVE ME A
HARD TIME YOU KNOW. THESE
INFORMATION SECURITY ANALYSTS
ARE YOU KNOW MAYBE I'M WRONG
BUT AND SO I THINK ON. THERE'S
A- YOU KNOW IF THEY GAVE ME.
YOU KNOW. FOR AND- I DON'T KNOW.
KNOW LIKE. I MEAN. MAN BUT
HERE'S WHAT I HAVE TO GIVE TO
THEM COME. PERMISSION TO BE
ASSIGNED. AS FAR. AM I AND I
SHOULD SAY THAT I THINK THAT
IT'S- WAS ACTUALLY. THAT EACH
OF US HAS A UNIQUE PRESSURES
NEVER BEFORE SEEN. NEVER AGAIN
SEEN OUR CREATION OF GOD AND
GOD MADE ALL OF US WERE THE OF
HIS LAST. AND I JUST LIKE TO
SAY THAT I'M CLAIMING THE FIRST
AMENDMENT OF THE CONSTITUTION
FREEDOM OF MIND AND CONSCIENCE.
PROTECTION FROM DISCRIMINATION.
THAT WOULD BE A GVC VERSES
ABOUT. AND I SHOULD SAY I HOPE
YOU'LL KNOW YOU'VE HEARD WAY
GOD MADE YOU ALWAYS HAVE BEEN
ALWAYS WILL BE THE ONLY STICK
TO OUR MORE THAN I. GOT THIS
YOU YOUR FAMILIES PARTY WAY GOT
MAJOR THANK YOU SO ÛH.
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US-
HAPPY THINGS GIVEN PATRICK
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE TODAY. WHICH I WILL. RIGHT
THANK YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
I WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS WOULD LIKE ME TO
SPEAK. HEARING SEEN NO ONE LAYS
IN GERMAN WE NOW LIKE TO GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE ROOM ONE TWELVE
WE'RE GONNA SEE IF WE. HAVE
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. THAT
ROOM IS LONELY. THAT NO ONE IS
IN ROOM TWELVE SO WE'RE NEVER
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBERS. THAT WE WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO BE TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION OF
TODAY'S HEARING. WE WELCOME YOU
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR
COMMENTS YOUR QUESTIONS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR THAT'S THE WAY
YOU CAN PARTICIPATE HERE TODAY.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. GIVE US A
CALL. WE HAVE. ABOUT EIGHT.
NINE FOLKS WHO WERE IN THE
QUEUE PREPARED. TALK SO WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE TO DO IS ALL TO
SAY. GOOD MORNING IF YOU CAN
JUST GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY.
SECOND FROM. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
READY TO GO AYE HE JUST GOT THE
HIGH SIGN YES WE ARE. LET'S GO
TO OUR- FIRST. CALLER GOOD
MORNING. YOU ARE IN COMMITTEE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU IN THAT LINE
NUMBER IS EIGHTY TWO. EIGHTY
THREE LINES OPEN. HELLO GOOD GO
AHEAD GOOD MORNING YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE HUNTING CHAIRMAN
BOUGHT. OKAY GOOD MORNING
CHAMBER CHOIR GOOD MORNING SIR
BRADFORD MEMBERS MEETING I'M
I'M TRYING TO BE TRANSACTING
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BANKING
ALLIANCE EIGHTY ENDORSING
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND OVER TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY DELEGATE TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE CREATION
OF A PUBLIC BANK CALIFORNIA'S
NOW BREAKING RECORD BREAKING
DEFICIT OUR CITIES ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES OUR COMMUNITIES NEED
URGENT ECONOMIC RELIEF AND IT'S
A PUBLIC BANK WILL ENABLE US TO
LEVERAGE PUBLIC FUNDS. TO
REBUILD AND RECOVER AND ADDS
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM SAID I
HAD GIVEN A TORY- CAMPAIGN
TRAIL WE MIGHT BREAK WALL
STREET CHOKEHOLD ON STATE
FINANCED BY DEVELOPING OUR OWN
STATE BANK THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTRANSLATED SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US WERE REALLY GRATEFUL
MATTER MODERATOR. IF YOU WANT
TO GET FOLKS INTO THE QUEUE
WOULD MAKE THAT ANNOUNCEMENT
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU
WANT TO MAKE THE ANNOUNCEMENT.
THANK YOU. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
HAVE PUBLIC COM YOU MAY DO SO
BY PRESSING ONE. ZERO ONE ZERO
FOR ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. AND THE
NEXT TIME WE'LL GO TO IS NINETY
THREE. GOOD MORNING YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE. YEAH THANK YOU MY
NAME IS SUSAN HARMON I'M WITH
THE EAST BAY PUBLIC BANK-
FRIENDS OF THE EAST BAY PUBLIC
BANK. AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT-
THE IDEA OF THE STATE BANK. AND
I'D JUST LIKE TO SAY FAREWELL
TO. SENATOR MORE LOGICALLY FAN
OF WHERE THEY'RE AT WORTHY
ADVERSARY. KEEP THIS HERMAN
THINK SO MUCH HE JUST GAVE THE
THUMBS UP SO THANK YOU MS
HARMAN HAVE A WONDERFUL
THANKSGIVING AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CALLING IN TODAY
MADAME MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU THENEXT ONE
WILL BE NINETY FOUR YOU LINES
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE GOOD
MORNING. HI THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING- JENNIFER CANNER
THINKING ON BEHALF. INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG PUBLIC
SEVENTY GROUP REPRESENTING
FORTY THOUSAND CONSTITUENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M NOT SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA GREENTREE. PROBABLY
CALIFORNIA THE ACCOUNT WE
FIFTY. FIFTY VENTURA COUNTY
CLIMATE HOT IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A STATE PUBLIC BANK THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS TANNER THANK
YOU FOR CALLING AND HOPE YOU
HAVE A WONDERFUL THANKSGIVING
WE APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
TIME THAT A MODERATOR WE GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YES
THANK YOU IN THAT LINE WILL BE
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING LINE.
NINETY NINE. LAST CALL FOR LINE
NINETY NINE. MADAM CALLER
MATTER MODERATOR CAN WE PLEASE
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. HE TOLD
ME YOU LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIVE. ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS.
I'M NOT A DELEGATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS SEVENTY
MEMBER OF PUBLIC BANK LONG
BEACH AND THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
BANKING ONLINE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT A CALIFORNIA STATE
PUBLIC PLAN AT THE SYSTEMIC
SOLUTION TO A BROKEN
CREDENTIALS ARE SOME. FOR
PROFIT BANKS THAT HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE PROBLEMS IN
OUR COMMUNITY ARE NOT THE
SOLUTION WE NEED ALL THE URGENT
SOLUTIONS ANY STATE PUBLIC BANK
IT'S ONE OF THOSE CRITICAL
SOLUTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
IN TODAY WE APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE TIME OF A WONDERFUL
THANKSGIVING. MADAME MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. CAN I CRY
COMPANY HUNDRED AND SEVEN ONE
OLD. GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
MY- GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MANDALAY WITH UFCW LOCAL SEVEN
SEVENTY. I WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND
MY SINCERE THANKS AND
APPRECIATION TO CHAIRMAN
BRADFORD AND- FOR CONDUCTING
THIS HEARING IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION A REALLY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION I WANT TO PREACH SAY
THANK YOU TO ALL THE CENTERS
FOR YOUR QUESTIONS. I'VE
ENJOYED HEARING THEM AND TAKING
MANY GOOD NOTES FOR FUTURE
DISCUSSION ON BEHALF OF OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND FRONT
LINE WORKERS BUT THE U. F. C.
W. CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF A
PUBLIC BANK POSTED CALIFORNIA.
IN THIS WATER CRISIS GROCERY
AND RETAIL DRUG WORKERS ARE
STRUGGLING IN BASIC WAYS AT THE
POTENTIAL EMPLOYEES. THEY'RE
THE MOST VULNERABLE TO
CONTRACTING CO IN NINETEEN
WHICH COULD MEAN DECREASED
WAGES. EXTENDED LEAVE AND EVEN
DEATH. WELL THE STATE OF HAS
DONE MUCH TO IMPROVE THE
CONDITIONS THERE WILL BE MORE
SERIOUS NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES.
SHOULD THE INSURANCE OF THIS
PANDEMIC. STATE PUBLIC BANK
WILL CARRY OUT ITS ACTIVITIES
BY PARKING THANK WITH COMMUNITY
BANKS AND CREDIT UNIONS. AND
LEAD RESPONSIBLY TO LOCAL
COUNTIES TO INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF CREDIT IN AREAS
THAT WALL STREET BANKS ARE NOT
SERVING. ESPECIALLY.
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THIS
COULD SUPPORT GREATER ACCESS TO
HEALTHY FOODS AND UNIONIZED
GROCERY STORES IN COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE NOT HAD ACCESS AND
SOCCER THE GREATEST LOSS DURING
SPEND DEVON. THIS IS A MOMENT
OF RECKONING. WE MUST BE BOLD.
A THIRD OF THANK CREATIVE IN
OUR APPROACH FOR THE FUTURE OF
OUR STATE. CALIFORNIA IS A
LEADER AND WE ARE PROUD TO
STAND WITH A FAMILY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND CHOOSE INGREDIENTS
FOR I THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND PLEASE PASS AREN'T
HONORS SINCERE THANKS TO ALL
THE MEMBERS A U. S. E. W.
DURING THIS HOLIDAY SEASON HER
WORK ON THE FRONT LINES WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY. NOT A
MODERATOR AT LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
IN A COMPROMISE. HUNDRED EIGHT
ONE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN WIRED SHARE BRADFORD
MY NAME IS JUSTIN RATHER THAN
AND SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
WORKER OWN RECOVERY CALIFORNIA
COALITION TODAY- WE APPRECIATE
THAT DISCUSSION AND DEFINITELY
MUCH SUPPORTIVE OF THE
DISCUSSION AROUND. PUBLIC
BANKING AS IT RELATES TO ONE OF
THE END USERS AND POTENTIALLY.
BAD BEING CALIFORNIA AND THE
STATE SUPPORT AROUND WORKER ON
CONVERSION- AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
MANY OF OUR SMALL THE THIS
RADIATOR THREAD OF CLOTHING
BECAUSE OF THE SERVICE NOT ME.
AND THAT HAVE ACCELERATED DUE
TO THE PANDEMIC INDUCED
RECESSION SO WE THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MESSAGE JOINT HEARING- AND
AGAIN TAKE CARE ENGAGE
CONTINUING GETTING ON THE ISSUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL HAPPY THANKSGIVING TO YOU
BETTER. MODERATE IT'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
INTERNET FINAL BE SEVENTY. HI
AM- STEVE CAKE I AM. THE PUBLIC
BANK COME ON VALLEY WHERE GROUP
PRODUCT EXISTENCE FOR ABOUT A
YEAR- INCLUDING- ABOUT TEN
ACTIVE MEMBERS- BUT A MAILING
LIST OF SEVENTY. WE WE'VE BEEN
STUDYING THIS AND- HOW AND WHAT
TO URGE STRONG SUPPORT- FOR
THIS- PUBLIC BANKING. IN OUR
AREA- AND AS THE STATE BANK AS
WELL WE THINK YOU COULD REALLY
A SMOOTH ROAD FOR THE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL BANKS- WE ESPECIALLY
ENCOURAGE OUR SENATOR
PORTANTINO TO SUPPORT THIS
MOVEMENT THANK YOU. STEVE THANK
YOU SO MUCH HAVE A GREAT
HOLIDAY WE APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING IN THANK YOU SO. MUCH
MADAM MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND I FINAL BE ONE ONE.
GOOD MORNING AND MY OTHER YES
YOU ARE YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE WE
WELCOME YOU GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU MORNING MY NAME IS ROSE AND
WENT IN THE TURRET COUNTY. THE
FIRE INDUSTRY SAILED CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES. ARE
QUITE AN EMERGENCY IS
ESCALATING BUT TRADITIONAL
MAINSTREAM BANKS CONTINUE TO
FINANCE AN EXTRACTIVE
INDUSTRIES. THAT ARE
DEVASTATING OUR COMMUNITIES
STATEWIDE. AS WE WILL SEE FIRE
SURVIVOR AND FOUNDING MEMBER OF
THE THOUSAND OAKS CLINIC
COALITION. IT IS CLEAR TO ME
THAT. THANK YOU FOR THEM THANK
YOU FOR OUR THIRD ONLY WHERE
THEY CAN BE A BIT IN CLIMATE.
AND. AS I SAID A STRONGLY.
CALIFORNIA STATE THING THANK
YOU FOR YOUR AND HAPPY THINGS
OKAY HAVE A GREAT THANKSGIVING
LISTEN WHAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR CALLING IN TODAY WERE VERY
GRATEFUL. MADAM MODERATOR LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. OUR NEXT
FINAL COMES FROM A LINE OF-
SIXTY EIGHT. HELLO THERE MY
NAME IS RICHARD GIRLING- NUMBER
OF UNITED EDUCATORS OF SAN
FRANCISCO ANNOUNCER- IT DIDN'T
AFFECT ME THANKS FOR LISTENING
ON A CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BANKING
ONLINE- THANK YOU TICKET NUMBER
CORRECT FOR THIRTY YEARS. AND
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT I STRONG
SUPPORT PUBLIC THING. I AGREE
TODAY'S HEARING ALTHOUGH I MUST
SAY NOT OF THE CAR THE DAY OR
ONE OF THE DON'T EED TO PUT.
WHITE WHAT. I WOULD LIKE TO
DRIVE THANK YOU- CONTINUES.
WELCOME ARE BANKS THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD NOT. TO WHAT THE CODE-
JIM HAS AB HE PUBLIC FINANCIAL.
ARE CALLED THE SPARK. AND IT
WOULD BE WORTH THAT THE LEAD-
BETTY THAT THE HOW THEY MADE IT
WORK. INSTITUTIONAL WHEN YOU
SHOULD LOOK INTO THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH RICHARD WE
APPRECIATE YOU CALLING AND HAVE
A WONDERFUL HOLIDAY AND MADAME
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT CALL COMES FROM
THE LINE OF ONE NINETEEN. GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING ONE
MORNING. HI MY NAME IS THE ONE
ON HOW TO BE AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF THE STATE PUBLIC
THEM COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY DENIED
ACCESS TO CAPITAL COMPUTATIONAL
BANK. AND MORE RECENTLY ON
TOWARD THE COLOR CONTINUE TO
BEAR A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
OF THE PANDEMIC A DATE PUBLIC
BANK IS A CRITICAL STUFF
HILDING A MORE EQUITABLE
ECONOMY PRIORITIZES THE MOST
MARGINALIZED IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR CALLING IN TODAY I WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS IF YOU'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING YOU CAN CALL US
AT. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR WE HAVE OVER TWO
DOZEN FOLKS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
IN THE QUEUE AT THE MOMENT.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
MADAME MODERATOR. THANK YOU AND
I'LL BE WHAT ONE SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING. THANK GOOD MORNING ONE
SEVENTEEN WE WERE IN COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT MADAM MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
THE NEXT ONE WILL COME FROM
LINE ONE ALL FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SHARON YOU'RE DOING A
GREAT JOB RUNNING THIS MEETING
TODAY THANK YOU. JEFF CALLING
FROM SAN DIEGO- HOME TO
ASSEMBLY POWERHOUSE LEADERS
LIKE CENTERS HUESO AND ATKINS
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBERS GONZALEZ
AND GLORIA ALL OF WHOM SUPPORT
PUBLIC BANKING- MY ORGANIZATION
PUBLIC BANK SAN DIEGO OF COURSE
SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE TEN- AND
WE'RE WORKING VERY HARD TO HELP
CREATE- CALIFORNIA STATE PUBLIC
BANK. THANK YOU HEY JEFF THANKS
SO MUCH GIVE THE NEW MAYOR- OUR
VERY BEST HAPPY THANKSGIVING TO
YOU THANKS FOR CALLING IN.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE MADAM OPERATOR. THANK
YOU KNOW BE ONE NOT. TWENTY
SEVEN. YES HELLO THIS IS SHELLY
BROWNING CALLING IN FROM SANTA
ROSA AND FIRST AND FOREMOST
THEY'RE MCGUIRE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HOLDING
THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING
TODAY I GREATLY APPRECIATE IT-
I WENT FROM THE PUBLIC BANKING
SANTA ROSA AND THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC BANKING ALLIANCE. AND
I'M CALLING IN IN DONJON FAULT
THE COURT FOR A STATE PUBLIC
THANK YOU EXPERIENCE COULD HEAR
YOUR VOICE HAVE A GREAT
THANKSGIVING THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR CALLING IN LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE AND A
MODERATOR. THANK YOU THAT'D BE.
ONE SIXTEEN. HELLO M NAME IS
BONNIE PETTY I LIVE IN SANTA
ROSA AND I AM A MEMBER OF THE
NORTH BAY JOBS WITH JUSTICE AS
WELL AS THE ALLIANCE FOR A JUST
RECOVERY- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PUBLIC BANK I
REMIND TO THE SENATOR AND OTHER
SENATORS AND IN THE MEANTIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
HEARING IS THAT A GREAT HEARING
I'VE BEEN WATCHING FROM THE
BEGINNING SO. I JUST REMIND US-
WE ARE RECOVERING STILL FROM
MANY FIRES AND AS WE LOOK AT
THE FUNDS COMING IN FROM THE
PG&E SETTLEMENT I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE HOW MUCH WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO LEVERAGE THOSE
FUNDS MUCH BETTER HAD WE
ALREADY HAD A PUBLIC BANK IN
PLACE- FOR THAT AND- WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO. MISSISSIPPI I
HAVE TO SAY THAT- HER SOLUTION
OF JUST BEGGING THE BIG BANKS
TO DO MORE IS SIMPLY NOT A
SOLUTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
IN MONEY WE APPRECIATED HAPPY
THANKSGIVING TO YOU AND THANKS
FOR HANGING WITH US TODAY
THAT'S. GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
MATAMATA WRITER. THANK YOU
THAT'LL BE NOT. TWO HELLO AS
YOU DURING THE MORNING HEARING
IN MEETING OUR A URINE
COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING THE
FLOOR IS YOURS HELLO. OKAY AND
WHEN SHOWN WITH MOTHERS OUT
FRONT MOBILIZING FOR POLITICAL
CLIMATE. SONOMA COUNTY CLIMATE
ACTIVIST NETWORK THE FRIENDLY
PUBLIC BANKING SANTA ROSA AND
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BANKING
ALLIANCE. I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE PUBLIC THANK YOU I AM I'VE
BEEN A SUPPORTER THANK YOU FOR
FOUR YEARS I DO A LOT OF ON
SOCIAL MEDIA AND I'M PLANNING
TO GET AS MANY GROUPS AND
INDIVIDUALS AROUND THE BAY AREA
FROM NORTH BAY TO SOUTH BAY.
AND BEYOND INDOORS PUBLIC
BANKING I LOOK FORWARD TO
PUBLICIZING THE PUBLIC BANKING
BILL WHEN IT IS ANNOUNCED THIS
SPRING. PUBLIC TRANSIT IN DEEP
DISTRESS AND EVERY TRANSIT
AGENCY IS FACING HUGE CUTS
WHICH WHICH WILL AFFECT MANY
LOW INCOME TRANSIT RIDERS IN
BEING ABLE TO GET TO WORK AND
TO GET TO. CONSENSUAL SERVICES
OVER 30% OF TRANSIT. RIDERS ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. LET'S SEE IF.
IS EXTREME DIRE AS- OF WRITERS
BEING UP A DAY TO SOCIAL TO.
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS. PEOPLE
MAY LOSE THEIR JOBS THE REAL
RESULTS OF THIS CAN YOU MAYBE
EVEN THEIR HOUSING. WELL I
GUESS WE'LL HAVE INCREASING
DIFFICULTY IN GETTING TO THE
FINANCIAL SERVICES WE NEED A
PUBLIC THANK NOW TO PROVIDE THE
ENTIRE STATE WHICH INITIAL
FUNDING. THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS WE APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING IN TODAY HAVE A
WONDERFUL HOLIDAY THAT'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE MADAM
MODERATOR. THANK YOU HAVE COME
FROM LINE OF. TWENTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU FOR HOLDING HEARING AND I
AM TOTALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
PUBLIC THINKING CALIFORNIA IT
REALLY NECESSARY BECAUSE OF THE
BRICS CENTER FOR EXPEDIA. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF FRAUD THIRTY
HAPPENS ON WALL STREET AND WE
NEED A RADICAL SOLUTION RIGHT
NOW IN. ORDER TO CHANGE AND-
THE AND A MONEY THAT THE THAT
IS WORKING FOR THE- WE NEED A
PUBLIC THANK FOR THEM BECAUSE
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THERE
WITH WITH UNIT QUALIFY BIG.
CANDLE WHERE FOR HUGE BANK GOT
A SIX HUNDRED IN SEVENTY THREE
MILLION SETTLED FOR THE GENERAL
AND OAKLAND. GOT ABOUT FIFTEEN
MILLION- DURING THE LUNCH IN.
OFFER RATE RATE WHICH ISN'T
THOUSAND. IT'S NOT I THINK
INPUT IT INCIDENTS. AND JEFF
MORGAN BROWN EIGHT POINT TWO TO
GET FIVE IN QUEUE BOMB. IN
BASED BAND TWO HUNDRED AND FOUR
MILLION IN YEAR AT A WHILE HE
IS WHICH IS BIGGER THAN THEIR
BUREAU STREET SERVICES SPENDING
DEPARTMENT. ULTIMATELY WE NEED
TO DEVELOP A NEW WAY TO DO
BANKING THAT DOES NOT INVOLVE
WALL STREET THAT THE COURT THE
COURT TODAY I ASKED THAT THE
COURT CREDIT UNION AND THE
PUBLIC BANKING WITH THEM IS THE
ONLY WAY TO DO THAT- THE FIRST
COMMENT MADE IN THIS SESSION.
WITH ABOUT HOW THE BANK. MAY
NOT BE. THE THEY DON'T MAKE A
PROFIT I'M SORRY BUT PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT BE MAKING A PROFIT
OFF OF THE WORK OF OTHER PEOPLE
BACK. WALL STREET IS NOT THE
WAY TO DO THIS AND WE NEED A
NEW PASSWORD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR CALL STATE WE
APPRECIATE IT. HAPPY HOLIDAYS
TO YOU LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE AT MADAME
MODERATOR. THANK YOU KNOW COME
FROM ONE OF ONE TEN. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU THIS IS TOM
CALLING CALLING FROM TRANSITION
CINEMA VALLEY WHERE A GROUP OF-
ABOUT A SEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE
COMMITTED TO COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE AND ADDRESSING THE
CRISES OF RESOURCE DEPLETION
CLIMATE CHANGE AND FINANCIAL
INSTABILITY REFORM TO TWENTY
TWENTY IN TWENTY TEN SHORTLY
AFTER MORTGAGE BANKING CRISIS.
AND WE LONG SUPPORTED A PUBLIC
BANK ALTERNATIVE TO ADDRESS THE
MANY GAPS THAT EXIST IN OUR
EXISTING BANKING SYSTEM I WANT
TO THANK THE BALL LEGISLATURE
LEADERS WHO HAVE PASSED AB
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN. AND HAVE
BROUGHT US THIS FAR ON THE
STATE PUBLIC BANK HERE IN AB
THREE TEN I ACTUALLY WANT TO
SAY TO THAT I'M A BIT
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE DEFENSE
OF THE STATUS QUO BANKING
SYSTEM TODAY IN SOME OF THE
COMMENTS. I HEARD- THAT- EVEN
IF THESE HISTORICALLY LOW
INTEREST RATES THAT- WE FIND
THE PRIVATE IN UNDERWRITING
INVESTED INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS ARE STILL TOO
EXPENSIVE TO SATISFY
CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS WE SIMPLY
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FUNDING. TO
MEET ALL OF OUR NEEDS. I'M ALSO
DISAPPOINTED THE FALSE FRAMING
DUCTUS THE CDFI IS AGAINST THE
PUBLIC BANK INFRASTRUCTURE AN
EXPANDED PUBLIC BANK.
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK- WE HAVE A
PROBLEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA
PROGRESSIVE MAJORITY THAT KNOWS
THE PUBLIC BANKING IS A VIABLE
SOLUTION. AND WE LOOK TO YOU
LEGISLATORS TO FIX THIS PROBLEM
BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE ME
PERSONALLY. I VOTED AGAINST.
OPPOSITION FOURTEEN. NOT
BECAUSE I'M AGAINST STEM CELL
RESEARCH WHICH WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN BUT
SIMPLY BECAUSE WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THE
BANKING SYSTEM WHICH PAYS OUT
WAY TOO MUCH MONEY TO PRIVATE
SECTOR BANKS SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO YOU GUYS FIXING THIS PROBLEM
AND I AGAIN APPRECIATE THE THAT
WORKS GOING INTO THIS COMMITTEE
AND THIS THIS HEARING TODAY
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION MY
COMMENTS AND HAPPY THANKSGIVING
TO ALL HEY THANK YOU SO MUCH
JOHN HAVE A GREAT THANKSGIVING
WE APPRECIATE YOU CALLING IN
TODAY FROM CINEMA VALLEY THAT'S
GO TO. OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
NOT A MODERATOR. THANK YOU AND
THAT'LL COME FROM LINE A ONE
TWENTY FIVE. HI HI THIS IS A
COMMON MODEL WOULD BE- MY
FAMILY CREDIT CLUB HERE IN
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FORMATION
OF A STATE OF PUBLIC BANK. EVEN
AS I LOOK OUT MY WINDOW RIGHT
NOW I SEE DAMAGE FROM THE LAST
CREEK CALIFORNIA FIRED BY MY
HOUSE THAT WE NEED TO MOVE OUR
RESOURCES AWAY FROM- BOTTLED
FUELS. INTO GREEN ENERGY AND A
PUBLIC BANK COULD BE A STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION THANK YOU HAVE A
GREAT THANKSGIVING HEY YOU TOO
SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH JOHN
THANKS FOR CALLING IN TODAY
HAVE A GOOD ONE WE. APPRECIATE
IT THAT'S A GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU NOW COME FROM.
ONE ONE TWENTY FOUR. HI MY NAME
IS SYLVIA CHIEF OF THE POLICY
DIRECTOR OF A PAN ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK WERE
INVITED MENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION WORKING WITH ASIAN
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND WORKING FOR A JUST
TRANSITION. TO REGENERATIVE
ECONOMY WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF CONTINUING TO EXPLORE THE
STATE PUBLIC BANK AND HOW TO
SOLVE THE NEXT SET OF
CHALLENGES HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
IN THIS HEARING. I THINK WHAT
WE'VE HEARD TODAY THAT THE
SCALE OF WHAT WE NEED IS NOT
BEING MET BY THE CURRENT
OPTIONS WE NEED TO CREATE AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE WALL STREET
DOMINATED PUBLIC FINANCE SYSTEM
WE HAVE NOW WHICH HAS RESULTED.
IN DISINVESTMENT IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
UNDERINVESTMENT IN THE
SOLUTIONS W NEED TO PROMOTE
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND THE
PROPOSAL FOR STATE PUBLIC BANK
IS A CRITICAL STEP TOWARD THAT.
THANK YOU THINK SYLVIA HAPPY
THANKSGIVING TO APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING IN TODAY THAT'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ALL NOW
COME ON LINE A ONE OH ONE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS PROBABLY NOT ONE
HUNDRED ECONOMICS DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA WE IN THAT
COALITION WE HAD THREE HUNDRED
COMMUNITY THINGS ORGANIZATIONAL
MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE WHO
WORK WITH IMPACTED FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES. WELL MAYBE EVEN
THAT THAT ARE MANDATED FOR THE
PRIVATE MARKET SUCH AS FROM THE
COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT ACT IN
ORDER TO HELP THE COMMUNITY.
WE'VE BEEN TRYING PRIVATE
MARKET SOLUTIONS AND PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS FOR A LONG
TIME. 293240% I THANK YOU FOR
COLOR NOT BE CLOSE YOUR COOKING.
COMPARED SEVENTEEN PER OF WHITE
SMALL BUSINESS. A STATE THANK
MIGHT BE A PIECE OF. BUT IF
PEOPLE ENTERED INTO COMPROMISED.
AND IT. HOW ECONOMICALLY. NOW
MORE THAN EVER THANK YOU MUCH
HAPPY THANKSGIVING THEY HAVE A
THINGS THANK YOU CALLING IN FOR
YOUR COMMENTS APPRECIATE THANK
YOU MUCH THAT'S GOOD FOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE MAN HONORED-
THANK YOU AMERICA. LINE OF.
FOUR HELLO MY NAME IS TERRY AND
I'M WITH THE COUNTY ACTION TO
NETWORK AND AGREE WITH SENATOR
RAZA A BIT YOU KNOW THIS- IN A
LOT OF MONGERING A WAY WITH THE
BANK TALKING ABOUT ARE WE TO BE
ABLE TO PULL THE OFF BUT- WE
DON'T WE NEED TO PAY MILLION.
OF FOR EXECUTIVES SALARIES FOR
THE WAY THAT THE BIG BANG DO
AND ALSO. YOU KNOW YOU'RE
YOU'RE LISTENING TO THE BANG
THE BIG BANKS HAVE BEEN BAIL
OUT TO OR THREE TWO BY. DOLLARS
AND I THINK WE'LL GETTING WHOLE.
HAS A LARGER EACH. AND MOST
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD. AND WE
CAN DO THIS THE- WITH OUR- TO.
AND THE- I THOUGHT IT I DON'T
KNOW WORK. CLEARLY AND IT I
DON'T THINK IT'S LIKELY THAT.
AS OTHER HAVE- AND I ALSO THINK
IT'S VICIOUS HI. OF THAT. I
CREATE. ANYWAY I BELIEVE THAT.
MY STRONG SUPPORT A PUBLIC BANG.
AND I THINK THAT. THE CLIMATE
CRISIS AND MARK THE WE ARE ITS
ONLY GONNA REQUIRE. AND MORE ON.
AND A SPECIAL THE- COULD HAVE
THAT CURRENT IN WITH HOW. WE
REALLY NEED HELP BANG IN ORDER
TO DEAL WITH THESE EMERGENCIES
AND TO DEAL WITH THEM IN A WAY
THAT IS. FAIR AND JUST AND NOT
FOCUS ON PROFITS. THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHAREMY OPINIONS AND ALSO.
HAVE A WONDERFUL THANKSGIVING
EVERYONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TUNING IN TODAY WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE THOSE WHO
ARE HOLDING ONLINE I JUST WANNA
DO QUICK TIME CHECK SO WE HAVE
TO IN THIS HEARING AT ONE
O'CLOCK AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS
AT ONE O'CLOCK IS IT THEY HAVE
TO COME IN AND CLEAN THE
CHAMBERS BECAUSE IN WE HAVE THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. SO IT I'M
GONNA IT KEEP GOING HERE FOR
TWO MINUTES EACH PARTICIPANT UP
UNTIL TWELVE THIRTY AT TWELVE
THIRTY I LIKE TO BE A TO GO TO
ONE MINUTE PER CALLER JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THROUGH
EACH OF OUR CALLS BECAUSE WE
STILL HAVE CLOSING COMMENTS BY
SEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AS
WELL AS CHAIR BRADFORD SO LET'S
KEEP GOING TWO MINUTES EACH UP
UNTIL TWELVE THIRTY AND WE'RE
GONNA GO TO A MINUTE EACH PER
CALLER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
THROUGH EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
OUR CALLS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM YOU. AT.
844-291-6364 NOT. A MODERATOR
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT A
COMPANY A. ONE OH TWO. HI MY
NAME IS MAX WILL KESSLER AND-
SYSTEM THAT WAS IN LOS ANGELES.
WANTED TO REITERATE- A LOT OF
WHAT I'VE HEARD TODAY IN THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE ARE
SUPPORTING. THE ARGUMENTS THAT
LEVY TODAY ARE SUPPORTING A
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION THAT. IT
IS JUST NOT. AND I UNDERSTAND
THERE ARE CHALLENGES TO PUBLIC
THANK. BUT I DON'T FIND THE
SOLUTIONS ARE TO CONTINUE. TO
RELY. FOLLOWING THESE PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS AND THEIR PROFITS
WHEN THEY USE THEIR PROFITS TO
PREY UPON COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
WE SAW WELLS FARGO DO IN THE
STATE BANK ACCOUNTS SCANDAL.
AND THEIR CONTINUED IN FOSSIL
FUEL INDUSTRY WHERE YOU KNOW
AVERAGE AT- THE NEW YORK RICH.
GAS POWER PLANT YOU YEARS AGO
AND IT DAHLE THE PEOPLE MADE
ISSUES. IF YOU CAN YOU RELY ON
WHETHER OR NOT THE STATE LOS.
MAKE PROFIT AND THEN PROVIDE
MONEY TO. THE COMMUNITY ON. HE
PLANS ARE GOING TO BE A STEP HI.
THEN INSTEAD CALL. SO SHOULD
SEEM LIKE A SO. AND I AM THAT
THE PUBLIC BANKERS AND LOT OF.
BUT I THINK IT WOULD BE MORE
FOR US DISCUSS WHAT THOSE ARE
BECOMING WAS SOLUTIONS TO THEM
AS SENATOR THOSE. POST TO KIND
OF ENCOURAGING US NOT TO MEET
THOSE. ARE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME I DON'T THAT THANKSGIVING.
SHE DID THANK YOU SO MUCH AT MY-
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US AT
TODAY THINGS O YOU. THAT'S AT
GO TO OUR NEXT. MATTER MODERATE.
THANK YOU KNOW COMPLY LINE ONE
HOW. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
LAURIE NATION SANTA ROSA YOU
WILL NEVER COUNTY WHICH IS VERY
WELL REPEAT TODAY. THANK YOU
MICHAEL P. REPRESENT OF THE
CHINESE AND WE CAN FAIR WORK ON
BEHALF CULTURAL. HEARING TO
COUNTY THREE FIFTY CINEMA WHEN
THE ALLIANCE FOR JUSTICE. WHICH
IS WHAT COOLEY OF LABOR
ENVIRONMENTALLY OF GROUPS
FORMED AFTER THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FIRES THAT DEVASTATED
OUR COMMUNITY. THESE
ORGANIZATIONS STRONGLY SUPPORT
FOR NATION APART AND POLITICS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FASTER HAPPY
HOLIDAYS HEY HAVE A GREAT
THANKSGIVING THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US TODAY FOR
TUNING IN FOR YOUR COMMENTS
THANK YOU LET'S GO. TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU NOT A
COME FROM. FIFTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING LINE FIFTY SIX YEAR AND
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU- SENATE
MCGUIRE ENSURE BRADFORD- STEVE
BERTEL BELOW IN THE
TRANSPORTATION AND LAND USE
COALITION- ALSO WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR A RECOVERY- WE-
LOOK AT PUBLIC BANKING AS A WAY
TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD-
PROFIT SHOULD NOT BE THE MAIN
MOTIVATOR FOR SOME PROJECTS
AND- WE APPRECIATE YOUR HOLDING
THE HEARING TODAY TO FIGURE
OUT- WHAT THE OBSTACLES ARE TO
OVERCOME I'M SURE YOU CAN DO
THIS. IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME FOR
THIS TO TAKE EFFECT- SO. I
WOULD URGE YOU TO- MAKE
PROGRESS THIS SIX YEAR PASSED
THE BILL GIVEN TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND HOPE THE
GOVERNOR WILL SIGN IT. THANK
YOU. THE SERVER ABOUT ALWAYS
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANKS FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ON BEHALF OF TRANSIT AS
WELL HAPPY HOLIDAYS TO YOU
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE MADAM MODERATOR. THANK
YOU COME FROM. ONE ONE TWENTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS SHERRY FRIEDERICH I'M A CPA
AND ALSO THE TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR FROM THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE THANKS VERY MUCH TO
CHAIRMAN OF ACQUIRING BRADFORD
FOR HAVING THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING TODAY- I WAS ABLE TO
PARTAKE IN THE LISTEN TO MOST
OF IT- MY COMMENTS ARE RELATED
REALLY TO THE FUNDING. OF
PUBLIC BANKS- I KNOW THE
DISCUSSION HAS BEEN ON THE PMI
A FUNDS I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE OTHER ELECTED
OFFICIALS THAT HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH STATE FISCAL
MANAGEMENT THAT- THE USE OF
THOSE FINANCES FOR NEEDED
OPERATIONS AND NOT NEEDS TO
MAINTAIN LIQUIDITY- VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO NOT BE AT
RISK OF LOSS ARE. OUR SAFETY
LIQUIDITY AND THEN YIELD ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO PAY FOR ALL THOSE
NEEDED SERVICES I WANT TO
THANK- DELIVERED AND THE
PRESIDENT OF TACK TACK WHO
SPOKE VERY ELOQUENTLY ON OUR
OUR COMMENTS AND COMMENTS FROM
OUR ASSOCIATION OF FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
GOD JOHN MORLOCK HE HAS DONE A
FABULOUS JOB IN THE SENATE- AND
CONTINUES TO DO A GREAT JOB
TODAY WITH HIS COMMENTS AND I
KNOW AND WISH HIM THE BEST OF
LUCK- SHE'S REALLY HELPED. KEEP
THE STATE IS NOT PERSPECTIVE
AND SO- I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
KNOW I'M NOT SUPPORTING THOSE-PMI A FUNDS TO GO FOR PUBLIC
BANKS THANK YOU AGAIN ALL
PLEASE STAY SAFE AND HAVE A
THANK YOU HAPPY THANKSGIVING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
DAMAGE YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE IT'S
WONDERFUL TO HEAR FROM YOU AND
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE
OF ORANGE COUNTY. CENTER
MORLOCKS IS HIGH EVEN AS A
SPEAKS OF THANK YOU SO MUCH
HAPPY THANKSGIVING TO YOU AS
WELL WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU CALLED
IN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
COMMITTEE THOSE WHO ARE ON THE
LINE WE ASK YOU TO KEEP HOLDING
ON THE LINE. BECAUSE OF OUR
TIME IT IS NOW REACHED TWELVE
THIRTY WE'RE GOING TO GO TO ONE
MINUTE EACH ONE MINUTE EACH FOR
THOSE WHO ARE HOLDING ON THE
LINE THERE FIFTEEN CURRENTLY IN
THE QUEUE WE'RE GONNA ASK. FOR
ONE MINUTE PUBLIC COMMENT EACH
INDIVIDUAL THEN WE'RE GONNA GO
TO. COMMENTS FROM SAN BRADFORD
IN OF COURSE ISN'T MEMBER SOME.
NEXT CALL PLEASE MARC. THANK
YOUNG NOW COME FROM LINE.
TWELVE IT'S JAMES MCVEIGH FROM
SOME I'M REPEAT THE CINEMA
VALLEY HOUSE GROUP AND WE ARE
1100% IN FAVOR OF PUBLIC
BANKING THANK YOU AND HAVE A
HAPPY THANKSGIVING THANK YOU SO
MUCH JAMES HAVE A GREAT
THANKSGIVING WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BETTER
CONTROL LINE OF TWENTY NINE.
HELLO HEY HOW YOU DOING YEAH
THE GOOD AFTERNOON YOU'RE IN
CAMINO. THANK YOU THIS IS SUNNY
GALBRAITH I'M A TEACHER IN
CINEMA COUNTY BUT THREE FIFTY
CINEMA IN THE LINE FOR JUST
RECOVERY AND I ALSO CO CHAIR
THE SANTA ROSA JUNIOR COLLEGE
CLIMATE ACTION NIGHT END OF
SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR SUPPORTING THAT EVENT
AND MEETING WITH STUDENTS THE
SUMMER OVER THEM- WE HAD GROUPS
OF STUDENTS. ARE WORKING TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN AND EIGHTY THREE TEN AND
WE'RE THRILLED THAT YOU'RE
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT ON ALL THE
GROUPS AND PART OF IN THE
STUDENTS THE CREATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BANK- FOUR
ONE ONE OF THE REASONS TO MOVE
RESOURCES AWAY FROM BANKS THAT
CONTINUE TO FUND HEALTH WILL
KILL EXTRACTION. PROJECTS INTO
TO REALLY MOVE PROJECT MOVE
MONEY INTO OUR COMMUNITIES TO
HELP DEAL WITH THE CLIMATE
CATASTROPHE AND ECONOMIC CRISES
BROUGHT BY COBIT SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND
YOUR- WILLINGNESS TO MEET WITH
STUDENTS OVER THE SUMMER B. AS
THEM THAT WITH A HUGE THRILL
FOR THEM THANK YOU. NO THANK
YOU SO MUCH- PLEASE GIVE THEM
MY BEST I HAD AN ABSOLUTE GREAT
TIMING IS SO IMPRESSIVE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AT THE CENTER AS A
JUNIOR COLLEGE IN PARTICULAR
HARD WORK OF THE STUDENTS THANK
YOU FOR CALLING IN SUNNY IT'S
GOOD TO HEAR IF YOU HAVE A
GREAT THANKSGIVING. AT THAT'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU I'M NOT A BE ONE. NINE HI
NAME IS STEVEN DANIELS AND I AM
A STUDENT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
STUDIES AT CSU SAN MARCUS AND I
JUST WANTED TO CALL IN TO SHOW
MY SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC BANK I
THINK IT IS AN INCREDIBLE IDEA
IT IS IMPORTANT WE FIND WAYS TO
FIND THE SOLUTIONS OF TOMORROW
AND THANK YOU FOR EVERYBODY WAS
PUT IN THIS HEARING ON AND
HAPPY THANKSGIVING. THANK YOU
SO MUCH STEVEN YOU TO HAVE A
GOOD ONE WE APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING IN TODAY. LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
AMERICAN FROM LINE. TWENTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING UNTIL TO
FOLLOW THE CALIFORNIA
REINVESTMENT COALITION OUR
MEMBERS ARE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS AND PROVIDERS AND
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS AND
LENDERS- WE HAVE DONE THE
NECESSARY WORKHOLDING WALL
STREET BANKS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
DIFFERENTIAL TREATMENT ON FAST
AND AT WORST THE KIND OF
BLATANT RACISM THAT HOLDS
COMMUNITY DOWN FOR GENERATIONS.
OUR MEMBERS WERE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF BACK TO FIND IT EVEN A
QUALITY IN NINETEEN RESULT IN
FINES DECADES OF REDLINING AND
DISINVESTMENT FROM WALL STREET
BANKS ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE BIG
BANG. IN THE ONLY WAY WE SEE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION I'M COMMUNITY
COMMUNICATING. ACTUALLY HAVING
ACCESS TO CAPITAL THAT WOULD
MEET THE NEEDS AND BY COMMUNITY-
YOUR MIND IS THAT THIS IS. A
NEEDED IN DELIBERATELY CREATED
BY INTENTIONAL BUT WALKS WITH
ME THERE WILL THAT HELP THE
MOST PROGRESSIVE EIGHT WOULD
WANT TO THE LARGEST IN THE
WITHOUT BEGIN WORK OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO AND- TO
ENSURE THE AND SERVING BY
COMMUNITIES OVER. THANK YOU AND
HAPPY HAVE A GREAT ONE THANK
YOU MUCH YOU'RE WE THOSE TODAY
THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN. LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BETTER COME FROM. LINE ONE
NINE. HEY THERE MY NAME IS. THE
TECHNICIAN WHAT THE SENTENCE PA
BANK- YOU'RE YOU KNOW EXCEPT
OVER TWO BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
ONE OF THE TOP PLACES BILLING
YEAH STILL ABLE TO FIND IT TO
FIND BY. SOURCE FOR HOUSING
HOMES PUBLIC TRANSIT INTEREST
MORE- WE TALK ABOUT THE CAR
ABOUT MAKE NEVER TALK ABOUT THE
CAR TALK OF BREAKING FOOTBALL
ST OR THE LAW OF BECAUSE OF NOT
PUBLIC. THANK GOODNESS DAKOTA
HAS SENT TO POINT YEARS OF OUR
PROFITS. MOST CREDIT UNION FOR
CAP INCOME. I WAS ABLE TO BUY
THE PPP LONG PER WORKER PER
BECAUSE- SO NORTH CAN. DO CAN
DO IT WHY CALIFORNIA MIND YOU
THAT A LOT OF THE STUFF. CAL
TRYING TO FOR RIGHT ARE POPULAR.
THE PRESS THAT OUR PUBLIC POWER
NORTH BECAUSE HAS PUBLIC BANKS
I THINK WE NEED TO STOP AT THE
RADICAL LASTING. AND ACTUALLY
LOOK REMEMBER CALM. EVEN IF YOU
DON'T ABOUT ANYTHING JUSTICE
ISSUES A CARE ABOUT MAKING
MONEY PUBLIC BANKING IS THE
ISSUE JUST AN BY SAYING. PROP
AND PEOPLE ARE NOT ACTUALLY
MEASURES MUTUAL EXCLUSIVE IT'S
WHERE PEOPLE ARE THE POP AND
PUBLIC PAYING. PUBLIC BANKING
WE- PROFIT TO PEOPLE WHO
CREATED IT WE OFFER SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH THANKS
FOR IN TODAY A GREAT HOW.
THAT'S GOOD OR NOT CALLER. AND
IT'LL COME. ONE THIRTY TWO. HI
MY NAME'S IT WILL LET I'M
LIVING IN MARIN COUNTY AND I'
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT- THE CAN
STATE BANK THANK YOU FOR
CALLING THIS TODAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CHRISTOPHER HAVE A
GREAT THING APPRECIATE YOU CAN
IN GO TO OUR CALLER PLEASE.
WELCOME FROM LINE OF FIFTY
FOUR. RIGHT I'M GOOD AT AND
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING MY NAME IS TRACY
CHRISTIAN BURKE ALAMEDA COUNTY
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF OPEN
PRIVACY AND MEDIA ALLIANCE ARE
BOTH ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE STATE PUBLIC
BANK WHY DO WE NEED ONE I THINK
WE SEE A PERFECT EXAMPLE FROM
THE RECENT- PRECHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM. AS WE WILL HURT SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THAT WE DESPERATE
FOR PHONES. GET THEM. AND THE
READ FOR THAT IS THAT THE BIG
WERE TAKING OF CORE CLIENTS WE
NEED A BANK THAT WILL
PRIORITIZE THE INTERESTS OF THE
PEOPLE THANK YOU AND PLEASE TRY
TO FIND A WAY TO COME. YEAH ON
A CALIFORNIA STATE PUBLIC BANK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TRACY THANK
YOU FOR CALLING IN TODAY WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS HAPPY
THANKSGIVING TO YOU LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
AMERICAN LINE OF ONE THIRTY SIX.
HELLO. ONE THIRTY SIX THIS IS
THE TIME YOU. AS TAX COLLECTOR
ABOUT TO. CAN I JUST WANTED TO.
A AND WITH EACH OTHER PRESIDENT
OF TECH ABOUT A LOT OF OUR
BELOVED COUNTY TREASURER ON
SUPPORT GOALS THE PUBLIC THANK
AND ANOTHER THING SAID BUT YOU
MAY REMEMBER SAID WITH MONEY WE
DON'T. HI THERE. AND- WE WERE
LIKE TO BE TOLD VEHICLES TO BE
ABLE TO. POLICE THE IN THE
DISCUSSION OF OUR AT- ALAMEDA
COUNTY CHOI TO IN CAL WAS BUILT
PRODUCT THE I'D IN THE CONFINES
REGION RIGHT. SO THAT'S REAL AS
WELL AS WE CAN LOOK. TO YOU CAN
TREASURES BEGIN BECAUSE- THANKS
VERY MUCH. MY ECONOMIC
COMMUNITY INTENDED COULD
ALLOCATE STRONGLY SUPPORT
PUBLIC SPEAKING IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S REAL CLEAR THAT AS ONE OF
THE LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD WE CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER WE CAN
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO HAVE EIGHT
CALIFORNIA STATE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
HAPPY THANKSGIVING LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. AND THAT'LL
COME FROM ONE OF. FORTY ONE.
THIS IS BRAD GARRETT WITH THE
SANTA CRUZ CLIMATE ACTION
NETWORK THEN I'M ALSO WITH THE
PEOPLE FOR PUBLIC BANKING
CENTRAL COAST WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT A CALIFORNIA STATE
PUBLIC BANK- IF THE PMI IS NOT
AVAILABLE TO CREATE A BANK WE
MUST EXPLORE OTHER VIABLE
FUNDING SOURCES I PERSONALLY
WOULD SUPPORT USING PMI A BUT
OTHER CHARGES SHOULD ALSO BE
CONSIDERED. WE MUST FIND
SOLUTIONS THAT BENEFIT THE
PUBLIC INSTEAD OF DEPENDING O
WALL STREET BANKS THAT HAVE
INFLICTED SO MUCH HARM IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR ENVIRONMENT
WE ALSO SUPPORT GDF FIVE WHICH
WILL HAVE MORE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE WITH THE PUBLIC BANK
THAN WITHOUT THERE'S A PAINFUL
IRONY WHEN I HEAR TALK ABOUT OF
THE CDFI RELYING ON WALL STREET
FOR ITS FUNDING. VIDEO FIVE
NEED PUBLIC BANK- WHEN YOU TALK
OF RISK PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING
NOW THE ENVIRONMENT OR START
THERE'S ALSO SUFFERING THESE
ISSUES ILLUSTRATE PROFOUND
RISKS OF NOT HAVING A PUBLIC
BANK- SO PLEASE SUPPORT OUR
PUBLIC BANK STATE PUBLIC THANK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU YOUR
COMMENTS HAVE A GREAT
THANKSGIVING. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
COME FROM LINE. ONE FORTY
THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS SHEILA.
WITH THE LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS TO THE TEMPERANCE
KOBE AREA. WHERE A CO SPONSOR
OF AB THREE TEN AND ALSO
WORKERS SPONSORS OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE SEVEN. WE COME TO
THIS ISSUE FROM THE LANDS OF
RACIAL JUSTICE. WORKING TOWARD
A PUBLIC BANK AND AT THE STATE
PUBLIC BANK AND PUBLIC PENSION
SYSTEM THAT WILL ADVANCE ACT T
THE CAPITOL. IN RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES. WITH A FOCUS ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WE
DISCUSSED RICHARD THE
CALIFORNIA TAKEN THE FIRST STEP
TOWARDS THAT YOU SHOULD THE GUY
BANK. NOW TIME FOR THE
TECHCONNECT OUT AND PULL YOU
TRANSFORM INTO THE TO THE STATE
LEVEL INFRASTRUCTURE BANK
THERE'S BEEN MUCH DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE BANK OF NORTH DAKOTA.
ONE POINT IS THAT WHILE IT IS
MUCH SMALLER THE STATE OF NORTH
BECAUSE MUCH SMALLER THEIR BANK
IS PUNCHING FAR ABOVE ITS
WEIGHT HAVING DEPLOYED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL. TAX DOLLARS NEED TO
THE STATE'S ECONOMY PERSONAL
BUSINESS LENDING THIS IS
MULTIPLES MORE THAN WHAT WE
WERE ABLE TO DO WITH OUR I
THANK BUT ONCE YOU BECOME THE
PUBLIC THAT IT COULD YOU. THEY
COULD PLAY SIMILAR ROLE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL OF A
GREAT THANKSGIVING THAT'S GO TO
OUR. NEXT CALLER PLEASE
MINIMIZE- THANK YOU MALCOLM
LINE ONE FORTY. HI MY NAME MIKE
IN PART OF FRIENDS OF THE
CLIMATE PLAN AND ROSA SENATE
COUNTY THANK YOU CENTER FOR
HOLY THIS HEARING AND EVERYONE
WHO TESTIFIED TODAY. AND- IT'S
PRIMARILY- IF THERE'S AN IDEA
THAT TIME OF CALM THIS DEBT AND
SO FROM A KIND OF. WE JUST
EXPECT THAT HAVING A PUBLIC
BANK IN THE STATE WITH ALLOW
MORE IMAGINATIVE WAY TO BRING.
RELIEF TO COMMUNITIES LIKE
SANTA ROSA SHEPHERDS SO BADLY
AND BUYERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
EIGHT THANKS MIKE FOR CALLING
IN HAVE A GOOD THANKSGIVING.
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU COME MINE FOUR SIX.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS REYES I AM
REPRESENTING HOSPITAL VALLEY
HOUSING GROUP WHICH HAS BEEN
MEETING WEEKLY FOR THE PAST
FIVE YEARS. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PUBLIC
BANK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER RAY PRESHEAF CON AND
HAVE A GOOD THANKSGIVING THAT'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AND OUR LAST
ONE IN Q. IS FROM ONE FORTY
SEVEN. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JACKIE FIELDER I'M A CO
FOUNDER OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC THANK COALITION. THANK
YOU SENATORS FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING TODAY- PUBLIC THINK IN
THE FUTURE INACTION SUCH CLEAR
ESPECIALLY COMING FROM THE
STANDARD MAKE ANY ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. IT'S ALSO GOING TO BE
THE WAY THAT WE- BUILD OUR
STOCK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY
THE WAY THAT WE GET TO AN
ECONOMY- CARBON FREE ECONOMY.
IT'S THE WAY THAT ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES STAY AFLOAT AND THEN
BOUNCED BACK AFTER THE PANDEMIC
AND ALSO WAY TO BUILD OUR
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK
YOU ALL AND- PLEASE. FORTY B.
THREE ONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
STILL THERE YOU CALLING IN
HAPPY THINGS TO. MADAM
MODERATOR THAT'S TO LAST CALL
CALL FOR THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE A PART. VIA THE TELEPHONE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT LAST CALL
FOR THE Q. LAST CALL FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE ZERO FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY HERE COMES THE PMR AND OUR
NEXT QUESTION WILL COME FROM
ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE SEVENTEEN YEAR LINES OPEN-
DID YOU CALL NINETY THREE ONE
NINETY THREE YET YOU ARE LIABLE
AHEAD SIR WE CAN HEAR YOU YOUR%
LIVE IN COMMITTEE SIR THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. YES I WOULD LIKE TO
UP MY NAME IS STAN GOLDMAN FROM
SONOMA COUNTY. AND I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK SENATOR MORAL FOR
POINTING SOMETHING OUT- HE
CALLED TO OUR ATTENTION THAT.
FIFTY TWO TIMES OR MORE THAN
THAT LARGER THAN NORTH DAKOTA
AND SO THE CITY'S WOULDN'T BE
APPLICABLES WITH US WELL SUCH
AN ADVANTAGE NOT A DISADVANTAGE
BECAUSE NORTH DAKOTA- PUBLIC
BANKING PUTS A GREAT DEAL OF
MONEY INTO THEIR GENERAL FUND
EVERY YEAR- PUTS TWO TIME THAT
AMOUNT OF MONEY. THINGS BEING
EQUAL ENTER THE CALIFORNIA
GENERAL FUND EVERY YEAR IF WE
HAD PUBLIC BANKING HERE. COOL
COOL WE'VE WAITED. HAVE A
PRECIOUS COMMODITY OUR TAXES
AND WE GIVE THAT MONEY AWAY TO
OTHERS. TO MAKE PROFIT OUT OF
THAT WE CAN USE THAT MONEY FOR
OURSELVES THOSE PROFITS TO PAY
FOR- FINANCING IS INTEREST.
THIRTY SIX. SMALL BUSINESS
LOANS RENEWABLE ENERGY PROJECTS
DISASTER DISCOVERED A RECOVERY
AND SO FORTH SO DO I WOULD
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING YOU GUYS
CAN DO TO BRING THAT FORWARD
AND AS FAR AS BETTY. THANK
YOUNG JAMIE DIMON FOR WHICH THE-
FOR C. D. F. I MEAN ARE MOSTLY
THIS IN HERE THERE'S THAT.
STAND HE SYMMETRICAL THANK YOU
STANFORD IN AT GOOD HEAR FROM
YOU HAVE A GREAT THANKSGIVING
SIR WE YOUR WITH A TODAY LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALL PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT A COUPLE MORE.
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU HI I'M
NORMAL AND DIRECT ECONOMIC
PROGRAM FRIENDS OF THE EARTH
WHERE AN ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE ORGANIZATION
WITH OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE WERE
FOUNDED. AND OVER TWO MILLION
MEMBERS NATIONWIDE. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE STATE PUBLIC BANK.
SO MANY OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS OF SAID WE MUST DIVEST
FROM WALL STREET AND APOSS
APPEAL PROJECTS THEY SUPPORT.
WE NEED TO KEEP PUBLIC FUNDS
HERE AT THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL TO FIND SUSTAINABLE
CLIMATE RESILIENT RECOVERY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE TODAY
HAPPY THANKSGIVING THAT'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
IT'LL BE. ONE THIRTY FIVE. ONE
THIRTY FIVE. YES YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. EIGHT YES IT IS MA'AM
HEARING COMMITTEE- PLEASE
PROCEED ONE THIRTY HEY HI.
THANK FOR THE WHOLE YOUR MY Y.
ARE YOU LOOKING DISTRICT IN OUR
LIVE IN COUNTY I'M A THE FIRST
FROM THE BY YOUR MIND. HEAD WE
FOR PERSON I'VE BEEN IN YOUR
OFFICE- THE NUMBER NINE AND I
SAY I'M A LITTLE BIT OF BOTTLE
BY HI NEED OF THE HEARING AND
THE CAR. OF THE HEARING WHY
WOULDN'T ANY WAY THEY THAT
WHILE STREET BANKS ARE WORKING
AT THE DISPLACED PERSON FROM
TOP. THANK YOU AWARE OF THE
BACK THAT THE GOVERNOR CAN'T
CAN'T ANY ASK INTEL. WHAT DID
YOU I SHOCKED THE END WOULD
THINK STATE BANK WOULD BE IN
CURFEW WHAT THIS SHOULD DOING
FROM THE CORRUPTION IN THE EASY.
AND CORRUPTION IN. EIGHT EVERY.
LOOK AT HELLO. STATE TEACHERS.
MANAGE WELL. AND NOW YOU WANT
TO GET IN THE BUSINESS OF. CALL
ME CRAZY BUT I'M WOULDN'T WAIT
FIRST. WHO HAVE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU CAN GET INTO THE
BUSINESS OF BANKING HAVE YOU
BEEN. EATING LATELY THIRTY
SEVEN PEOPLE CANNOT EVEN RUN
THE DMV AND NOW WE- GO INTO.
BUT I WANT HER WOULD BE EARLIER.
WHO GAVE. TO SENATOR MORE
LOCKED HE'D BE ONLY ONE WITH
ANY IN THAT HEARING AND IT
INTERESTING EVEN ONE OF THE
ONLY BASICALLY IN THE ROOM WHAT
DO YOU THINK CAN. IN. WELL I'LL
HAVE AS THE FINAL. RECALL NEWS.
BERMAN AND MORE LOCK. YOU HAVE
THINK YOU CAN VERY OF A GREAT
ONCE THANK YOU WE HAVE A MORE
LOCKED FOR GOVERNOR FAN IN I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE FOLK ON WHAT MEMBERS IS A
IN WARNING OF THE TANDEM JUST
LIKE THE FED GOVERNMENT G. LIKE
THE FEDERAL THE STATE
GOVERNMENT REMOTE. BECAUSE
WE'RE IN THE OF THE PANDEMIC-
AND IT'S AN THAT CAN TO PROTEST
AS A HAVE THAT'S A NUMBER ONE
BUT THE IS WHY HOSTING REMOTE
HEARING STE. HAVE BEEN AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE THE GO
TO OUR NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANK
YOU THAT ARE COMPARABLE. FOUR
NINE. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
STEVE POLITICA NOT A MEMBER ALL
THANKS DIEGO CAL PUBLIC BANKING-
AT THE FORMER BANKING FOR. I
BELIEVE. HOW WALL DOSE. THAT
LAW WALL PRICE PAYING. ARE
GOING TO US OUT OF OUR- GOOD
NEWS CURRENT IN BE NOW SB THE
NEST PART. TO ADDRESS THE IN A
OTHER CHAO ARE TO ACROSS OR
EXPERIENCE LET'S NOT BE DELUDE.
HE'S PRIVATELY OWNED BANKS
THEIR PRIMARY AND OPERATING. IS
PROFIT TO SHAREHOLDERS. PRODUCT
OFTEN COME TO BE A BE A OF THIS
DAHLE FROM THE SAME. BY CAR. A
PUBLIC MAY BEGIN AND ENDS WITH
THE PUBLIC INTEREST- IT IS TO
NOTE THERE ARE PRIOR CALLER
STUDENTS. THOSE VERY SAME BIG
PUBLIC BANG THAT ARE JUST
COMMUNITY EACH DAY-
PARTNERSHIPS WITH CURRENTLY AB
HUNDREDS BLLIONS OF DOLLARS
BEHIND. OR DELAY CHAU- TO END
FEEL WE AN OFFER. MORE SO- NOT
TO SEE BALD SOLUTION THAT PUT
OUR FELLOW. NEED TO PRIORITIES
ADULT LOS. THANK YOU MATT COME
FROM THE LINE OF. ONE FIFTY
TWO. SEVEN EIGHT YES IT IS
URINE COMMITTEE MA'AM GOOD
MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON ACTUALLY
HI GOOD MORNING THANKS THANK
YOU FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING
TODAY A GEORGIA KELLY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE PRAXIS PEACE
INSTITUTE. A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION INTO NO LESS WE
HAVE BEEN HOLDING FORUMS AND
EDUCATING THE PUBLIC ABOUT
PUBLIC BANKS FOR THE PAST TEN
YEARS SO I HIGHLY ADVOCATE FOR
THEM. THE ADVANTAGES OF HAVING
A STATE PUBLIC BANK CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE FOR FUNDS FOR
RENEWABLE ENERGY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
REPAIRS I STRONGLY SUPPORT- A
DATE THE USE OF OUR TAX MONEY
TO GO TOWARD THE PEOPLE AND
BUSINESSES OF OUR STATE INSTEAD
OF TO WALL STREET BANKS. SO I
AM IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE TEN.
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THE
HEARING AGAIN AND HAPPY
THANKSGIVING TO YOU ALL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ME TO HAPPY
THANKSGIVING WE APPRECIATE. YOU
CALLING IN THAT'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU AND I'M
NOT CALLER. IS ONE FIFTY. HEY
MY NAME'S AN MEANEST AND IN ON
FROM HUMBLE KELLY CALIFORNIA IN
THE COMMUNITY MEMBER AND I CAN
SEE HOW THE LANDSCAPE IS
CHANGING HERE DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. AND I THINK WE NEED A
STATE BANK EIGHT A PUBLIC BANK
BECAUSE- OF THE SMALLER
BUSINESSES NEEDING LOW INTEREST
LOANS TO GET US THROUGH THIS
TIME THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
FOR THEIR SHUT DOWN BECAUSE-
BASICALLY RESTAURANTS AND SHOPS
AND BARS. ARE SOARED INTO THE
HEART OF OUR COMMUNITY TO HELP
SUPPORT A LOT OF. OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO ARE ARTISTS AND
MUSICIANS. WHO MEET AND GREET
PEOPLE THERE AND ARE YOU ABLE
TO MAKE A LIVING HERE IN OUR
UNIQUE COMMUNITY THAT'S REALLY
GEOGRAPHICALLY ISOLATED. AND I
CAN ALREADY SEE HOW SURVIVAL OF
THE FITTEST IT'S GOING TO BE
REALLY HARD ON A COMMUNITY
BECAUSE- THE RESTAURANTS AND
BARS THAT ARE. POPPING UP- ALL
GENES AND THAT'S NOT GOING TO
BE A SPACE THAT OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO SURVIVE AND I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND HAVE A
HAPPY HOLIDAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I HOPE ALL IS WELL IN
BEAUTIFUL HUMBOLDT COUNTY WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL- AND
HAPPY THANKSGIVING TO YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AT THAT
HAS CONCLUDED OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT SECTION OF TODAY'S
HEARING I APOLOGIZE. WERE AT
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR WE STILL HAVE
TO DO- CLOSING COMMENTS BUT WE
LIKE TO BE A TO DO IF IT WORKS
FOR FOLKS BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A
HARD OUT AT ONE PM AS WE SAID
AT THE VERY BEGINNING WE'VE GOT
TO BE ABLE TO TURN CLOSING
COMMENTS OVER. FIRST TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO A VICE
YOU'RE MORE LOCK THEN WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO CHAIRMAN
BRADFORD SO LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THAT FURTHER DO WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO AND SAY THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP YOUR HARD WORK. AND
I KNOW THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS IN THESE
CLOSING COMMENTS AS WELL. FROM
SENATORS THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
SURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IN
INDIA TIME BE AS BRIEF AS-
ENTRY DOWN MY THIRTY. CLOSE OUR-
A COUPLE OF MINUTES HERE WE GO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT BUT I
WANT TO SET THE STAGE AND THANK
A HOAX. WHO ARE ON HERE BOTH
PARTICIPANTS ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS. FOR AND THE IN A
HOUSING THOUGHTS ON THE ISSUE
THESTATE PUBLIC BANK BECAUSE
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WORKS. YOU
KNOW WE STARTED OFF WITH DOING
THIS WILL BANKS ARE THOSE A LOT
OF QUESTIONS AND ULTIMATELY WE
GOT- WE GOT FIRST IN THE NATION
TO ALLOW LOCALIST. TO SETTLE
DOUBLET BANK I WANNA MOST REST
OF LAWS WAS ABLE. TO OCCUR
BECAUSE WE HAD ROBUST.
CONVERSATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE- AND- I WANT TO
START OFF BY SAYING THAT. WHAT
WE'RE DEBATING BEFORE US IS THE
CREATION OF THE STATE PUBLIC
BANK- WE DID HAVE LEGISLATION.
LAST SESSION AND I WANT TO ECHO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WORKS
WERE WE- BUT WE DECIDED TO
CONTINUE IT- BUT LET ME ALSO
MAKE SOMETHING CLEAR THAT IAN
D. PROPOSALS THAT WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD- WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
USING A P. I AM A- FUNDS. SO
I'M JUST CORRECT THAT AND I
THINK WE'VE BEEN. PRETTY CLEAR
IF THERE WAS ANY DOUBT WHEN YOU
SAY THAT. THERE SHOULD BE SOME
OF THE TABLE GOES. ARGUMENT
SUPPORT OF THE SITE. AND THAT'S
PARTLY BECAUSE THE LEGISLATIVE.
WHERE AND WE HEARD- THE- YOU
CAN ABOUT USING THE FUNDS ARE
NOT NOT HAVING SAY THAT- WE
WILL INTO ACCOUNT. OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE ON
DURING THIS HEARING AND IT'S AN
CORPS INPUT INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT HE DID ALSO HERE-
ABOUT THE RIGOROUS PROCESS IN
THE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK THAT
WAS CREATED. IN EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN EIGHT WHICH MADE IT
A VERY SERIOUS CLLS PROPOSAL
NOTHING DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING FOR STATE
PUBLIC BANK THIS ISN'T. AN IDEA
OUT OF THIN AIR THIS IS A
SERIOUS POLICY PROPOSAL- THAT
WILL HAVE A FREE MARKET
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK THAT WILL
HELP TO PREVENT A RISK NO
DIFFERENT THAN AND THEN ANY
OTHER. BANKING ENTITY ARE
AVAILABLE AND LET'S JUST FACE
IT NEEDED THE D. CURRENT
BANKING SYSTEM IS BROKEN. WE
SEEN GREAT WORK FROM. CREDIT
UNIONS WE SEEM WORKS- TO ME
BANK- BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
IN A GREATER SCALE ALSO WE SEE.
WE SEE THE ABILITY OF THE STATE
PUBLIC BANK. DURING UP WITH
YOUR WITH A CD- ADVISE AT A
LOCAL LEVEL ARE WE SEEING. THE
POSSIBILITY ARE YOU CAN EVEN
ENVISION A SCENARIO WHERE.
AIRBAGS ALWAYS IN THE FUTURE
HOUSE- AND LEVERAGE WITH
COMMUNITY BANKS AND CREDIT
UNIONS TO DO MORE LOCAL LENDING
TO SMALL BUSINESSES AND I THINK
IT'S YOUR IT IF WE WERE TO TALK
TO SMALL BUSINESS. THERE'S A
LOT OF LACK AND A LOT OF WANT
IN TERMS OF NEEDS- THAT WEREN'T
AVAILABLE TO HIM TO BIG BANKS.
I MEAN THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE-
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY I
THINK THERE ARE BETTER USES. OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE BETTER
USES OF OUR STATE- DOLLARS.
WHEN IT COMES TO HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES WHEN IT COMES TO
HELPING- SMALL FARMERS WHEN IT
COMES TO HELPING TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. OR JUST
HELPING US OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC
OR OR EVEN DURING A NON
PANDEMIC TONS I THINK THERE'S
NEEDS TO BE A REIMAGINING. OF
HOW WE DOING ANY BANKING SYSTEM
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
THAT CONVERSATION. AS WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD I KNOW
THAT WAS A COUPLE OF THE
TREASURES WERE CLOSE BUT BUT
CERTAINLY THERE WAS TREASURES
LIKE THE ONES IN MY OWN
BACKYARD OTHER AREAS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE. OF A PUBLIC BANKS-
AND IT MAKES ABSOLUTE SENSE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS IT. MAKES
SENSE IT ABSOLUTELY MAKES SENSE.
EIGHT A BANKING SYSTEM. THAT
THAT PUTS PEOPLE'S. IN OUR
COMMUNITY NEEDS ARE SMALL
BUSINESS NEEDS ARE GOOD
CULTURAL NEEDS. BEFORE THE
NEEDS OF PROFITS AND
STAKEHOLDERS. AND I THINK THAT
WE HAVE A GOOD OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE THAT HERE. CALIFORNIA
AND WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
INCREMENTAL CHANGE TO CREATE
THAT THAT PUBLIC STATE BANK.
AND WE HAVE A GOOD RAMEWORK
FOR IT. D. I. BANK IS DONE GOOD
WORK I THINK YOU COULD DO
BETTER WORK IF IT WERE TO BE
CALIFORNIA'S. A STATE PUBLIC
BANKS. ARE AND I AND I WOULD
CHALLENGE- FOLKS WHO MAY BE. A
LITTLE BIT CAUTIOUS ABOUT
CREATING THE STATE PUBLIC BANK.
THAT THAT I'M APPRECIATIVE OF
THE REASONS WHY WE CAN'T DO IT
BUT WE IMAGINE THAT WE COULD DO
IT. AND TELL US WHAT IT IS. I
HAVE IN THE PAST TO GETTING
THERE. BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S
GREAT POTENTIAL AND HAVING. A
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- SOLE AND
PRIMARY GOAL. BESIDES BEING
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBLE BESIDES
MAKING SURE THAT PENCILS OUT
BESIDES ALL THOSE THINGS THAT
WE WOULD EXPECT FROM ANY BANK-
AND GOOD REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
TO ENSURE. THAT THAT ANY THE
CONCERNS. ARE BLOOD EITHER RISK
OR OTHERWISE THAT WE HAVE THE
BANKING SYSTEM. THAT
PRIORITIZES THE WELLBEING OF
CALIFORNIANS IN IN CALIFORNIA'S
OUR ECONOMIC SYSTEM AND I THINK
THERE'S A REAL POSSIBILITY
HERE. YOU KNOW WILL TAKE. ALL
COMMENTS ALL CONCERNS WHAT WILL
TREAT HIM BALLOT- BUT AGAIN I
WANT TO SAY TO MR- TO THE
CHAIRS BUT MISTER BRADFORD.
MISTER MCGUIRE AND THE
TREASURER AND THE CONTROLLER
AND- ALL THE ADVOCATES FOR AND
AGAINST. OTHER PARTICIPATED IN
THOSE IN BETWEEN. OUR THAT WE
WANT TO CREATE A SERIES POLICY
PROPOSAL- THAT ADDRESSES A LOT
OF THE A LOT OF WHAT'S LACKING
IN CALIFORNIA'S. A BANKING
SYSTEM AND WILL TAKE EVERY
COMMENT SERIOUS WE'RE GOING TO
WORK TOWARDS IT. UP I THINK
IT'S TIME IS COME WELL WE'VE
NOW SEEN. OUR PROPOSALS AT THE
NATIONAL. LEVEL- FROM I
PRESENTS A NEW YOUR IN
OTHERWISE I- ARE LOOKING
TOWARDS CHIU ASSIST OR SINGLE.
ON ACROSS THE- AT THINK IT'S A
NUMBER THAT. LEADS WITH THE
SOLID. OTHER HEALTH SYSTEM THIS
A STATE. BANK THAT CAN WORK- SO
THE WORK OF COMMUNITY BANKS YOU-
INCREASE AND HELPS CREATE A
SUPPORT THE WORK. OF FUTURE A
MUNICIPAL PUBLIC BANKS SO WITH
THAT IN MIND I WANT TO THANK.
ALL THE SENATORS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN SOME
PRESIDENTE- AND A LOT OF WAYS.
OTHER SENATE COMMITTEES WILL
COME TOGETHER TO HOLD A HEARING
ON AN ISSUE NOT A BILL I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THAT SO.
WE HEARD EVERYBODY VERY LOUD
AND CLEAR ABOUT P. M. EIGHTY OF-
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY SO I
JUST WANNA SAY THAT AGAIN AN
EMPHASIS- INDUSTRY JOURNALISM
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS MISTER
CHAIRS IF YOU HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ANY- I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR. YOUR ROBUST
PARTICIPATION AND- INCLUDE YOU
AND ALL OTHERS WHO HAVE BEEN ON
THIS- CALLED- MR CHU HOW WHITE
NOT GIVEN ENOUGH THANKS TO- AND
ALSO THE CONTROL IN THE
TREASURE OF ALL. MISTER
BRADFORD OF ALL PARTNERS. IN
CREATING A FRAMEWORK FOR A
CALIFORNIA STATE PUBLIC BANK-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND HI I
APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK
THINK. SIMILAR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP ENDED THIS IS
CRITICAL WE MADE A COMMITMENT
TO THE SIMILAR MEMBERS SOMEONE
OVER SANTIAGO SIMILAR TO- EARLY
IN THE FALL THAT WE WOULD.
FOLLOW UP ON THIS HEARING IT
WAS CRITICAL TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS TO. THE COALITION IS
SUPPORTING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
IS WELL I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO INNOCENT MEMBER TO
HAVE BEEN NOTHING. BUT
GENTLEMAN OF THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS COLLABORATIVE AS WELL
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THEIR
PARTNERSHIP. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF COMMITTEE WE'RE
GONNA TURN OVER THE VICE CHAIR
FOR CLOSING COMMENTS THEN WE'RE
GONNA FINISH IT UP WITH YOUR
BRADFORD. MISTER VICE CHAIR
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANTED. TO MAKE A COUPLE
OF CARS- OBSERVATIONS ONE WAS
WHAT- COMMENT I WROTE. DOWN
LISTENING TO THE PUBLIC.
PROPERTY SHOULD NOT BE THE MAIN.
YET THAT'S THEM THE FREEMEN
UNDERPINNING. A RISK TAKER DO
SO FOR PROP. AND PAY AND TAX
ACCORDINGLY. AND I'M CONCERNED-
AS A LEAD. THAT THE STATE HAS A
STYLE DRAFT THAT THE GOVERNMENT
DOES NOT HAVE TO. TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WOULD ADDRESS A
PERCEIVED NEED AND SO WE SHOULD
PROCEED WITH CAUTION. IF IT
BANKS ARE VILLAINS WHICH HAS
BEEN STATED A FEW TIMES THEN
REGULATORS WHICH ARE GOVERNMENT
ARM. MAY BE A PART OF THE
PROBLEM MAYBE THAT NEEDS TO BE
RE EVALUATED. SO MY- FAREWELL
RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE THAT.
THE STATE CAPITOL SHOULD STICK
TO THE CORE BUSINESS OF
GOVERNMENT. WITH THAT MISTER JR.
CALIFORNIA HAS A GLORIOUS
HISTORY OF BANKING. A HARRIS
NEWMARK OF. STORE OWNER IN LOS
ANGELES- WE HAD THE ONLY SAFE
IN TOWN YOU IMPACT THE
TREASURE TAX COLLECTOR FOR L.
A. COUNTY USED IS SAFE- AND HIS
NEPHEW CASPER CONE WOULD BE THE
SECURITY SYSTEM- HE SLEPT ON
THE FIRST FLOOR OF THE STORE
AND WATCH DISABLED I. HUNG BUT
HE WOULD FOUNDER BANK HIMSELF
WE KNOW IT TODAY IS UNION BANK
N. I'D SAY IT'S W. HELLMAN- A
WONDERFUL LOS ANGELES IMMIGRANT
IS WELL FOUNDED FARMERS AND
MERCHANTS BANK THE FIRST
ORIGINAL AND THEN HE WENT OFF
TO GO TO SAN FRANCISCO TO BE
THE PRESIDENT OF WELLS FARGO AT
THAT TIME IN THE EIGHTIES LATE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS OF WE HAVE A
GLORIOUS HISTORY AND AS A
CALIFORNIA HISTORY BUFF I JUST
WANT TO. JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR SIX AMAZING YEARS OF
BEING ABLE TO SERVE IN THE
CAPITAL OF CALIFORNIA THIS IS
BEEN A THRILL AND IT'S BEEN AN
HONOR TO WORK WITH EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SEVERAL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- SIR I KNOW IT IS NOT DONE
WE ARE GRATEFUL GRATEFUL TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH YOU SIR HAPPY THANKSGIVING
TO YOU AND YOUR FAMILY. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORK WITH YOU
HERE IN THE MONTHS AND YEARS TO
COME. THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
VERY GRATEFUL SIR AT THE TURN
IT OVER TO OUR PARTNER IN THIS
INITIATIVE. CENTER BRADFORD WE
SO APPRECIATE WORKING WITH YOU
EACH ANDEVERY DAY MISTER CHAIR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN WATER AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORT IN PUTTING THE
SHARING TOGETHER- DURING
HEARING OF GOVERNANCE. AND
FINANCE AND- BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS I THINK
IF THERE'S ONE TAKEAWAY. WILL
LEAVE WITH TODAY'S. THAT THERE
IS A NEED. THAT IS CLEARLY BEEN
ARTICULATED THAT THERE IS A
NEED THE ONLY ISSUE IS. WHAT
METHOD AND HOW DO WE GO ABOUT.
FILLING THAT NEED OR SERVING
THAT NEED. BUT THE NEW CLEARLY
EXIST. AND I TO HAVE CONCERNED
JAZZ TO THE ROLE THAT THE STATE
CONTINUES TO PLAY AND AREAS
THAT. SHOULD BE HANDLED BY OUR-
YOU KNOW PRIVATE ENTITIES BUT
MANY OF OUR PRIVATE ENTITIES
ARE FAILING US AND THEN THAT'S
WHY THE GOVERNMENT HOUSE TO
FILL THE LARGER THE GAP AND
STEP IN WHEN OUR PRIVATE
INDUSTRIES DON'T DO THEIR PART-
HI. HOPE THAT OUR BANKS ARE
LISTENING- AND I IN HERE THAT
THERE IS A LARGE POPULATION
THAT IS NOT BEING SERVED THERE
EITHER UNBANKED OR UNDERBANKED
AND WE HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS
AGAIN BECAUSE THERE IS A
POPULATION OUT THERE THAT NEED
TO RESOURCES THAT THEY CAN
ACCESS TO. TRADITIONAL CHANNELS
AND- WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY T
SERVE THAT POPULATION-
REGARDLESS OF WHO THEY ARE AND
NOW THERE IS A NEED AND I DID A
BILL A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO-
TRYING TO CREATE A BANKING
DISTRICTS AS TERMS OF THE WHAT
THEY WERE DOING IN NEW YORK.
BECAUSE AGAIN WE SAW THE
RIFTING THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT HAVE NO BANK
ACCOUNT AND- AGAIN SO. WELL
IT'S TO A PUBLIC BANKING
SYSTEM. WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
THE AYE BANK WHETHER IT'S FROM
CEDIA ALFIE'S- I THINK THE
STATE DOES HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY
HERE. AND I THINK WE'VE- HEARD
THE MARCHING ORDERS FROM MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND WE WANT TO
THANK ALL THE PANELISTS FOR
THEIR GREAT INFORMATION OUR
TREASURE OUR CONTROLLER WHO.
RAISED A LOT OF CONCERNS BUT
ALSO PROVIDED A LOT OF GOOD
SUGGESTIONS AS TO HOW WE
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE- BUT I THINK
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S STILL MUCH
WORK TO BE DONE IN THIS AREA I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR MORE LOT FOR. HIS
EXPERTISE- THROUGHOUT HIS
TENURE HERE IN THIS SENATE AND
I WILL HEED HIS ADVICE- CLEARLY
AS IT RELATES TO. DEALING WITH
FINANCES BECAUSE I'M NOT A CPA
SO I HAVE TO RESPECT THOSE
FOLKS WHO HAVE EARNED ELEVEN
WAS A TAX ASSESSOR AND A
CONTROLLER SO- COUNTY.
ASSESSOR'S SILVA- THE HE SPEAKS
FROM EXPERIENCE AND FROM REAL
LIFE AND MANY TIMES WE AND
ENDING GOVERNMENT WANT TO BE
EXPERTS IN ALL AREAS AND WE
HAVE TO RESPECT THOSE WHO- I
HAVE THAT EXPERTISE SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND AGAIN-
GERMAN MCGUIRE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP HERE- ASSEMBLY
IN- THIS HEARING TODAY AND ALL
MY COLLEAGUES TO WEATHER HERE
IN PERSON OR REMOTELY FOR YOUR
INPUT AND YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND I. HAVE NO DOUBT AS WE
START THE NEW YEAR THIS WILL BE
ONE OF THE TOPICS- THAT WILL GO
FORWARD AND WE SHOULD ROLL UP
OUR SLEEVES AND FINDA WAY TO
ADDRESS. IT SO THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK SO
MUCH- MISTER CHAIR CHAIRMAN FOR
AT WE ARE SO APPRECIATIVE HUMAN
BRADFORD FROM THE BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
COMMITTEE. OUR PARTNER IN THIS
HEARING THAT WE COULD NOT DO IT
WITHOUT YOU SIR THANK YOU THAT
LAYS IN GERMAN OF COMMITTEE WE
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT LAST MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS FOR. TAKING THE TIME
IN YOUR BUSY SCHEDULES ON THIS
CRITICAL WEEK ONE AT EIGHT
KNOWLEDGE AYE MR CANAL THE
CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE FOR ALL OF HIS HARD
WORK. ON THIS- HEARING TWO DAYS
WELL AS MISS NEW ALL IS WELL
THANK YOU BOTH DO YOU HAVE FOR
THE PARTNERSHIP FROM. ALSO
BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE. TO BOTH TEAMS FOR
COMING TOGETHER TO BE ABLE TO
GET TODAY'S JOB DONE I THINK
THE BOTTOM LINE FOR US IS THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT DESERVES OUR
ATTENTION. IN THE NECESSARY
HARD WORK TO WRESTLE AT WITH
THE COMPLEXITIES THAT IT EXISTS
KNOW THAT THERE IS MUCH MORE
WORK TO COME HERE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ON BEHALF OF BOTH
COMMITTEES THE SENATE
COMMITTEES AND GOVERNMENTS IN
FINANCE AND BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS WE HOPE
YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL
THANKSGIVING STAY SAFE- AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU HERE. IN THE NEW YEAR
LACING GENTLEMEN THIS JOINT.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS NOW
ADJOURNED.